u
didn't go for the over one
now I did it yesterday
thank. I will thank you
both for joining me- we
have got a nother. Day
today- full of dead
interviews good stuff like
rainbow six extraction
coming up in a couple of
minutes- Dave you spoke to-
spend from Larian about
Golden State three. Was it
we will be sharing the Xbox
extended showcase because
just one showcase. Isn't
enough I it's gonna be
hosted by our friend
parris lilly and there are
going to be deep dives in
and updates on games like.
Forza horizon 5
I don't know maybe. As
that's that's one thing
that I'm I'm I'm really
looking forward to and then
we have a couple of trailer
blocks and India in there
there's a few trailer so
I'm excited to see we've
got. You know a unique
explosives trailer is so
one of them is Chinatown
detective agency which I'm
really really excited to
check out- and then there's
a bunch in another trailer
slot especially- no
personal bravery is 1 eyes
caught my eye- yes and then
the influence around table
I'm on they are on- the
show at. The guests that
we've caught include. But.
Zero NuVasive video games
no bicycle michael highgam.
Legend and our very own
Jeff this not kill- bacula-
so that's going to be
that's gonna be fun you
need to do some of the-
yeah yeah definitely please.
All right coming up next- I
mean we've got- Jordan's
interview with the rainbow
six extraction team now
Dave are you excited for
extraction formally
quarantine known as excited
yeah for sure I'm a lapsed
rainbow six siege plaza and
I sort of fell off the
wagon when it was getting
it's way to say the I fell
off the wagon for Amos six
is gonna be silly for me
but now that I ended up
with all that extra
terrestrial stuff I'm like
yeah no back on board now.
This is this is right up my
street all of a sudden but
saw them dialing back the
operator is and taking
another stab at like a
different direction I'm I'm
very careful. Yeah I'm
intrigued to see more of
this one I really enjoyed
the presentation they had
at the use of forward last
weekend- so without further
ado here's Jordan speaking
the creative director. On
rainbow six extraction.
September one I'm
jordan ramee and I'm joined
by Patrick the tag creative
director for rainbow six I
was about to say seat
rainbow six extraction
thank you for joining me
today. It's a pleasure. So
you could tell I I'm I've
been playing seats like
since day one I put in a
lot of hours so and I'm
like I'm really excited to
talk about extraction with
you because I'm- new.
During the six game but
like if I accidentally say
like see each one I'm
supposed to be saying
extraction please just.
Bear with me all. Right no
problem- I'm doing I did it
myself a few times. Okay
that that makes that makes
me feel so much better. So
now obviously like
extractions shares some DNA
with seats like that's
probably why sometimes I
get a little mixed up in my
mind I kind of want to pick
your brain about that
specifically so starting
off- rainbow six siege has.
A lot of operators at
launch with just a few but
now there's just this.
Massive roster of different
characters the people able
to choose from so how did
you pick which ones would
make the job from seats to
extraction by like you said
the- you. Amount of
operators available- in C.
chore for us it was very-
very fun- and also
challenging to take. A look
at the roster and decide
which one we would bring
with us- in- in extraction.
I would say there's too
many too many- points that
we took. For sure- the
gameplay aspect of each
operator some of our
readers are- a best fit for
IPV experience- so we pick
those operators but we
also- chose a few operators
eater because we knew that
they were really loved. By
the community and in some
cases I would even go as
far as to say. We pick some
of the operators that maybe
didn't receive as much love
as a- as we would have
liked as in siege but- we
think that they can shine-
in the- context like
extractions as it was one
of those things that- Erin
who. I can't so I checked
out- extraction ahead he
came back from the preview
like my first question for
him was like it's a bonnet
still there. Is My Girl
still there my main. The
curly so seeds and
extraction are these two
different games so how does
in game progress work an
extraction does it work off
of seat rescue run locks
are not writers and CJ
Levin lock them an
extraction is that a
totally different process
to the to game speed into
each other. How does that
work obviously both games
are- built on the same
foundations but they're two
different games it's
really- extraction is a
standalone game. With its
own- eco system- so there's
no direct link in terms of
progression. Between
extraction and see what you
do an extraction you will
get the game inside
extraction. I'm gonna have
to probably unlock upon
again is what you're saying.
Probably. Well I'll I'll do
it I'll put in the hours
I'll get my girl back. And
I guess kind of like almost
jumping off of that why the
decision to make that clean
break away from seed as
opposed to just bringing
outbreak back as like a
more. Permanent mode like
you've decided to now go
and it's completely
different T. V. direction
with a separate game was
the reasoning behind that.
Adeoye said there's a to-
to different elements that
there. That brought us to
this place- first off is
the outbreak event like you
know a few years ago there
was an event clans siege.
Where it was a P. V. Evan
that lasted three weeks-
the reception was very good
at a community really-
loved it. And on the other
side of the- Ubisoft
Montreal we're- big studios
there's a lot of different
projects going on and their
walls always just said
discussions about. Doing a
PVC game- so with it was
like a bit like the stars
were aligned. To look at
okay- could we take- the
foundation of siege and
come up with a standalone
game- to really push the
envelope in terms of a- a
real that tactical
coworking. And that's what
we did and now that
extraction is coming out as
this completely separate
game will seizures like
future updates influenced
extraction like if- new
operator is coming to see
just there a possibility
that it. Comes to
extraction are the other
two games kind of like well
they divert and go down. To
completely separate paths.
It's too soon to- the only
thing- I can say at this
point go and that you into
that it- in the beginning-
when the siege- came. Onto
the market it started with
a limited amount of
operators and it grew a lot
from there- so I can not
tell a more at this time-
but we have certainly have
different plans already in
place- Ford in very near
future. Tease tease you
have my mind racing at the
possibility of maybe.
Getting like brand new
operators and extraction
possibly even unique
operators I- I know you're
limited I know that you
can't speak to it I. Will
have to do an IRA is what's
on the line. The their
finger over the button it's
like we'll cancel the
interview right here right
now don't test us. But
let's let's talk story- a
little bit like so what is
the goal of that team
rainbows trying to
accomplish and extraction-
so in terms of the context-
three years ago they were-
you preachers were facing-
and I'll break. And at the
time the thought that they
dealt. With the trip and it
was over- an extraction-
they will very quickly and
very abruptly realized that
the trip is not only not
over. But it involves it's
not the same trip anymore
and- and a bit like a like
a the situation- worldwide
situation that we lived in
the last. Year they don't
know much about this new
truck- so as- an operator
you are going incursion to
go there and not
necessarily to fight or to
kill- the enemy but really
to go and gather as much
knowledge as you can. On
the add. This unknown
tripped. And that way- the
rear team to react
scientific can analyze it.
And it gives you better to-
fight and- 5 district S. A.
N. how exactly will
extraction tell its stories
it just the traditional cut
scenes that like
environmental world
building story telling
people to find clues during
the levels what's the
what's the deal yeah I
would say it's a mix of a
different things- for sure
at the core of the game-
once again it's a tactical-
pull up shooter so we
didn't want to put. Too
much- constrained and to
force the players to listen
to very long and cut scenes
we know some players love
it- some players have less-
interest for that so we
made sure to yes there's
going to be a few cut
scenes- you'll- you'll have
a lot of. Enter with- the
handlers of the- the people
that stayed behind and that
gives you Intel about
what's going on. In souls
who about what you should
do or not. And we also have
what we call the codex at
which is basically all the
knowledge that you will
gather- while doing the
objectives. Will go into
context so for the players
that are very interested in
understanding a bit more
about the lower in the
mysteries. Of the trips the
parasite at where it's
coming from what it once-
it's will. All be stored in
the critics. And like you
and did we have a bunch of-
Easter eggs- it in the
inside the different maps.
So you might have the time.
To find some all the way be
careful the. Game is quite
challenging school. It's
easy to get it going to be-
mix of man I know that
there's probably like a
secret in here that I
really want to find at the
same time- my friend is
dying I need to come back.
And say that. Exactly and-
if. They let them. Few days
ago- I had to. Questions I
like that- and I was not Mr
Lee- aware of all the this
is the day Easter egg that
we're into and the maps so
ask around and I ended up.
Having to go to a full. The
full list and I was blown
away because I've been
playing a game for quite
awhile now and I would say
I phone maybe 10% of them.
The ninety under percent I
was not even aware it
wasn't the game and some of
them are quite impressive
okay cool cool like as as
an assignment you are not
watching anymore just like
past me the list. We can.
Lower stakes stuff like
that after it. Look at it
like a I like to see every
minute as its price so
let's talk. As a so in your
own experience- playing
extraction like you
mentioned already that
there's like it's still a
bit of- tactical experience
but how does it if in any
way like compared to. Seats
like is it the same like.
Really tactical experiences
in a bit more arcady does
it plays pretty much
exactly the same what's the
comparison. I don't it
doesn't play out all the
same- just the nature of it
having- only five opponents
but 5 opponents that are
you in front of you is not
the same as- as being in a
PC environment. But I would
say that the best me. To
the biggest differences if
you compare- extraction to.
What I would call- under-
run N. gun. Or shooter I'm
there this is certainly
something we didn't want to
do- there's great games-
that the completion but on
our side it was really. A
matter of making sure that
you feel like you're a swat
team. And your for sure
you're outnumbered but if
you go guns blazing- you
won't have the level of
success that you might
think you could have- it's
really a matter of
surprising the enemy- being
ready to retreat quickly.
If things goes- but feels
badly- and not it's- go in
and then trench war against
the enemy because it's not
going to be a recipe. For
success for sure. And could
some theoretical. Pick this
game up. Tried to play
through it completely on
their own like is there an
offline version of this
gamer is this like. Now you
should probably find some
friends online to play with.
I would say- for sure you
can play the game from a to
Z. and single player. And
it's very interesting it's
the same game- it's not
something different to some
of the different mode is
the same game- but that
there. The feel and the-
head of the tension is not
the same because when you
play alone- you are much
more in control of your
city because there's no
one. Making mistakes at
apart from you that but at
the same time- if things go
badly- it's going to be
much tougher- but we have.
Today gamer at its core
when we started working on
the game right from the get
go we wanted to make a call
up getting. Where tree
players would help each
other to achieve the best
level of success and- and
at the same time allowing
figuratively alone or with
a friend- so that. Because
a on my side of the snap
ins often I play with my
friends. Every week but
there's always one of them
that is linked- so that we
can still play and it's the
same like I said it's not
different gamer so it's the
same progression. So you
can still- continued to
play and the progress that
you make playing alone will
translate- in Europe.
Players 1 and vice versa.
Well unfortunately that's
kind of all the times that
we have the- thank you
again Patrick it was
awesome to talk to you
about extraction I'm very
proud of myself calling it.
Extraction for this entire
and- mistakenly referring
to it as the- originally I
thought that I would. For
those of you watching at
home remember stay safe out
there and for more on
rainbow six siege Rambus
extraction and play for all
content stay tuned to
GameSpot. It was a
fascinating look at rainbow
six extraction which I did
not know how to any single
player component or a known
online component I'm
interested in checking that
out as well Dave you
mentioned that you are into
it did anything in that
stick out to you. As as a
big reason to come back to
rainbow six. Yeah just the
for me ability to play a- I
feel like you get a closer
knit group of people
playing it together. When
like to be brutally honest.
Normal siege may my friend
Sally. This feels like it's
going to be something you
can cooperate a bit more
with and I think it's
beautiful the sledge's
hammer still has a place
it's like the most useful
tool news game despite a-
despite its simplicity.
Yeah let's see here- forget
in an above extraction time.
I definitely want to give
it a go I'm really bad at
just regular rainbow six
siege I mean I can barely
I'm also kind of nervous
because I feel like there's
so many different operates
is now not going to keep
track of everyone and what
they do also the fact that
I keep calling that one
guys at. Lionel it's I know
that's nice name for some
reason that's what I call
and I'm like that's my- fun
C. H. as- as people. Say I
don't want to be doing bad
chuckles you know because I
kind I'm not up to speed
on. Lauren will be operated
but I am intrigued because
I'd like we talk about this
at length how much we want
to find a new game. So
whether that is extraction
or back for blood then Hey
I'm I'm open to it. We call
we call cigna magneto in in
overwatch I think we'll
figure out. Anyways I'm
next up we have any
interview with spend from
Larian talking about
Baldur's gate E3 which was
released in early access a
little while ago but has
been gain updates interview
for this strikingly
handsome I think you'll be
floored by him when will be
nice. BAndai check out
ladies singles. Enjoy blush
on life live stream click
to have it. Defensible K.
three myself included are
hungry for more news so I'm
going to try and roll high-
my persuasion checks and
get some information out of
Lawrence and spending guess
spend. How you doing I.
Very fine so how would you
describe the current state
of Baldur's gate three-
Everest every time we're
silence that usually means
we're busy with something.
So we're busy with
something. At stake limit
lower than expected. And
so. The next update this is
around the corner. And I'm
gonna give you the exact
date because of the weather
would. Keep bad but we're
trying to push it out. As
so. It's an update that
phone was a little. Getting
so it's a more focused on
futures on that's- add its
goal you. And I. You will
receive certain dresses at
that would be reading
credit reports and scores
asset that's pretty much
what's going on. The last
major update was back in
February of this year with
the true to being at it was
the team learned since then
so there's obviously we are
working on what's in there
yeah we're also working on
the rest of the game trying
to get it finished. And she
some points. And we're
learning from there's-
onboarding inspection so we
need to work harder on the
onboarding so we're doing a
lot of stuff as someone who
will actually be in the
next update also add to
that role there's into what
is it like to label doesn't
fall to treat those kind of
things so as not just a
story also read. The whole
this results do it in by
the time you will see the
dentist came you will see
everything that we've done
and that direction. I
understand. Do you think
about it but cool stuff so
does our the- F. that
making better. Comments a
work whose point for and
are getting feedback
that's- certain players are
not finding what they're
looking for and so we're
trying to work on that.
Trying stuff out liberation.
As things that work don't
work and so some of them
are also coming and we're
we're adding. Some of the
problem is that the
technical system certain
things don't translate
welcome video game- so this
is a bit that we are yeah
we're we're working on all
right east Xbox tryouts and
so. They're not far off
into the future also for us
to reset. So based on this
are you making big changes
to systems that are already
in the game we are
actually- we- you can
certainly expect certain
things to be turned around
I think it's necessary she-
mocks finding themselves in
their- biggest problem we
have right now. You know
the players that. On the
process and they don't have
enough things to do a state
program that has to certain
extent limitations be gamer.
When you're playing at the
table you can come up with
crazy ideas or your DM can
help you figure out crazy
ideas things that are
beyond which your actions.
As and so putting again. In
the- system so we want
everything that goes in
there is a system yeah it's
not so easy as so- but it's
something that we're
working on. Example of a
system that does work well
at the very least losses
actually better for the
many process would be
shopping. Right trolling is
also something that works
well the system you can
Chokri much everything that
you can see if you're
throwing off. It's a drop
as those things work well
in the men's the actually
M. choices that. Meet also
specially in the beginning
of the game because that's
where I work problem lies
and especially beginning
at. The more things to do
and we find. That a lot of
players coming here and.
The also they've played
originals. Adam find same
type of game back they want
to be able to do more
things than would expect.
Then you can do in indie.
And so we trying to out
some. This is not a
business of the Indy. The 5
across is the door. So at
the data it is used. You
to. At a result gives you
limited things. From the
get go. To work with. Well
it all just a literal. And
like this with what's-
expected able to do things
on. And so we to he said
this is not. Add but and it
doesn't mean that people
who really stuff and so we
have to figure out ways of
communicating that's
because that's why I
mentioned on boarding
house. There's a bunch of
things that you can
actually do but I don't
necessarily. A little
better user experience. Six
US in terms of content
being added to the game can
you give us any hints
whatsoever to what you're
working on- yes it's going
to be more expensive than
any of the things that
we've done so far as so
there's going to be things
that people expect that
maybe not necessarily part
of the next update and I
are going to be coming down
the line. And it takes a
little time to make because
we are getting further and
further. So we have much
more. Things that we have
to take into account that
stuff as so it's a bit
slower but we do have
things that are being which
I think will. Well you're
very welcome once we're
going to restart as so at a
little bit of space is
going to be necessary
there- it is lower. Than it
used to be as- see like
everybody else I've been
affected by it I predict
prices. And so it's just a
little work don't miss a
lot of stuff. And when it's
all going to land it's
going to. Make gamer. If
you keep up with the pride
of each update being being
the last you're gonna hit
critical mass of what you
compare- some point surely.
That's when we'll release
right at. That's the I mean
like. We are really trying
to. By next year. I mean
something this year for
sure and we're we're
working very hard. Getting
us in there but it's a very
big Gaming deserves to have.
And then each every single
feature. There are features
that you're going to see
and then the next thing he
didn't expect that you say
why are. Anyone who played
you'll start understanding-
this is quite. Or maybe
you'll find something.
Later I don't think you
really a lot of time to.
Features but it's your
truth you wear it for me
to. Community so we already
have. Additional rounds of
feedback so that we read.
When I guess there's hands
we- when we get to see
better. It's good. And if
it's- something that we.
Overlook we can still react
with. There saying. Yeah
thanks. That the only I can
say it's like a- but a long
that's really good good for
each. So all of both skate
three leaving any access a
full release is twenty
twenty just ballpark what
you're aiming for. And we
would be happy if we can
manage to release its next
year I mean like we're
aiming for it's- it's no
guarantees and so we're
we're definitely. Okay we
took a big set and
everything that was related
to most structure and- I
have always acting and I
during the crisis so that
St time also use working
together as far. But now-
as well as getting in a
better place and we are
starting to pick up speed
together. And so- what was
the level of work like it's
not as if we're we're done
yet since that I'm-
speaking on why I seem is a
very long to do list it
comes builds gave three.
Last time we spoke we
didn't have the new
generation of consoles your
hand is bringing both okay
three two year Xbox series
acts and pass 5 some think
the you're working towards
you know after all the
twenty. I've got right if.
You throw it I can grab it
right now. Thank you again.
Does not has right now.
Yeah guidance Akon Akon
rewrote anything I've got
I've got like a plus two to
persuasions I help and okay
I wish you had our next
update in your hands
already in my- so the fans
missing you in Ijoma. The
new usually bust one out
for big things like a panel
from hell. Is that a panel
from how three in the
works. Yeah I'm actually
dying. And it's thirty
three degrees Celsius over
here so I guess that's when
states aren't I don't know
what and so yeah I mean
like there's going to be at
some point- so- it's a-
yeah. The fact that we have
for that 1 are very versed.
Fast so and I. Take away
alone this is like we are
it's not responding. Thank
we're trying to focus on
finishing stuff and so that
this ticket comes with some
silence which is not
necessarily what community
wants to hear. Abbott is
the best way of doing
things. The difference
between divinity original
sin two and the access and
then for release was. Math
is that sort of gonna be
the same vibe when it comes
to bowl to skate three's
eventual release is going
to be well it's different
from what we've played now
as they can be giant leaps
forward that we can. Feel
as players. Yes and so I
think there's two quantum
jumps that are gonna be
KCG. First one is people
that started up when they
got RT access from day one.
And so when they'll see it
that's released it will be
very surprised. Because
there's so much stuff that
we'll have to dramatically
reduce. Your energy access
we're also keeping surprise
for the ending I for the
reset. Itself so it will be.
I that at the start and
then the- welcome but each
as we do have a bunch of
course you see that we
absolutely. As so and- then
this I saw the second one
should you the final update-
his first. Step certainly
the intention- for which to
do. But that means the
difference between the
three and- is that this
game is possibly more Nick
and it is and every last
much more. And everything
that it does covers- so. It
altogether actually hello
releasing it- I will
already happy if it didn't
have to do that welcome to
the goal it's going to be.
Something very to the drag
and some the das to have
was that the master mode
you've already spoken about
it much in the past is that
something you can talk on
now. No because we honestly
we don't have a development
everybody else is that
question but we are so
focused on making the game
itself and it's such a
beast hello that we just
the company has more than
tripled in size to make the
G. three and even that
works if you look at a
recruit you see the spend
your jobs openings and this
is just because we- so. As
a Gaming and every single
assets is being delivered
at such a high level of
quality and. It's- yeah we
just don't have to this
point it's a- obviously
this would be a with
Ruppert from it right and
but- yeah for a three out
is getting go getting
serviced as so that when
you in when you replace or
when you to your about it
you're eight my attention
complete and you're going
to say yes Corsetti you
make different decisions
acid that's really what
we're trying to build. And
that's- the quite different.
Or this is the dungeon
master mode something you
might look at doing pose
release so I almost.
Everybody right now is.
Just getting the G. three
dot and it seems like. The
fact that it's still a long
uncertain Verizon's tells
you how much work still has
and if you see how we've
grown as people are
working. On it they also
tells you exactly how. Much
it is- ad so the staff. If
this were. Virgil saying it
was already michael highgam
we made it worse also
correct with the most of
the- and so it's just a
yeah. And it's not that
it's that much longer. It
is just verifications the
intensity with which each-
minute of gameplay is being
worked on so. And emissions
of the team they're super
of arms director so much
longer into it to try to.
Add I you know I like.
Right and- when you play D.
so I was sort of on the
beach because the beginning
of mac one once you get to
the door. And that means on
getting better you know
especially. When you look
at the early access the
they and I that means much
better I know it's coming
like that Stephanie so much
but so let's just each this
actually makes. Thank you
for. Depending on the
choice you made. And then
the door which has in.
Those things in you you
were you look at it you
want why am they do all the
effort of putting- and
that's yeah I mean it makes
and there's a letter to the
US for of. There when did
you see what it is. You
said okay the ramifications
this are. Large at so yes
they are large so. Would it
through the entire. Said
and when you play them
that's you just you say Hey
I'm that somebody enough
about we keep our costs PC
to finishing of the all
there. Just me and your
people the world see this
we're happy to somebody
cared about. And that's
that's the world we invents
the effort. And to. Think
that you will see. And when
you see them you're happy
that's- looking. The people
going to go back to this to
be now try to. Figure what
exactly- teasing here. The
figure I'll figure it out.
Maybe on the next time we
checked you out yeah well
you remember when you said
that and then I'll tell you
exactly how many.
Imitations distinguished.
So did the list in the
documents Mahtomedi because
I was present at a couple
of them and- that were read
work on for a long time.
Just make this possible
it's like a it's everything
about me is this is the
thing with this game you're
always surprised by how
much work every single
thing is just because of.
The pros that taking with
it and trying to sustain
its- cinematically also.
Throughout the entire thing
right so. It's fair. Yeah
it's amazing thing did the
minute to minute gameplay.
RPG calling the way that
we're doing it. Thanks to
all of our efforts and you
don't want to compromise.
Because you're doing
cinematics which is the
thing that. People forget.
And because it's much
easier to make. RPG like we
used to making. I just
added a couple clients.
Here's a new branch of the
darkest but put it in there
no I would he Steve diets
rather comes with. Putting
it cinematically in there.
And at. And single player-
each party member position.
You know and we're we're
taking that's- and I'm
happy of time when see I'm
really happy that they
spend time this yes good
but it is. I keep it is it
is it is so it's been a
while since you've the can
EA but you've got it now
you've got the flow is
there anything you want to
say too hungry fans- I he-
I mean there's- like a- and-
we are passionate about
making really really.
Really good RPG that can be
very proud of that you are
going to. That is going to
respect your choices there.
And to be able to deliver
that. And so and I know
that there's a lot people
are engaged they want us to
we call on just grammatical
like that do needs add.
Something that we can be
proud of who needs thank
it's right over its and
that we don't want just
like. She here's a bunch of
crime in questo instructs
actually so that you can.
We were not good at and SO
I had. But that takes time
to do it the other way. And
so hang in there honestly I
think the most I see on the
bow gave separate is just.
You in armor again anyway.
Hopefully it will be too
long now until we can see
both you and- a- and more
bold is K. three until than
ever in a home for mobile
does get three news and
updates whenever we can get
them. Make sure you
subscribe to GameSpot.
Welcome back to GameSpot's
playful showcase that was
passed me now you've got.
Present time line may. Sam
we've spoken a few times
about actually playing.
Real life dungeons and
dragons. And now you've
abandoned me and traveled
across an ocean. Why do we
labeled skate instead with.
I am not sure. Every public
I was harsh we were going
to couples therapy and
therapists definitely said
don't hang your laundry out
in public and we did it I'm
fine I am excited to check
out about his game three- I
like many people jump in
and play the starting over
and I was like this seems
great Formoso trapped in
like a weird bug right now
so I'll come back to this
later and rethought and re
all the character. I'm
tempted not to jump back in
because I've made a lot of
improvements I'm also super
super keen on seeing where
it goes based on what's
wrong with saying that
excited to see I know it's
kind Ruppert something cool.
The saying similar use of
check out when it was when
it first came out of it
access is but- I know
you're a big fan of RPGs.
And I've recently been
playing since the RPG's.
Are you gonna use of
waiting until the full
release comes out will. Be
tempted again. Yeah because
it really go is hooks in me
and then I realized that I
would get to the point
where. I can contend with
and I would just be sat
there waiting for them to
update and so I wanted to
just kind of hold off. As
well like I wasn't having
as 5 time with bugs
etcetera as some people
that I knew but- at the
same time it still wasn't.
Like the best. Way to play
at the obscure wait for the
final product I'm very
excited I loved wisely. I
honest I love. I played.
Sons in dragons- on the
tabletop. Civils gate is
gamer I really adore. I do
want to see it. When it's
in its full full version.
But for now we're at we're
going to. Check some
exclusive gameplay from the
Sherlock Holmes games which
is gonna be. Big because
it's three bricks currently
watching so. You can get
that here awful. Funny
accents just after this.
Hello and welcome to
Sherlock Holmes chapter
one. An open world action
investigation game that
explores the first steps of
Sherlock becoming the
world's greatest detective.
You were sure lock a twenty
one year old expiring
privatized struggles to
prove himself to the world.
Before you lies Cardona an
exotic island under a
British protectorate in the
Mediterranean Sea. Don't
expect a warm welcome here
most folks are prejudiced
against foreigners
especially those who are
well dressed and easy on
the eyes. That makes your
job as a rookie detective
even more complicated.
Whether you're vaccinated
or not Sherlock Holmes
chapter one won't hold your
hand as you investigate
core donors darkest
secrets. It's up to you to
find your way around the
island into decide what
your next step will be. In
this video we want to give
you a glimpse at the
seemingly elegant paradise
and more importantly. Your
disposal analyzer
environment in planting.
Let us also briefly take a
look at the island itself
we designed it to be as
varied as possible with 5
unique districts for the
player to explore each area
offers fascinating vistas
colorful characters and new
side quests the old city
district is an area mostly
populated by the Ottoman
descendants. It's
architectural styles are
influenced by eastern and
southern European cultures.
Giant fortress walls famous
Turkish bathhouses the
bizarre in the caravanserai
hotel make at the tourist
Mecca. The Scarlatti-
district is a bustling
administrative center
mostly controlled by the
British Empire. This area
is as European as it gets
with city hall the trolls
museums banks and hotels
all built by the Venetians
in the before times. Answer
writes in uptown district
lined with opulent villas
and juries establishments
it's a popular exotic
vacation destined for the
rich. Then we have minor
sent worst district on the
island it is a shanty area
an abandoned silver mine
with decrepit buildings and
slums in last we have
silver to an industrial
district full of factories
and warehouses some intact
some abandoned. Rest
assured each and everyone
of those districts were
treated like a stranger
most people won't take you
seriously you sure you're
in the right place we don't
serve cocktails EA I'm
looking for information
about a sailor who recently
drowned in Scolari- would
you happen to know anything
about him. The maybe not
one of the two two and then.
I in order to get closer to
your suspects and gain
their trust you will need
to change your overall
appearance and how you act
this is where our new
disguised mechanic comes in
handy. Can I get your
money. Not I'm good don't
know and a lot of the guy
who drowned in the fountain
instruments in many
throughout the game new
outfits can be purchased
from vendors for earned by
completing quests across
the island. There are
dozens of outfits hats
facial excess res and
cosmetic items at your
disposal. Use them to
customize your Sherlock to
your liking and role plays
a senior policeman local
trader or even a pirate to
get into closed off areas.
Sneak into the police's
prison cells or on private
venues as you pursue the
truth of core donors
weirdest transgressions.
However while many
situations require specific
outfit it's only a piece of
the puzzle. As a stranger
on the island you will need
to approach it citizens and
ask for help. There are
several social classes
within the game like
aristocrats workers
lowlifes eccentric. Knowing
who to approach what
questions to ask and how to
disguise yourself is key to
getting the job done every
item you select for your
skies will have to be
accurate enough to give you
credibility overall so that
each class is more likely
to take you seriously and
want to share information
with you. If you I mean.
Keep in mind everyone on
the island will react to
your new identity either
positively or negatively.
Asking Intel from a
policeman while dressed as
a thug will get you nowhere.
But put on an aristocratic
outfit in some will give
you the world. In order to
check the potential
reaction of someone use the
concentration about. All
the people of course don't
have three different
default labels that will
help you gain an overall
view of who they are first
is ethnicity and
occupation. Second is
dynamic will change
according to the person and
your current disguise the
third is a specific trade
of this person all Cordani
ins are unique and you have
to adapt to them to find
your way through the
island's mysteries. Let me
give you an example. We're
on the hunt for a mermaid
apparently there's someone
going around killing
sailors and the locals
believe it's a water. Well
this sounds preposterous we
still need to find the
culprit. So where would be
the right place to start
let's choose to head to the
local saloon at the sailors
frequent and talk to the
bartender. The issue is all
we know was the saloons
name but its whereabouts
are sort of on the hush
hush. We can ask one of the
sailors about it but they
are unlikely to talk to
some fancy pants rich boy.
So here's how I'm going to
approach the situation. I'm
going to buy a sailor's
outfit and put it on. Then
I'm going to open up my
casebook. Selecting Penn
the right evidence the one
that mentions the name of
the salon. With this piece
of evidence penned I can
approach people on the
streets and asked them if
they know something about
it since I'm dressed
appropriately. I'm more
likely to get a reply so as
you can see. We aim to
create gameplay elements
that synergize with one
another and give you
engaging tools that are fun
to use. At the same time we
leave it up to you to
discover the synergy think
about how and when you want
to apply. After all. What
makes a great detective is
your intuition. That's what
we want to engage we want
you to use your gut feeling
follow what your intuition
says. Sherlock Holmes
chapter one is coming to PC
PlayStation five Xbox
series X. and last Gen
platforms sometime in
twenty twenty one. If you
like what you're seeing
consider which listing the
game on the platform of
your choice and subscribe
to our social media for
more news in game play.
Thanks for watching our
video. I'll see you in the
next one.
It was a look at
some gameplay from Sherlock
Holmes chapter one a
prequel to the frog whereas
at detective game. Series
Monday just before going to
the game but you said.
We're gonna be judging the
British accents but we were
greeted with a- what I can
to see was an American
voice over. However we do
know that the person
playing Sherlock Holmes. Is
as vibrant it is a friend
of games so I'll X. I
Jordan Voght use also the-
the main male voice actor
in. The missiles so very
excited to play well I.
Love the Sherlock Holmes
games daily. Despite like.
Being quite a lot to do
with like puzzle game wise
to solve the case that they
do. Like really succeed in
making you feel. When you
do manage to solve- coming
up next so we can look at
Doki Doki literature club.
Plus you can add def
trailer. I if you please a
woman is this came out.
Laying it yeah it was-
people described it as
being like a little creepy
and- anything even slightly
creepy I will avoid like
the plague because I have-
the bravery of smokes while
without. I will scream and
seeing a six for Harriman
scream is not the violent
crime pines the world but
I've heard nothing but good
things about the original
so maybe I will finally.
Dig deep and build some
courage and play the next
patient maybe no promises.
Tell me looking to go back
and replay- yeah I that was
a game that I'd like
Ubisoft all the way through
because I could not stop
playing and so. Hello mom
Monika just money coming
from Monica Monica only so
I'm excited to go back to
and see how they do the
cool things on other
platforms. But because it
was very PC focused. Yeah I
was gonna say one of the
really cool things that
they did was the way you
could exhort of mass with
the game's files to change
the outcomes I'm interested
to see how that would work
on something like
PlayStation Xbox or switch-
but let's find out here is
a look at Doki Doki
literature club. Plus.
Hello my name is Dan
Sabado. And the creator of
the psychological horror
game Doki Doki literature
club. And now after a lot
of really passionate work
from a whole bunch of
people. I am delighted to
share Doki Doki literature
club plus review for the
first time- some of you
already can't wait to
revisit your friends in the
club. But if you're new to
Doki Doki literature club
we're excited for you to
meet the club members for
the first time on PC
Nintendo switch PlayStation
or Xbox this summer. DLC
plus gives the original PC
game high definition
visuals and brings it to a
number of new platforms.
It's also packed with all
kinds of new features and
content for both existing
fans and new players to
experience and enjoy.
There's a lot of cool stuff
for me to go over but there
are also some things that
you'll have to discover for
yourself when you play the
game. DLC is a game that
explores the unique kind of
relationship that people
can have with fictional
characters. And the
relationship they have with
video games in general. I
want to make a game that
causes people to think more
deeply about how they
mentally and emotionally
process their experience
for fiction. And using
psychological horror too
deeply disturb them is
really effective way of
achieving that. I always
felt like the members of
the literature club
deserves more space to get
to know each other and kind
of explore their
interpersonal
relationships. So for DLC
plus I wrote a new story
line that I call the side
stories. The side stories
are unrelated to the events
of the original game. And
instead focus on how all
the club members went from
first meeting each other to
becoming close friends.
Really wanted to create an
environment where these
characters. Have to. Learn
to overcome their
communication barriers and-
each other's needs and
reflect on themselves and I
think that will be really
meaningful to those of you
who relate to the
characters maybe even find
yourselves in similar
situations I think this is
a great time for some
wholesome storytelling I
can help keep us inspired
to continue improving
ourselves and our
relationships with others.
The side stories also have
a brand new soundtrack to
go along with them. Music
has always been an
important part of DLC and
really important to me
personally as part of
playing video games I love
how music tracks sort of
absorb all the emotions
feel during the game and
how it all comes rushing
back whenever you hear the
songs again. So for the
side stories I brought in a
new composer Nikki Tyler
the shares the same passion
and understanding of the
special impact of video
game music Nick and I
worked really closely
together on songs that have
some familiar catchy
melodies along with a bunch
of brand new ones. To make
it even better DLC plus has
a built in music player
music player has twenty six
music tracks in total. I
really hope you enjoyed
discovering the music as
you play the side stories
which will also unlock.
Speaking of unlockables
another fun new feature is
the picture gallery where
you can unlock pictures as
you play the game. There
are more than a hundred
unlockable pictures like
gamer work wallpapers and
never before seen concept
sketches of certain
memorable scenes from the
game. I think it's a fun
way to encourage people to
try new things and DLC. And
see if they could discover
all the content. It's not
easy to reach 100% content
completion. But but if you
and your friends share each
of your own discoveries
you'd be able to do it
together. That's about it
for the stuff I'm ready to
talk about today. The thing
else you'll just have to
discover yourself. I know
that there is always a
concern with re releases or
special editions having a
whole bunch of changes to
them or the original
content being tampered with
in some way so we
thoughtfully included all
the new content in a way
that ensures the main game.
Doki Doki literature club
is as authentic and true to
the original as possible.
Overall I really wanted to
make DLC plus. Not only
really special for existing
fans also a fantastic and
sensible way for new
players to get in on the
psychological horror
experience.
Another cheery
and upbeat look at WWE
literature club but we know
there's something else
going on beneath the
surface and I'm ready for
Monica to. Do things to me
again- but- did you see
anything in there Dave that
your- that you're like cool
that looks interesting I'll
check out. In other than
Monica like. They went
inside reading Hosey and
adorable. What is the
decline from like the
accommodations of overhead
this is making is making me
a little uneasy I feel I
I'm I'm very out of my
depth because you both
played it you know exactly
what's going on and I can
see just under the camera
during this time try to get
me to play. Break my brain
and half. Lucy anything in
a year you can go back to
it- got a CD like the fact
that adding ins of side
stories and- EA is
definitely how I mean when
you said this new music
because after I play docket
okay for the first time the
plate a couple times just
to get different outcomes-
the music is definitely in
the air when that will
stick with you for a long
time. I'm Dave you're very
right it sounds lovely and
comforting but it's really
not. This I'm very excited
to play it again. Tony next
up we have. An interview.
Wave that John offerings
general manager of call of
duty to talk about.
Everything quality you know
the battle royale genre and
the state of the game so
enjoy called fans. What you.
So I come events on the
ground E3 this year but the
GM of college age high
faxes kindly agreed to come
join us and talk about
everything because- thank
you so much for joining us.
Any super happy to be here
so it's only a few years
ago the corner GT was. A
singular based and now it's
more of a multi headed
hydra- of war zone the
honorable lace. Quality
mobile and its own people's
right out all year round
but during peak season
anymore so who's playing.
All of these versions is
that much crossover are if
you sort of seen.
Individual markets taking
on each type of game. Yeah
I think it's really an
interesting time for the
franchise your point
because it's expanded at
such scale so quickly you
know you think about what
happened not just with the
premium releases doing what
they've done. But here
comes mobile here comes
wars on and now you have a
whole new B. R. components
the community and it's just
been a really interesting.
Exercise I think in how to
transform the franchise
it's never been stronger in
many ways so when you ask
like who's playing. Clearly
we've seen. EIC gate open
as far as new. Entrants
into the system beyond what
we were traditionally known
for with. Korean peace
predominately- campaign.
Variances prior to those
releases- that I mentioned
and you're also seeing a
region. That have opened up
I think mobile has done a
tremendous job sort of
lighting quality up in all
these different ways in in
regions where maybe we
weren't as dominant- that
can scale in different
parts of the world now with
the same he so it's really
amazing you know I think we
have cross pollination. We
also have is sort of region
specific identities that
have emerged given that
growth that I mentioned.
And the franchise in many
ways it is undergoing. A
renaissance. Really
consider ourselves
differently who are we as a
mega brand we appeal to. I
in in ways that maybe have.
Created new new factors for
us and it's really about
connecting more players all
over the world removing the
barriers making it easy to
drop out of college we like
to play with you and with
your friends right I'm glad
you mentioned that the R.
spec because Boyzone is
really. Hello of that genre
do you feel like there is a
responsibility. For quality
roles on. Sort of keeping
those healthy almost well
we're always going to look
at how we make sure we're
delivering top quality
experiences right so if it
if it's- out there and it's
got call of duty. In the
name right we're going to
continue to think about
what's next how do we keep
up leverage that experience
and making it clear centric
so it's just gonna be. A
guard post for us but
you're right I think now
given. How interconnected
and dynamic. Recology brand
has become. We have to be
sensitive zero. Components
are aspects are
expectations of communities
that might have been. Just
much different or smaller
frankly. Prior worsens
dominance and take over sh
and the way that it's
captured such attention so
I love that you know
personally I think there's
so much we- therefore can
do you to have a bigger
con. Canvas on which to pay
so to speak but when that
you're right columns you
expectations new ways of
thinking about creative new
ways of thinking about
connecting seasons- and
what we need to deliver for
awards and- experience.
Let's say around. You know
season for coming up here.
Has its own intricacies.
Has its own dimension- that
might. Interplay definitely
and what will show up for
the core premium Cold War
audience right all within
the same. Messaging
framework or creative
artists right mark cell we
love that I mean we
wouldn't have done it if we
didn't think we couldn't-
delivered a world class way
you're right. It adds more.
Conversation around you
need expectations. And
speaking of that full
season coming up what can.
What can fans expect from
the season. Yeah it's a
pack one we've got a lot
and- from players across
both or- any kind maps.
Operator weapons I
personally narratives arc
satellites now crash on to
the scene. You know the in
which we can continue to
keep the content fresh
that's really the whole
strategy here is just keep
giving players reasons to
come back- come and play.
And create that re
engagement in a much more
consistent manner and where
is it affords us an ability
right stretch. And in these
ways and keep refreshing
the content. At a seasonal
positions here what we see
in our major mainline
release cadences so it's
fun to do and I think
season four is going to
have something for
everybody in many ways. All
of the structural
organizational execution
level challenges and
opportunities that come
with running not one but
multiple. Collegiate games
these days. At what scale
are you still pushing
forward with with the mold
is this or defining for
sourcing it gains think of
focused on or is it sort of
spending all those plates
at once. Well you know I
think it's a little bit
that we become. Our own
biggest competitor in many
ways right because quality
has scaled so tremendously.
In a way that most brands
not just in Gaming but also
an entertainment often
aren't playing at that type
of dominant level all at
once. So yeah it certainly
invite you know complexity
to keep pumping out top
tier engagement top tier
experiences year round but
we're well positioned to do
it I think it speaks to the
health of the franchise
that you know there's
dynamism sort of happening
inspiring and all these
different cylinders. You
know specific challenges
come with the territory of
trying to be a true mega
brands but that's part of
the appeal in my opinion is
that you know we play big
and we've lost trying to
federal records and break
them all over again. It's
an exciting time and- how
much of. The health of war
zone and quality mobile if
it is tied to that and
you're really speaks of C.
that's huge. Time of year
figure that and it brings
in a lot of plays Spohn.
Each individual collegiate
games now strong enough for
the consoles stand on their
own all how much is that
you get a release ready
pushing for the at the
secretary. I think there's
no question that in many
ways what hi Mobil's doing.
In and of itself. And then
what wars in history sort
of in and of itself with
its own community and its
own collection points and
that certainly with with
mainline is doing you could
make the argument. That
they stand on their own
merit in many ways just
from the sheer scale of
who's pouring into that.
But you know I think the
magic is how we found the
synergies creative writing
season three point five we
just came off of our-
eighties action heroes and
that is a great example of
that right like you really
saw it laid out. Not just.
In Cold War but with the
war zone and then even
mobile bringing some of
those assets and we used to
play so you felt like you
were having at sort of.
Franchise wide experience
regardless of which door
you chose. Or internet. In
it really translated- with
major success for us so the
search. Have own stress.
And they- have the own you
want. Because you never the
place space and- just that
making any intricacies are
going to be different and
you need to be sure about
that. But at the same time
I think. B. one plus one
equals three power quality
is that we can be both
specific and customized and
really enterprise wide to
position the brand as- you
know something much more
than just a one. I'm really
glad you mentioned the-
action movie additions ox I
absolutely adored that.
Bandai I want to know is
that. Is that more so
action movie staples in the
mix is this so
collaboration between
brands in already existing
franchises. Something that
you want to do more. And do
you have any in the works.
Whenever it makes sense you
know it's all it always
comes back to strategy what
we're not gonna just do
something because it's cool
today or it's expected to
do it's gotta make sense
it's got to happen at the
right time- and you don't
want to sort of. Again be
one note or trip wire on on
just because it's work
before you should do it
over and over again right
and so. I think there's
really careful
consideration around the
power of those types of
partnerships and- you know
as you mentioned it's
awesome. Enjoyed it whether
you enjoyed playing is
Rambo or John McClane an-
hour like that tell- in
many ways on. Brandon
another reason. Call of
duty right we're always
going to about the time of
this partnership. The why
behind doing it right and
as long as there's- a
massive focus on. Spohn
great gameplay I want to
drop and I want to drop it
with my friends so this is
gonna be socially. You know
connected for me- then
certainly it's something.
To look at but we're always
gonna think about doesn't
make sense in a broader
sense scope and strategy
before we just sort of.
Rolled them out. And into
much expected. If those no
object. There was there was
no speed bumps in the road
and you could choose any
franchise that you could.
Drop ins was aren't purely
your choice your favorite.
No one can say no to what
would what would it be. I
don't even think I'm
allowed to answer that
question I'm sure the
phones will ring if I take
that. Take to 1 but I will
say as an as an EDC kit and
I am kind of signaling a
little bit of money. I
loved it and in terms of.
Hi and well I grew up
watching a lot of Die Hard
says expecting to wanna
really go that route like
Rambo. My heart it was just
the one it took K. so you
know I love that I think
that the multiplicity
factor that list was very
cool to. We'll we'll we'll
take that into
consideration. And we'll
keep all right well if you
take your requests I'm I'm
a big fan of fifth element
I know you've already done
Bruce Willis bought them
for demolition someone on
staff very happy if you put
them I love both of those
suggestions. Noted it. They
said this obviously very
much speaks to the
evolution of call to G. C.
but now. It's evolved so
much to from the quality
that we knew. Three four
five years ago now it's
also 5 has its main
competitors shifted
somewhat he do you feel is
the- the main threats to
the market the moments you
you know it's a great
question and the reason. I
love the question is
because the brand has
stretched in all these
different ways. Whereby the
competitor said is
actually. Really really
dynamic and wide wide
ranging and sometimes the
competition is really
ourselves and I don't mean
that with any hubris I just
mean again because were.
Playing all these different
spaces that oftentimes you
don't find one singular
brand being able to do or
what I do as- sometimes
it's really just about how
do we want to. You know
manage our own success here
I see that too because even
coming up the ranks in the
sports side competitive
part of. Right like a lot
of the visionaries
competing with sports. And
entertainment properties
and not just chapter EA
sports but really the NBA's
yeah also the world. Sort
of entry into different
discussion points around-
eating with it really
depends on what part of the
franchise or seeking to
light up. Everything I say
that was like competition
is good you know like the
morning Gaming is becoming
this far transformational
industry worldwide I think
it's just good for quality
good for EA sports it's
good for entertainment for
events. So you know we
while we are always going
to look at the competition
we also sort of welcome it.
Because all. Certainly
shall rise with you know
the innovations just
Koreans. Industries are
seeing. Now you've come
from the E. sports of she's.
I'm speaker too how to do
the- of a Spohn to two
cards. Welcome I'm a little
biased I say that it's very.
And but it I stayed because-
these are real the liberal
James our sport you know I
and that may be lost and-
traditional once a
mainstream. Sure in risk I
think what qualities you
enter really change the
narrative around not just-
professional competition
but world class production.
World class broadcast
events world class ticketed
events where you can go and
have a college experience
and also see. The best of
the best in the world yeah
the reason I say it's
important is because when
you think about how much
our player. Base is just
expanded right in hundreds
and hundreds of millions of
people worldwide clans the
fact that you know are EA
sports community not only.
Engaged as exactly as they
are but they have to be so.
Tremendously good justice
statistically speaking to
be able to consider
themselves a pro and I
think that often gets lost
in the conversation how
good these guys and women
have to be ultimately to
compete. In quality just
given the franchise's scale
so it's something that- I
think we love because it
extends people's attachment
now I can tune in and watch
quality and have an
affinity for the branch in
addition to dropping into
play. But I also you know I
think it's about giving.
Players the respect that
they so rightly earned and
really putting them- on on
the map as it's really the
stars of tomorrow. Not just
in Gaming. In sports. And
this is very much time of
the where. People myself at
chomping at the bit for a
mole. Michael highgam GA.
But can you actually share
any details when you're
actually just announcing.
Thanks Caligiuri. I need to
excite since at this point.
I do not believe I'm at
liberty to share more
details- and that I don't
want to get a slap on the
wrist this early in my role
as GM- but I will say there
are great things coming.
And it's I think the reason
we also super energized
about being a part of our
duty right now because you
know that the days ahead
just looks so promising and
so exciting sledgehammer
games is working on on the
next release and it's gonna
be a tremendous tremendous
thank- so we're excited to
share more details here- as
we get closer to prime time
well I greatly appreciate
you spending a little time
with us today and everyone
watching. When we do
handing about
michael highgam J. we will
bring its use make sure
it's about the video
subscribe and stay tuned
for more content. China
thanks so much for joining
me. Thank you.
Welcome back
to the games as coverage of
everything extra out of E3
a play for- showcase ten
you know as well as I do
the demolition man question
from a live last interview
which EIC featured and I'm
sorry you're getting so
much of me today by the way
there are other interview
is available- the time I
had to I had to drive the
demolition my question I
yeah. The forty gusta lo
and Willis right. Yeah
don't like. I mean you
would put Wesley snipes and
they surely and- big why is
it is it is very much open
for taking some cash right
now- and I imagine. Yeah I
think it's fox that. Is
like the rights holder to
that movie- but- get Simon
Phoenix and they're- easy
like and if you get. John
Spohn in there you can
recreate the opening of the
movie way says send a
maniac catch a maniac and
then jumped out of that
plan goes Future. Well
there's ever anything to
get you deeply. The plans
because she was a- it would
be. In demolition man but
he's gonna be played out.
Here in that. Is that going
to be like for Chinese sets
but that would like really
that will what it would do
to town the demolition on
that. The well if J. if
demolition man was another
would have to be some kind
of tie in a Taco Bell in
the US and Pizza Hut and
you can just do you know
like if you go get me only
get code for skin or
something- I'm- ten AM.
Emily Bennington is been a
lot but like if it was a
ten minutes to pack
specifically. I would love.
Not that that at sixteen
the eighteen nineties
action movie. I'm still I
still want them to go fully
fully dash and end up in
this life I will. And do
she thought in the but next
up we've got a- news as
talented as he is handsome.
Looking for the fine folks
Nintendo three. Watching
games was coverage of E3
twenty twenty one almost
forgot what year it was
that I know is my pleasure
to be joined by bill and
Nate from Nintendo
treehouse how you doing and
folks. Hi great great
you're just showing off the
Nintendo direct where
according to strap in
tendering and- showed us
some really cool stuff
there so what we're gonna
do is we're gonna talk
about some of that stuff
almost looking to test you
on how well you know your
Nintendo direct which
should be fun. So first
questions first the
Nintendo direct opening
animation depicts a bunch
of red arrows moving from
left to right how many
individual arrows okay on
the screen during this.
Seventeen I'm gonna say.
Fourteen well the say
seventeen I did you nailed
it. Did you kill did you
know that had a son I know
everything. I spent ages
killing that there's one
arrow that just kept going
between did letters of
Nintendo direct SO nine
anyways I'm working on that.
Smoothly transitioning from
that why because- yeah in
smash brothers interesting
pick- interesting pic I
think- I mean obviously is
an iconic character from
tech and- you know going
back to the early games in
that series but it is also
one who's kind of evolved
over time. I think Mr
soccer I talked a little
bit about- about his
interest in the character
but- there will probably be
a lot more on that when we
see Mr soccer I presents.
Him hitting later this
month which is going to go
into quite a bit of detail
on the characters and move
sets. And and how is
incorporated into. So at
one point in the- showcase
their for this much from
this part- causing a throws
a character into a volcano
before activating his
double mode what character
was that. I think the last
one was. Man man yeah those
marks I'm going north. Bill
there definitely was
another one out there and
then- yeah I yeah I don't
know. They got it was not.
All experten zu E3
michael highgam it was the
last. He did- so in terms
of picking characters right
now at this point- how are
you kind of make I mean
you're running out of
characters- or that you've
promised anywhere you'd
like 1 left I think it is
right for I'm how do you
approach all house do you
have any insight into how
the team is approaching
picking that character you
go go out with a bang
right. Everyone obviously
is like crash bandicoot N.
smash but what are you guys
thinking do you know what
the inside you have any
inclination of what they're
trying to go for that.
Finish it up I think
they're probably like this
at this point. To the
internet like stop telling
me what to do. I don't know
bill it's like I have going
that- in general you always
know that you're never
going to. Please everybody
there's far too many picks
out there right now so- I
do agree that it should end
with a bang. The crash
bandicoot- because they- in
the smash- gameplay demo
has a ten hit combo what is
the official name of that
move as shown on the screen
during the direct- maybe
you should know this one as
well I think it was just
ten head count but wasn't.
Well I. Had thought about
Knox I'm confusing it with
the final smash- I guess
I'll also go with ten a
combo. Yeah correct there's
ten hit conquering lands on.
So Nintendo is a very
wholesome company but
you've once again decided
to release a game that
ruins friendships and has
families apart- interesting
approach for to go with an
all star off version of a-
Super Mario party what does
not allow you to do in
terms of putting together
a- package for. Fans of-
Mario party well for me it
allows me to revisit all
the games I worked on on
the N. sixty four- which
was so long ago but- I mean
honestly I think what
what's great about- super
about Mario party all stars
is that. With it being
button controls it becomes
the first Mario party game
on switch that's fully
compatible with Nintendo
switch light- it also of
course brings back the
board games from the N.
sixty four which I think
everybody loves- I'm a big
fan of kind of the dual.
The one the one door many
games that we cease to see
and Mario party two which I
think- philosophy- making
return here and- and then
you know I think I do think
you know Super Mario party
is going to remain. A game
of choice for people who
maybe are new to the switch
system or who prefer to
play with joy con controls
and that Mario party all
starters Mario party all
stars is going to be- super.
Superstars raw. Stars what
are you supposed as really
going to be I think the
game for people that have
either already played Super
Mario party or are long
time Mario party fans and
are really eager to kind of
dig back into the rich
history Austin I'm not sure
if you're aware of the
discussion around it but
the- the stage where the
cake has go a giant version
of Donkey Kong that's
called a dumper on show so-
you might wanna look into
that because the internet
after me is. So Mario party
superstars- Rosalina rolls
a- box noble and then push
it into another character.
Do you remember. What
character was the victim of
this horrible incident. I
am going to say it was.
Dakikada himself- eight
zero tech there was. We
okay it was in fact but-
all right gosh I was I was
getting. Fired out. One of
my highlights but the
showcase obviously I mean
you might try to find I'm I
was gonna wear the metric
each up I thought. I was
gonna wear the- the one
with the- outlined some
instance- why is it which
is really cool well Metroid
dread that's exactly. One
thousand one know what I
mean all. What if I'd
wanted. I metric threads.
Around for what sixteen
years now as a youth being
publicly- and it was not
thought to be the prime
number- and then referenced
in corruption and then.
Some people said it was
completed and I'm- kind of
how much of what we see
today. Aise aise hi a
Ruppert is represented in
that lineage or is it
something that was kind of
like entirely thrown away
and rebuilt from the ground
up I think you know
obviously Mr Sakamoto will
be the 1 contents that
question in detail he- you
touched on this a bit and
the- the interview that he
gave that we are right
after. The Direct in the
sense that. The core idea
of the same is being
pursued by this relentless
enemy I think is really
good the German that was
always match right dread
and- really what he-
articulated was that. He's
really waiting for
technology to catch up and
your technology and the
perfect partner in the form
of mercury steam which you
know after their work on.
Metroid Samus returns
proved it they just
understand that's right
that the DNA of what makes
a metric gamer Metroid game
and so- you know as far as
the particulars of exactly
how much you do without on
cocktail napkins far as the
overall game is. Safely
locked within Mr sok
mothers had I think suffice
to say that what we seen
about ME. Gameplay where
you're- these. Of into is
your- through. On that I
probably. Into from sixteen
years ago. Do you think-
I'm- there's more I mean I
a school to say. Probably
but using those more an
update. Now to have like
the- classic side scrolling.
Metroid games that have
more of a presence within
Nintendo this kind of
future because you know
they they've been gone for
so long. And now they're
back on you reckon this is
something that needs the
company was exploring
whether. And what can
people do like Metroid fans
like myself to show that
you know we really want
this to continue we don't
want. That's right to go
into a ball again for
another twenty years or
something. Like how do we
how do we make sure that
doesn't happen. Well I
certainly want to continue-
I mean I grew up with
metric as well as in the
first game that I played
I've always loved them- and
feel like. Genre to itself
it certainly never should
never ever go away. So- I'd
say. Certainly played a
game that's one- when it
comes to supporting it and-
I have a feeling that
you're gonna really like
what you. What should.
Which experience. Yeah I
think the thing that the
one thing I would add you
know I mean this is the-
mentions. Reuters or
defining I think everybody
recognizes that and when
you look at. How is defined
this game as sort of
closing the story arc of
the five game series of two
D. Metroid games- to me
this is a moment that
whether you are a Metroid
fan or not whether you've
never played the game ever
this is sort of one of
those moments and Gaming.
That everyone needs to
experience you know yeah
and that's a major for
Metroid fan like yourself
is get that message out let
people know you know this
is a series that has
defined a genre yeah this
is going to be a pinnacle
moment in that series
you've got to try this out-
that that to me is the
message that I'd like to
see Altmetric cancel every.
Is there any more of an
impetus to kind of make
classic Metroid games more
available like I know cemex
raised pretty much on
everything at this point
but- no seasons a classic.
Outside of like thinking
that yes some bass in a
program called rainy get it
like. Is there any
discussions happening like
we were releasing a sequel
to. It what is effectively
a sequel to a fusion but
there's a business also
whole bunch of people I
generation of people call
Playstation. So how do you
approach that the way that
the each of the games is
designed as as yes there's
connective tissue between
all of the games and
there's a story arc between
them- but each game that's
actually a really solid job
of reintroducing what's
happened prior in the
series so you can sort of
started any point- and then
it also over the course of
the action exploration will
sort of drip feed these.
Little bits of story to
you- and you can piece it
together I would also say
that as were as were- you
know approaching launch-
you can expect to see a
kind of a steady cadence of
information- that'll help
get people who are new to
the series up to speed on
on what Metroid is- Samus
Erin is- and what that what
the story's been up until
now it's also never the
wrong time to go. On and.
SO in place super Metroid.
During a- trust- what's in
the metro as to what your
passes clear time- I don't
place play I play hello and
I to the IMS and later.
They just love it for a
like I will be helping
watch the file screening
that's the best I was
remembering the video game
so- I take it slow and
steady when it comes to
metric. So in the metric
thread key off there are a
number of enemies in the
background behind Sam's do
you remember how many
they're all. Behind seven.
Well 5. May is right Nate
Nate knows he's right as
well as cemex just move on
yeah. A couple times. It is
the answer I had to go with
something different no
matter what I said it was
gonna be wrong- he's on it
he's on it- so not I'm
complaining but- why. Why
was now the right time to
bring advanced was back why
wouldn't it be the- I mean
why wouldn't why wasn't the
right time for that.
Fifteen years of everyone's
going on about once was
coming back but why is it
now. Well I mean you know
every every team I think
has- it has different
projects that they're
working on and yeah and-
certainly we've seen a
resurgence with fire
emblem- over the years- but
certainly here in North
America- many of us myself.
Probably being in front of
the line- her our big
advance wars fans and- and
so I think I'm you know
personally I'm just really
happy to see that we it's
back- and that we were able
to announce it today.
Because I do think it's-
it's a series that is
worthy of a lot a lot of I-
I have. A passion for
myself. Yeah I keep my
keypad DS three DS with me
at all times because of the
bombs fall so I'm so glad
to see it come back I'm
glad to see it come back
because- my son lost my old
cartridges and all of the
play time that I had and-
so- only only time I'll
ever call him out for that
but that did happen. With
both of the- games included
that is. So much came. I
can't remember how long the
second game was but it felt
like hundreds of. Mac your
yeah it's a like a long
game but I'm excited to get
back in can you clarify
who's developing another
site said intelligence
systems is it intelligences
them's are they- is there a
co developer or anything
like that in fact we- we
just confirmed earlier
today that the developer is
actually way forward and
they're working together.
With consultation and
advice both from Nintendo
and from intelligence
systems on the project
fantastic that is a great
team to well not yeah we
love working with them
we've been fans of them for
awhile what is the mood
staff what a medium. Tanks
in advance towards. When
you got it. Man I no excuse
go it was on the screen for
a whole two seconds. I have
no idea on this one bill
you gotta you gotta save us.
I the medium tank. Is. 5 no
for no wait hang on 5. 5
sure yes. Correct yes it is.
Well done well done bill
almost good job looks at
the Gaming watch out that
kind of collaboration that
really cold super excited
about that my one immediate
thing was oh god am I going
to be able to buy this you
talk about about- kind of
availability and are you
prepared for it to be at
like super super in Dimond.
All our way out or should I
braced for another like
another new snacks classic
situation weights is going
to be gone and I'll have to
be back in people trying.
To find its- but- well
hopefully we'll we are that
special of my dread is
already so like I but I
looked away from my screen
well five minutes and then
I came back and it was gone
outside all right yeah
it's- I mean it's certainly
challenging these days I
think with any- just the
card a perfect storm of
code and people getting out
to retail and- you know
generally at high demands
for everything I think
makes it challenging but-
certainly with- with the
questions of the Gaming
module will hopefully be
able to provide enough to
cover up for what we expect
to be a really enthusiastic
response I certainly know-
I need to grab at least.
Three one for me and a
couple for a couple friends
so are we will certainly do
our best to anticipate that
demand and make sure it's
built this is your chance.
To ask me if you one of
those I'm just. And Nnesaga.
One of those friends
support. Moving on to
impress the well the secret
Brooklyn well and- one of
the main. Things are in my
mind is like how much more
of a focus from what you
can say is now- if but the
game because it's very much
you know. The original game
was a very light touch on
the matter if you know if
there is but everything I
see open it seems like
you're setting up a very
strong- story to tell is
that the right. Way to come
out here and think about it
or should we brace for
something I should have
people who are obsessed
with law get that pens and
paper ready well I think.
Certainly I think those
people are by getting the
pens and papers ready
anyway it's true- but- I
absolutely think it'll
it'll have a strong story
but I'm also I. You know.
Of the mind that. That but
is out of breath away. Had
a pretty strong so. Which
it was just. Told in a
very. Interesting way. You
know the game play design
was. Such that. Really had
to design a narrative based
around. Not knowing whether
or not everybody would
actually. Find all the
pieces of their- so the way
that you PC. The story of
what happened a hundred
years prior together. Based
on you know finding memory
locations. Experiencing
cuts is it really not
everybody would see. I
thought was really
interesting way to do
things. And at the end you
know for somebody like me
would. Absolutely covered
every inch of. Hi role in
that Gaming saw everything.
Really felt like it ends up
being very satisfied store
and I expect- absolutely.
Same from the new. But
course we're- not providing
any real details on that.
This first points where you
can see like. A snippet of
link with. Long hair and
that steam treatment- can
link Robert. You know the
guy's not that's possible.
My are you asking because.
You also have long hair and
a beard. Yeah I would to
see a long head badly but
I'm- wondering like easy to
young to. Like you does he
have a that's he have the
almost the grow bed on a is
that. I think like you need
to think about and maybe re
issue the high road story
at the like. A day that's
not a handlebar mustache I
do want to inform the
subject here I do want to
give a shout out to is in
the ridge. The first.
Brought the wild game. The
engine armor I don't know
if you ever got that full
set but if you wore that
set. She achieved maximum
mileage on that one yet the
one yeah- so yeah I I'm
holding out hope is as you.
Are for us and Spohn
spirits they're stuck. Yeah
I mean yeah if you can just
like let on and let's not
know that. It would go a
long way okay it's- I
think. I mean like the V.
P. five find images are
going to be incredible if
that happens because-
everyone loves. A bit-
during. Legend of Zelda.
Portion of the discussion.
Unless was. That badge on
it sure. What was the badge
balls. I discuss seven said
Dr horse but that's an easy
answer. L. I am going to
say he was wearing a and in
the shape of as the logo
birds of a- cool both the
wrong so wrong you may hear
the closest it was the
royal crest the crowd. Is
going to I was gonna say it
was very small it was a
very small- couple final
questions for you about-
interesting lack of animal
crossing during peak Direct
fashion and- can you talk
about that maybe because
people like. We're still
playing I'm addressing
what's Nintendo's what is
your behind not having I'm
pressing a what's the kind
of plan going forward
finally crossing is that
still like. I was playing
animal crossing morning.
Absolutely there's life in
it left you know we do
still plan to continue to
support it with updates-
didn't. Yeah I think in
general we were so jam
packed with announcements
for this Direct maybe just
wasn't. The right time for
more for more but so we
absolutely plan to continue
supporting future. And then
the final question just for
me. Where it where is
BAndai three like. Is it
still is still exist
michael highgam we're dying
out. Is there any if you
guys are you gonna
shirtless ever what was the
deal that. It definitely
still exists I can confirm
it. I St I'm not so I will
even go one further and say
not only does it exist but
it's progressing well. Okay
great and- well- you know I
think we have a habit of we
like to show things like
we're going to show them-
and certainly we like to
show things- when- I think
the developers ratio them
so well- we didn't have it
here at E3. But stay tuned.
Well I appreciate you
telling us that. Fell may
thank you so much for your
time today and for-
entertaining they question
again. I when I conduct
raises everyone's a winner
so as far as I'm concerned
you both 1. Great job.
Welcome back to games with
coverage of E3 twenty
twenty one that win now in
play for all this is our
own show where we have a
bunch of exclusive trailers
gameplay articles
interviews- that was times
interview with folks over
at Nintendo. Hi- he looked.
Like they looked like they
were having a great time
but also. Haynes it's some
of that look at how. Deep
those questions where
listen my whole rule is to
find and expose the fake
games. Cancel out I don't
care where you work if you
what kind Nintendo I'll
find you and expose you as
well luckily. Those two
lads very real game is they
they they did alright. And
actually I an update on
Bayonetta three which I'm I
you asked- in slack before
you went into these usually
K. going into Nintendo any
betting questions. And I
was right in that within a
three so I'm very glad.
That you asked thank you
very much I appreciate
that- we have the Xbox
extended showcasing coming
up in about thirty minutes.
Before then we also have
another bloc of exclusive
trailers so we've got a
lot- coming up including
endless dungeon scape bird.
Golf club waistline and
Chinatown detective
agencies that's coming up
in just a minute. They you
very excited for the Xbox
showcase yeah. 100% they-
many came out swinging
provise throughout the
entire year so far so. It's
expose really ignited a
renewed excitement from
other franchises sea of
thieves halo it's awful
enough to work with both of
those seeing Martha. Edible
and- just even more
recently for a an excuse to
trailer is coming up.
Oshkosh us gate bird as
with most horrible thing
I've ever seen to have a
great screen. Absolutely
well make sure you stick
around here GameSpot
because we'll be showing
the extended showcase- in
just a few short minutes
but first is a bunch of
exclusive you trailer.
At
least you we have built
expertise RPG games titles
such as and the space and
lucy james. And more
recently humankind. When we
realize it in twenty
fourteen dungeon of the
endless without first
venture into the world like
smart unique mix of
strategy action and RPG
mechanics never seen before.
He doesn't have the end of
this the player has to
protect the generator of
his cross cheap well
exploring an almost
infinite dungeon. All Y.
facing waves of monsters as
he tries to find his way
out. End up winning a lot
of awards for its game
design and shall we say
captured the hearts of both
amplitude fans and Roglic
fans but- even knowing this
we didn't really expect
such an enthusiastic
reaction. We revealed the
next game endless dungeon
at the game awards in
December two thousand
twenty. In this dungeon is
the return of amplitude on
the road like seen as our-
we like a lot. The game is
a spiritual sequel of the
original dungeon of the
endless keeping the
quarters of the game. All
while proposing a whole new
experience for fans and new
players alike. Now because
of the first game success
we knew the formula was
loved by players who were
still seeing a lot of
potential. In new ideas to
explore. I remember exactly
how the police started
we're all together having a
kid in big party at
amplitude to celebrate
something I have no idea
what it was. And we had a
lot of beer and- looking
with the idea of snow and-
what it's made out only. So
for the first time- we had
particularly dated- it
maybe like five days you
know- after like. You know
as and that's that's an
amazing moment that's yeah
I pretty much always. The
player will still have to
escort the crystal using
hero skills plus weapons
turrets and a good dose of
good thinking to be able to
make it all the way to the
eggs. The heroes will also
be more important than ever
in endless dungeon as
you'll be able to unlock it
recruit a bunch of colorful
characters. Each one of her
specificity special attacks
the biography backgrounds
and the way they react to
events in the dungeon.
We've only discovered for
them in the previous
trailers now but I know he
was asking will the pot be
there. Well we know she'd
love to be there. I have to
see what happens. We also
believe that no one should
go on the seemingly
hopeless mission hello so
in this dungeon is meant to
be payable either solo. Or
with your friends and co we
hope to deliver a great
crop experience so you can
explore the dungeon with
your friends. We would also
like to step up the
community engagement and
not. Frequently proposing
votes on our games together
platform. This will allow
players to directly impact
the game by voting on
various topics such as lord
gameplay and concepts. And
I was always giving
feedback to the dance team.
Player feedback has always
been crucial to the women
making. So keep an eye out
for opportunities to try
the game let us know what
you think. The community
already chose this official
name. And the christening.
So now we have so much more
coming for you and gives
you gather so you can
participate. In the
production of and it's
done. So sign up to get
together. To stay in the
loop. Cast your vote and
make your voice heard.
Product not yet rated. Hi
I'm local spring one of the
producers at team seventeen
and today I'm going to
introduce you to the dock
fancy medieval inspired
action RPG thank media.
Lotions steam for windows
PC lately she is by means
he's one of my team
seventeen indie games label
trials and is being
developed by our friends
over bought a studio in
Taiwan. In in a wld of
alchemy that's been ravaged
by insidious plague and
polated by terrifying
monste time is it tells
the stor of call this a
mysterious indivual who's
interest with the task of
clearing the plate has the
questi Foles call ts
will discover untold trus
and secrets the- Smedley
lead ta decision on how
to handle the plate to
vauish the source of the
evidence putting
malelence the kingdom
fall too soon hubris the
destiny. Of humanity is
up to him. Find easy is not
for the int of heart. The
most is plagug the
kingdoms are extrely
deadly I skilled in
combat many fall int tm.
But luckily call this is a
newomments about. As the
quest to balance this hf
humaalf raven wld be
save you must use every
tooln his arsenal fm
some county agili to June
wielding safer and I get
and rocks like cws and
feathers. In spi by
cabre medieval facts of
oodletting pctice by
plague docrs whenever
coldt deals dage to any
enemies they allow so of
eir managing. Tm with
your. Clothinsign and
absorbhe energy. Althis
can re t play from theend. e
of plague. Weapons sixwo
howi. e only shift
levels o damage. On the
site that delive a roof
damage to emies. Give
them a taste of eir own
medici. This is the ly
way tsurvive this
delate kingdom. Call
versus compatibilityan befut
ee system. Wheer that's
turningoppi inthe
fence unleashg longer a
more devtati combos.Linkinge
culturesn a ole lot
re. These abilities whencome
weapons aows players todelor
owntyle of playr even
at that. Ts chlenges of
all. We'll she mor by
media over theoming weeks
ahead of s launch later
this yr thanks forwahing. Ws
detectiv suthsncome
shts. I'm he to welcome
you to e wld Chinatown
tective agency. vibrant
neonit point and clickadvene
year twey thirty two.
's aame inspired bthe
dark uerbelly seard
boed dectivehills
cocs a novels and of
coursehe urban lancape
of the cer pkovies
th we tched growing
Well wel C. I D.
superintdent traipsing
aroundhinawnn the wee
hourof the morning.
Sods le a tabldheadlineBut t
portt inspiraon f
the game a the one tt
we setut tpay homage to.
Is the classic whe in the
worl is Cmen Sandieg
seri o games of the late
ghties and ninies.
These e the games tt
spir Chinatown's mtimportt c
Real research.  he played
e re of Araharm an
ex copnd Interpol offeryou'k
yondhe game for aners.
Sohat meanssing Google
toind t answers or
wikidia or whatever
search enge referce and
resource se enclopea.
Alma NAC Y.old family
memb ofriendrwhatever orhoee
in o mission Amira i
skedith turning
reertaff.o its placeofrigino
the quick abridged versionae
lookinstam. Sure if
you're into thatind
thing.ou'll be able t
view the status anall
theslitt details. B
you might als need to n
a sear online for any
clues that mig lead you
to i countryf orin.
You'lleedo find answe
to puzes that cover a
rang of tics in. History
art science and
cryptograp. These cases
will ao see you traling
the wld to exotic
locations in archf the
ne ld or to tra down
a rsonf interest.
esnce is a gam that
asks you to  real wor
investatio in der
prressn the game.Having sail
ntedo ensure thahe
difficulty othe puzzles
dn'tecome a
surmountable obstacltoyour h
we have meeting. A
librian who Amiraeams
up with in t game who cofr y
really c'tigure i out.
e solutions to the
zzles. Be carefu it's
going tcost you. Mting
doesn't wk forree. Andin Che
agen makg se you've
tnough mon in e
bank tpay nt is crucial.
C. if y goankrt it's
ga over Weopeou'll
jo Amihe uavels
copiraes Inftrat
criminalyndites. Amid
th bacrop of thehaot
worlhanging by a tead.
Chinown detecti agency
mesp lar this year PC
and switch.
You must. Six
put sold. World famous. You
too two eighty this call is
from Los previously kick
back. And reminisce. Take
my hand explain to me. This
project called humanity.
Hello while the shura. Do
B. no surprise saw line one
is that- shouldn't be side.
We've of the. My. I know we
won't give. Let go. The
signs of and I'm awful. Ste
can go.
The show.
Contingent with take my
head- sublime to on a one
of project called humanity
beautiful. Twenty one to go
into social Showtek could
still. And music to
ourselves of where we are
and how far we've come.
Your home away from.
Welcome to bang on bulls
chronicles exit plans
around this most fun and
then fish's game to date
Namco once also office.
Prompted by a team of it
with years of a- create the
most cold and ground game
yes this that could not
anime three D. please also
to. It down to them thank
shape could think of. This.
Is hi at work creating an I
think it's been B. U. blue
for room during bowl may.
Style is important and
through extensive
customization options you
can become whatever you'd
like. Whether it's a Polish
pirate princess a Brazilian
phenomenon having cowboys
or whatever. This is. You
roll and jump dash smash
and find your way through
the most incredibly
detailed and basically
historically inaccurate
environments. Full size we
heard you like bowls. Both
Greenville's will he'll
fall even ten Bob into a
bigger boat in order to
scare. Welcome can usually
be gathered then to a
three. Next the questions
like. That challenge to
come secret to find
treasures to unlock- tools
to bank many items to
collect. Some of these may
have a special effect they
can help you explore the
world will give you an edge
in combat as you burn.
Freeze the only 5 simply
turn your enemies into
chickens. If you don't want
to be alive we spoke with
you finally friends up to
four players on nine may.
The team at exit plan will
continue to expand the
game's universe. Titans
enemies and- balls out the
joy. This is the next
generation of finding okay
rap. Now and go have some
fun.
We are just under five
minutes until we cut to be
parris lilly Xbox game
showcase extended so make
sure you go and get ready
for the Imran Khan snack
breaks as well- but before
we get to that. We can talk
about some of the games
that were shown in that
block there was some really
cool one must always skate
for- gave. What do you make
of that. I love skating the
love birds and like you
point out the flapping
animation. It was it was it
was adorable like it's very
much reminded me old
school- sorry host games
where it would have you
Grindal stole. It like
snaps to the corner of the
environment I love is a
durable it's scary and more.
Lucy okay. I am it looks
very very cute- I'm just
excited to see more I hope
they get like. Just like a
little bit. DLC name what.
Yeah I get loads of. And in
that give the bird finds
something finally- golf
club wasteland was one that
I was very very into- I
loved it showed like golf
games- and this one's got
some interesting stuff
going on I kind of like the
radio thing happening it's
got like. Low flow 5 sci fi
beach golf and relax so I'm
into that many of you
interview- into. The idea
of the idea of that day's.
Yeah I understand. Like are
you saying that that this
is seven nation a very
chill soul of. Lo fi golf
games. There was- comical
the very silly strange one
that came out- on- what the
golf okay what the Gulf.
Gulf incredible game so
yeah I'm very incidence of
chilled golf five. Lucy
unpleasant off. Well I mean
my favorite kind of golf
is- that place in Vegas
where you can go in and get
drunk and just going-
difficult pulls off the
driving range- took off but
I didn't want the golf and
yeah I go for boyfriend did
have those those chill
vibes so I'm intrigued I'm
intrigued do I get booze
with it. That's the kicker.
I mean you could always
just get your own but it is
easy to do. A strong
independent Iran dang this.
This one goes out for the
well the press out there
how do you feel about polls
how do you feel about bang
on both. So this is does
anybody remember the
country bowls webcomic
stuff from like the yeah
just just like twenty ten
that with the weather web
comics and they would
represent countries with
the small bowls in that
have strained conversations
instructions. This just.
Gamer fight that I mean I'm
all for either way it
looked at first I thought
this initially not sure if
I if I get on this and as
they're showing new
features and more things
feel Bangon bowls to do.
There was an S. B. Q. R.
Roman legionary bowl that
was Scotland the brave in
bowl full of snow off like
that. Persia thanks other
husband has been noticed.
No it is there a couple of
other traders including
endless dungeon thing you
see- I'm trying to tell
detective agency which we
encourage going checkout
because they look cool by
wanna quickly hit on what
we're about to go into
which is as we said up top
the parris lilly Xbox game
showcase extended. I'm for
those who don't know that's
going to be I think it
seems to be interview
focused but it's gonna have
a bunch of conversations
where three four three
industries by halo double
fine I don't know about
Psychonauts ninja theory
for Hellblade to obsidian
about how they're gonna
talk about the- what's
there given that trailer
but I'm excited to hear
about it thank RPG games
before the horizon raffle
see if these. And while
it's H. as well as a bunch
of talented yeah on his way
you both most excited. To
hear about real quick Lucy.
I'm I definitely know more
about the C. the- parts the
carribean collab and Ford
said I think food so for me
it was a real stand out
from the presentation. We
saw on Sunday.
Stephanie ijoma one of
those also held late. Save
I'm a big in two parts
carribean so I think to see
if these add on will get me
back into sea of thieves
although it comes at a cost
because whenever I watch
those films I will talking
apar action for about three
and a half days so Ijoma so
you guys gonna hate me.
Because I'm gay so.
Delivered XLNX locum ready
for the amount counts break
and we're about to kick it
over to Xbox and a friend
Parris they need to show us
more of these games take it
away Parris. We.
Bring me
that horizon weekend.
Hello
and welcome to Xbox game
showcase extended I'm your
host parris lilly you may
also know me from gamer tag
radio and kind of funny I'm
excited to be here with you
today we just saw a recap
of Sunday's Xbox showcase
and wow thirty games from
some of the world's most
talented developers in
twenty seven of those games
are coming to you on Xbox
GamePass. We saw the first
in engine footage of store
filled and learned that yes
but that is that is
bringing it to Xbox PC and
day one on GamePass
exclusively thanks also to
battle for the twenty forty
two save me a pirate's life
stalker to cycle not too
and how bout read full.
Like they said this year
Xbox it's all about the
game. Today Xbox game
showcase extended is our
chance to hear from the
developers behind the games
that are redefining
interactive entertainment
developers like double
fine. Playground games
supergiant rare three four
three industries and more
we also have a new assessor
design program to share
with you and a couple of
other cool surprises.
That's enough talk let's
jump right in. You can see
for yourselves for the
horizon 5 looks phenomenal
and here with us today all
the way from the UK is Mike
Braun from playground games
Mike thanks so much for
joining us. Hey great to be
here now Mike for the
horizon has taken driving
fans to Colorado France
Italy Australia and the UK
how did you decide on
Mexico for forza horizon 5.
Yes so we knew right from
the start that we wanted it
to be the largest horizon
yes- but it's not. Far down
the path from the you
realize you don't go big if
it's just give me more of
the same so we also knew
that it needs to be the
most contrasting most
diverse open world without
the belts. And then we
start to look at Mexico
eight it really is like the
whole world in one country
it's got snowy peaks
tropical jungles. Canyons
amazing beaches beautiful
architecture incredible
historic cities balsam
mountain cities as well it
really has everything. And
then you want in the
culture the music the
artwork the people the
history and there really is
no more exciting location
for the horizon festival.
Now that we're in Mexico
what are some of the
authentic elements that we
can expect in the game.
Yeah totally so we've got
the largest and most
diverse world we have a
built in as I mentioned
just a moment ago.
Something that really
excite it does about Mexico
is the culture so we've
worked with creatives from
all across Mexico we've had
Mexican artist produced
beautiful mural artwork
you'll find on the walls
around the game we've
worked with Mexican music
acts to produce original
compositions for the game.
What a Mexican
scriptwriters and actors of
all of those Mexican voices
you hear in the gamer sound
really authentic. And
perhaps not as obvious- but
the other thing they super
authentic is all about like
they turned skies so we had
a team out in Mexico I with
all twelve K. hasty all sky
capture rig we captured
more than four hundred
hours of sky data. And then
we recreate nine games I'm
so old that the lights the
shadows the color
information the old is
recruiting game based on
real life data captured
from Mexico so. Everything
you're seeing batteries
just has not real offenses
do not doubt that feeling
of the reality. A we got a
peek at the vet. Lab no
what can you tell us about
that. Yes Sir I've been is
eight AM. A at suite of
tools. That will allow to
community Sir. Will
whatever they can imagine
really we look at the video
right now. All of this that
we say has been built using
the event lab tool sets. I
did the bowling pins have
been placed so someone's
going the PlayStation then
they've created rules that
touch on them as well so.
As the every time hitting
them. A rule has been set
up so that it gives gives
players points and then
also in the in a clip you
can see that. Everyone else
in a multiplayer session
sitting bowling pins as
well. All of 5 adding into
a collective team's goal.
The rules could have easily
been set up so it wasn't a
team school that it was
competitive all of our
career freedom is open to
plants it's- after game
designer. I think it's the
feature I'm most excited
about in and for
terrorizing 5. And I would
say as a gamer is a feature
of definitely excited about
because it really is going
to open up so unique
features between me and my
friends. Now with the power
of the X. Xbox Series X X.
in the S. what are some of
the new. Technical features
that we can expect. So in
in service. We're really
able. Ten everything from
happening on ten on race
race. We have a call
looking. Realistic ever
happen. Unparalleled but
detail. It does apply to
the rest of the world as
well. During the- Xbox E3
showcase the other day. I
mentioned we modeled the
detail and everything right
down to the individual
needles on the track
cactus. That was just the
plants that happens to be
closest to the camera that
points. I haven't got that
level of detail is applies
to everything that you see.
On thanks to the power of
the Xbox series consoles.
It's not just things are
right in front of the
cameras while we read about
to push out all of the- the
launch in the draw distance
and everything so that.
Everything in the scene. Is
full of detail. I'm done as
I mentioned earlier we cap
satellite data from Mexico.
So you got this realistic
lighting shadows I old it
comes together to create a
scene that just looks. Real
now Mike. When can the
world expect to play forza
horizon 5. Shaw so we're
launching this holiday. On
the Xbox series consoles
the Xbox one consoles were
on PC. About the windows
ten store and steam of
course wearing GamePass and
GamePass ultimate. And you
can place on your android
device with Xbox cloud
Gaming. And players who
purchased the premium
edition Ole if there
GamePass subscribe and get
the premium items bundled.
You'll get early access as
well so. You have to play a
little bit earlier than
everybody else. No my god
this is huge moment for you
the team what does. Mean to
you. Yeah well for me
personally I mean I've been
working for the franchise
for a really really long
time but this is my- it's
my first game as creative
director so. In this period
of the last few days and
then we call so as people
are seeing it for the first
time. For me it's probably
one of most exciting
experiences my life it's
been absolutely incredible.
Again might. Thank you so
much for being here. Thank
you so much problem it's
been a pleasure. Later in
the show we'll be hearing
from the developers behind
games like age of empires
four. Shredders and ground.
But first. The team into
theory has something to
share with you. Here's to
me. Chief creative ninja.
To explain what they've
been hard at work on. For
Hellblade to. Hello
everyone and welcome to our
brand spanking new ninja
house in Cambridge. I want
to give you an update on
the works of awful several
saga Hellblade to. We're
doing right now is building
a good chunky slice of the
game before we dive into
full production to build
out the rest. Hellblade was
very special for us and- we
didn't want to do a
straight sequel we wanted
to do something extra
special and so. When making
a loss is difficult as
possible and that proceeds.
The game is such a nice
length nine century
Iceland's so we've been
sending out of tune with
your teams out there. Doing
photography photogrammetry
and combining it with
satellite data to recreate
large sways of the
landscape. On the character
front with building real
costumes scanning them in.
Collaboration with
epic games to bring your
next generation digital
characters. On the come up
trumps we wanted to be
extra real and brutal. And
certainly in our main
actresses been training for
two years on all of our
analysis of on the ground
combat training. And so
when you're gonna see here
is not a trailer it's not a
game plan revealed. But
rather a montage of the
kind of what we've been up
to. Hope you like it.
Will
you follow me- and. 5. The
staff. Over the mountains
of. Today my mom. You might
see thank. We'll show you
what lies behind my. With
us. Which still. To start.
Suffering. CJOnline. C.
this call. Please. And one.
Thing. Yeah these new- sh.
This.
That is Xbox design
lab in here to tell us more
about Xbox design lab is
Nuveen Kumar I mean thank
you so much for joining us
thanks for so what is Xbox
design lab design lab is a
controller customization
service on Xbox .com where
you can choose nearly any
color combination you want
for your controller really
make it yours- you can
design a controller based
off your favorite video
game character your
favorite sports team or
whatever inspires you can
think of design lab as our
own personal design studio.
Now we've originally
launched design lab five
years ago and have since
sold millions of
controllers to fans around
the world but then we had
to take a pause as we
brought up our latest
generation Xbox hardware
but now we're back offering
customisation on the latest
generation Xbox wireless
controller now we have so
many awesome controllers
here right now can you kind
of talk a little bit about
them yeah well right off
the bat you can see there's
tons of color options to
choose from for most the
parts on the controller-
you can choose among
eighteen different colors
for all the different
different pieces on the
exterior. Three of those
colors are brand new to
design that we have shocked
blue also read in my
personal favorite the
electric volt color most of
the colors- include post
consumer recycled resins
and them so there's a
portion of things that are
ground. Up like automotive
headlights. Michael highgam
bottle jug- that make the
controller more eco
friendly we also have a new
button options for the a B.
X. Y. button set. In the
view menu share. Including
a really cool button
options- for a B. X. Y.
that's a throwback to the
regional Xbox three sixty
controller. You gotta check
that out. And yeah this is
just the beginning we're
excited to introduce more
customisation options over
time. Now to these controls
were inspired by games can
talk about that. Yes so
there's a blue and green
purple one that's inspired
by Psychonauts two we just
love the key art for that
one so we work with our
partners- to develop
controller to help bring
that to life. And there's
also one that's inspired.
By grounded and the Asian
character from that game-
we had a lot of fun and
design as well as a control
kinda looks like a fit if
you look at it. From the
right angles. Now I created
my own controller. Going to
pick it up now. I'm a huge
Los Angeles Lakers fan.
World champion Los Angeles
Lakers and my design was
inspired by that so I went
with the yellow. On the
front. I went with the
purple on the back- I
designed the buttons kind
of with a black accent
along with the- the
shoulders and the triggers-
but- I also didn't
description. On it and my
inscription says ka can't
cook. And that is inspired
by my good friend Khalif
Adams. He does a fantastic
show called Spohn on me.
But he's a terrible cook.
So I want to make sure that
every time I pick up a
controller to play on Xbox.
I'm reminded how terrible
of a cookie is. And to
avoid at all costs. But
enough of terrible cooking.
Let's talk about something
that you desire. Yeah I
designed the control right
in front of me here. Again
on my favorite color this
electric bolt I just love
the way. That the midnight
blue accents pop against
it. The dark a B. X. Y.
colors- and this was
inspired by a Parris
sneakers I have at home so
I had to make a controller
based on. That that's
awesome. Now one last thing
when can fans expect to
start designing their own
Xbox controllers. They can
start today by visiting
Xbox .com slash Xbox design
lab. There's tons of
inspirations to choose
from- customisations really
fun. And we're shipping
controllers to U. S. Canada
and most western European
countries. And that these
make great gifts whether
it's for yourself or that
special Gaming your life.
That is fantastic moving
thank you so much for being
here thanks for. Later in
the show. Morals edge will
give us a deeper look. At
age of empires four. But
first. Tim Schafer is
giving us a closer. Look at
Psychonauts two. Hi
everybody I'm Tim Shaffer
from double fine
productions here today take
a deeper look. Into
Psychonauts two seconds to
wasn't action adventure
game starring rescue not
quite a- powerful young
psychic also trained
acrobat who ran away from a
circus home to join the
Psychonauts. And expand and
explore his psychic
abilities one of Russia's
most important thinking
abilities that astral
projection which allows him
to project his psyche into
someone else's mind and see
their mental landscape made
real. He can help them
wrestle with their inner
demons and fight their
actual nightmares in person
which means the levels in
the game are actually
brains and seconds to has
even more brains than the
first game. One of the
first rain you'll get to
visit is that of cal goes
to Lobato the doctor about
I was actually a villain in
the first game. But after
us bottom they kind of
became friends he actually
has a piece of information
that runs once which is who
kidnapped. It was a lot of
and that's a lot of want to
tell you but you can't.
Because of something going
on deep in his unconscious
mind so rest has to travel
along with Sasha and mia
and coach Olander into his
mind and try to extract
that information. There's a
lot of forces at work
inside the bottles mind
maybe put there by someone
else who are trying to stop
you including some of the
enemies that you might
recognize from the first
seconds game including the
sensors entities designed
to stamp out thoughts that
don't belong in someone's
mind. Including rats who
doesn't belong here they
also see a lot of new
enemies such as doubts and
regrets about his mind is
playing with those regrets
and they're very dangerous
for us the mention there's
a lot of teeth have I
mentioned a lot he says
what he's- he's- and what
your dentist. It is no
longer but he really really
likes them locally to fight
all these enemies round let
his psychic powers
including his powerful
psychic punch he has his
hands extends like a V.
from his body into a
powerful melee combo. He
also has a second blast we
can shoot a powerful energy
beam out of his brain
branch also has nvidia
pyrokinesis it's always
handy to be able to burn
things with your mind. And
limitation Raskin uses own
thoughts his own thought
bubble over his head as a
balloon to float around or
ride around on to get
somewhere really quickly.
So with these new powers
Raskin fight all these new
enemies and hopefully find
out. Who kidnapped Truman's
another. Now what she was
thinking. The person. The
second is house forced. The
second end of the second
month. Hollis is also head
of the inter program. Which
is what Raz join now that
he- become. Of the site
month. And he's invited
into. Brains in. Houses him.
A new second. Called mental
connection where you can
see two thoughts in
someone's mind to connect
them. Sometimes trading new
songs making new things
happen. All residents
training in mental
connection inside of houses
middle classroom. He
experimental too far and
accidentally maybe slightly
on purpose creates a lot of
interesting gambling inside
of. Houses mine because he
wants to go on the mission
to the lady looked at this
casino. Unfortunately this
connection leads to more
connections and eventually
the whole thing gets that
arises control and holes
gets. Way too interested in
gambling. And the rest has
to go back into our mind.
Where he finds out that her
memories of medical school.
Where she studied
neurology. Have been
corrupted by this gambling
interests and it becomes a
casino on spittle. And Raz
has to. Actually go in
there and engage with all
these gambling machines in
order to shut it down every.
Turn houses mine back to
normal. She's gonna be just
be really. Inside houses
you'll see bigger tougher
so. That I'm trying to
bouncer instead casino and
also a new enemy called bad
idea about ideas- Spohn
actual nasty looking light
bulbs over their head that
become dangerously
explosive imploded rather.
Face now headquarters one
thing that happens in
seconds to this most
exciting to razz that he
gets to visit the
headquarters of the
Psychonauts themselves.
Which is called the mother
of little. Business center
for all Psychonauts
activity and Raz gets to
see his old friend Sasha
Amira who are councillors
like summer camp in the
first game. He now is a
scene where they work he
gets to see their offices
you can see their labs he
gets to see their co
workers. Other agents in
the field but also he gets
to see the- admin and
maintenance staff as they
go about their business and
hang on the cafeteria. And
serve the everyday
happenings of the- what
life what appears to be
normal in the second World.
Their love little hidden
pathways in treasures
around the base that you
can find. Side quests and
scavenger hunts and things
that you might. First name-
just to meet a lot of fun
things discover a lot of C.
about the second himself
and the law. Of the
founding Psychonauts
including the psychic six.
Who were seen on stumps
around the campfire in the
first game but now we get
to go much deeper into the
story of how they played a
part in the founding of the
Psychonauts- how they were
brought together and
recruited by Ford color.
And turned into this
amazing international.
Espionage force. One thing
that was important the
first games exploring this
natural environment around
the summer camp all the
little hidden paths and
caves where residences took
place. Until the second
game of expanded on that
there's an even bigger
natural environment
multiple natural violence
around the headquarters you
can explore. There's a
quarry outside the mother
load which is where they
dug out this massive
deposits. Attaining inside
him in this. Psycho
reactive mineral that
amplifies and Stan changes
second Parris there's lots
of secrets around the
quarry lots of abandoned
mines and caves and things
to explore. And next door
to the quarry is an
abandoned roadside
attraction called the
questionable area. A sort
of power vortex of strange
happenings which also
caused by the city name
deposits in the area. Water
flows uphill animals behave
strangely. There's caves
dedicated to the mystery of
the sass coops which is a
giant one I being that.
Might have existed might
not have. Here the question
areas Raz's family is
camped out his entire
family. As if to embarrass
him in front of his new
Psychonauts friends. His
family showed up and they
want him back in the
circus. It's turns out
someone's family members
includes I'm father have a
little bit of second power
themselves. And they'll be
exploring that in seconds
to. And you'll get to find
out who put this curse on
Raz's family to dine water.
The quotas have been cursed
by mysterious character to
all dying water and this
manifests itself in the-
form of the hand of
Bolivia. Which is this hand
that comes out of the water
which is really just rises
second construct presence
so afraid of water because
of the curse put on his
family. That every time he
comes near water this
creepy hand comes out and
tries to grab him and pull
him under which is all
happening inside of.
Rather's had. Nine seconds
to you'll get to find out
who put this curse
residents family. Where
came from and what he can
do about it. The store you
will cover about the
courage but I read his
family. Links back into the
store the foundation of the
second month in rats finds
out that his family in the
Psychonauts family. Are
actually- more intertwined
that he believed. So
there's a lot of mystery to
discover for the player-
and wrap. And his. And
friends. As they expo the
can. Between this and this.
A little to do. Molecular
molecular is a- when the
first milliseconds or 5
she's a powerful psychic
and she's a mass murder.
And she's been believed to
be dead for many years but
there's a lot of unknown
things going on behind the
scenes and a lot of
mysteries and a lot of-
plots for the player to
uncover. The second step.
So that's it thanks for
taking a deeper look into
segments to with me the
game is coming out August
twenty fifth. And you can
pre order now. So all stop
talking so you can go and
do that thanks for watching.
This is. Not good not good.
Open the doors and just one
stopping the shooting just
straight to the bridge.
Heavy really we come tanks
I called the bricks from
Latin Brutus we'd sound
smart calling them fruits
you don't you don't wanna
get in here and opening
these not I'm good. Deanna
cruises is looking like a
game I didn't realize I
needed in my life. And here
from straight Bombay to
tell us more about banner
cruises is check Fellers
said. Check thank you for
being here thanks for
having me. Now talk to me
about this game banner
crucis what's the concept
had how did you come up
with this so I grew up with
late sixties early
seventies sci fi I love
that stuff right Logan's
run is- you know Battlestar
Galactica space nineteen
ninety nine that wasn't
cheesy to me or campy that
was just the way sci fi. So
we want to send a game in
that world but we have this
cool colors cool shades
fantastical sci fi weapons
and creatures. But it also
lends itself to wanted
something that was positive
about the players the
characters you're working
together show. There's
aliens sure you're fighting
them sure you're trying to
save earth when you're
doing it in a positive
uplifting way yeah I just
after the pandemic and had
to go back to jury post.
Apocalyptic world I need
something uplifting as we
wanted to deliver that bet
that's awesome now talk to
me about the game play you
you've said that there is
an infinite replayability
to this old so how does
that factor in. Yeah so
this four player co op
you're playing with your
friends and what we wanna
do is make sure that it's
different every time you're
playing at and so we have a
lot of different systems
that do that but underneath
it all is the idea of the
A. I. driver their driver
is driving. Everything
that's happening in the
game with items with a
placed what's happening
with the creatures what's
happening with your health
care it's your perks all
those systems are driven
off fast. And so what that
means is as you're playing
not only do you have those
Hey this last time we
played this was nothing
hearing this time for being
overwhelmed. And then you
also those peaks and
valleys of it you have some
down time and you have
some. Really pick up time
and it. You know brought of
combat happening in it
we're also monitoring how
people are playing so your
first time playing in your
team is doing very well.
Ruppert health kids right
on the main path for you to
find. If you don't find
love at first we'll we'll
Spohn a couple more later
really good if you're
really killing it. Well we
might stop anything on. The
main path so if you want to
go find your- one of the
final. You're to go off
that means. The search for
that make the games a
little bit her. When we
more interest. Wave and-
saying. Hey let's. Double
the health all the- rate.
And then we do something of
the actual what from
specialist. As well. So if
you put same three. Every
week. New government can.
For ten weeks a row. Well
what's- up for you what is
the some crew. You know
seem to. In New. Only we
can do that because you
know. Do different. You've
got to be. Because you
don't have. Before or after
but here. We have these
really big peaks and
valleys would bring you.
Nothing for a little bit.
When I got to go crazy. I
love that it's scaling to
your basically your your
skill level right. So that
yeah that's fantastic now.
Kind of deeper dive more
into the park system that
you're gonna have the game.
So for the parks we looked
at a lot of games were you
start with. Almost a class
based thing and then you
know if you're playing with
the same friends. Well I'm
gonna be support you're
gonna be. Kerry someone
else may help like we can't
ignore what of what systems
were playing. Plan who want
to build a mix it up so
that every time you're
playing you're also. Kind
of. Choosing your role
based on the Ruppert zero
getting some folks coming
this. The automatic
compiler. Define American.
In the world once you find
one. The firm wanted. Foot
choose from. Then over time
you're- bill. A deck for
your for your character.
And so you might have it
where if you sign the
trailer there's a pulse.
Which is kind of like a-
Malay Shah of. Well you can
invest into that and you
could have won that you can
now. Recharge pulls faster.
And now with protects her
FPS- other players around
you. And then it gets more
powerful you can actually
damage with this all the
sudden. You went from being
a support character playing
in the back. To leading the
charge going forward and
knocking down aliens and
everyone else blasting them
more. We got a bunch of
folks that are about.
Almond investing in one
weapon making it where. You
do headshots that actually
does damage other aliens
rounds to now you're the
sniper hanging back. This
is really mixing up that
kind of experience that
you're having and you'll
earn these perks as you
place the more you play the
more perks you have. But
since we want the. Game to
always be great player
friends. If you. If you've
playing there also. Put me
on a plane for hundred
hours. Your brain. New yeah
well we sure the perks. So
you get all the perks that
I am very. To me well so.
When you hit. That X. of
all the crazy. Your game as
well. Because I about
having fun with your-
right. The share experience.
With friends now. We can
already talk about the
inspirations like by two
thousand. I look at that it
was like two thousand one
space Odyssey was the first
thing I thought of. But
let's talk more about the
enemies in the game what
what was on the
inspirations for that. So
the enemies- is we kind of
look at it of how we want
the players to behave. As
well as feel. In sweeping
outside Plato's every week
the player game. Watch them
and what we see is. Really
good teams that stick
together really tightly.
And even if you send
something like the brew
that demonstrates apart.
They took. The form back
together. So we created
some. Spohn yeah. This is a
good. Of kind of. We have.
The design. The spotter you
hear off the distance. And
you know what it's doing is
finding things on these
little tarts the comment
you're not the worst thing.
But they're gonna be
unrelenting until you kill
the spotter. In so you'll
be sticking with your team
to be like oh wait a minute
if spotter comes now in
this turrets common we've
got a guy download over
there. Mr committeeman go
hunt that thing down a
little killer single run
off you kill you feeling
good about it Nelson
realize what were my
teammates I'm all alone the
other specials here all I'm
in trouble. Mr create those
kind of moments words
mixing it up we're you
always want to have it were
kind of the almost takes
turns of 1 players. The
last one surviving there
the last one up in there
helping everybody else up
and get it going and so
really looking at having
those enemies give you.
Those moments for how it
affects the players. Honest
question for you. What does
the ana crucis actually me
so any criticism term it
means the notes before the
song little bit little kind
of intro therefore this we
have a character boards
that you never meet- and
the other Parris talk about
it because I was fun to
have this character that
you never really far sure.
Who they are because it's I
don't know subscribing it.
And she our name the barge
that you're on the launch
these missions Deanna
crucis. And sure Bob there
was this is not the main
event is not us against the
eight millions with fighter
pilots and everything else
is just regular people.
This is the free battle to
the battle is finding out
about the ceilings and what
just happened. That sounds
old school again the
increase the everything
that you talked about today
it sounds amazing I can't
wait to get my hands on it
but- Chad. Thank you so
much. For being here really
appreciate thanks for
having me. We've got so
much more coming in today
show including. Obsidian
entertainment with
grounded. By illusions and
let it roll with shredders.
And three four three
industries with a deeper
dive on that incredible
multiplayer trailer for
halo infinite. But first.
The original stalker was
one of the most intense in
theory gains a bit. Next
year we returned it to
mobile for soccer to.
Exactly from GSC game world
as a closer look at the
game. Let's check it out.
Hi everyone it's Zack from
GSC game world it has been
several days since the game
player you off still
occurred to our game now
has a subtitle heart of
Chernobyl and the release
date of April twenty eight
two thousand twenty two by
the way the pre orders are
open for both PC and Xbox
you're obviously here
reeling to learn more so
here are several details
about stalker to heart of
Chernobyl you probably
didn't know yet. So let's
dive a little bit deeper in
our trailer. This section
of the trailer is the
bandits gun fight on the
chemical plant. You can see
the actual in game
animations of picking up
the weapons and installing
modifications on the go.
The thing is you can note
to the desert open your
faction we are not showing
the exact moment right now
because we wonder if you
can discover it yourself.
You may actually recognize
the exact location on the
swamps if you played
stalker clear sky you may
remember this place the
time did the job but the
tower is definitely still
there. Also in the scene
you can see a venue
detector skiff is using for
the art of our times.
Because if it's warm it's
cold you'll K. which
actually means a brunch in
the Ukrainian. The artifact
skip is going to collect
it's called jelly in game
it recovers your stamina.
Moving to the dancing Nancy
in before you ask it yes
there will be a lot of
characters with an
interesting fate in the
zone. His hideout is
located in Chernobyl to.
That's a download so far
from pretty bad you have
seen in the gameplay teaser.
We do. But they had no it
about group led by. Some
reports. That campfires a
small pile of safety in the
unwelcoming zone in place
where you can finally have
a little rest before
another four eight. You
have seen the campfire
during the first trailer in
the Ruka village of course
it wasn't the only one. His
own is full of dangers and
mutants. The monsters as a
result of the numerous
experiments. We're not
ready to show you all of
them so let's stick to the
old good blood sucker for
now. Should I if you need
more coverage is PC was
misty. Michael highgam
lovely snowboard not but
Golgi. Sent to Japan plus
much and I need. Yes yeah
yeah W. you come sort of
the lumias trees moreover
you Razer Razer. About the
vehicle itself. Yeah this
is you. In rooftop scene we
had for proud of that
because of animation. We
made a small behind the
scenes we deal our motion
capture studio. The face
photogrammetry process
makes the final result as
close to the reality as
possible. Michael highgam
lovely snowboard not by
college. Yeah sh. The guy
was gone you're seeing in
this section is one of the
most powerful weapons from
the arsenal. Reporter
equipped with the P. forty
fifty moving to the final
thing for today the man at
the end of the trailer is
Sergi Grigorovich the
creator of the stalker
Sirius the- stock. Thanks
for joining us today we
can't wait for the moment
when the time comes to
enter the zone on April.
Twenty eight two thousand
twenty two. As you just saw
stalker two is shaping up
to be something special and
I can't wait to play it
next year when it comes to
Xbox PC thank GamePass on
day one. On Sunday we saw
the trailer for a plague
tale requiem. The sequel to
the award winning a plague
tale in a sense and for
those of you who are fans
of the original we've got
some good news for you to.
E3 was what would you.
The
king is back and here to
tell us more about age of
empires four our Adam ice
cream and M. a bridal from
world's edge thank you both
for being here thanks for
having us on absolutely.
The legacy excited for this
now you had some news at
the briefing can you kind
of talk about that a little
more well I mean fans got
to have their first looks
at two more of our line
civilizations- the Addison
dynasty and the French yes
and they bring a lot to the
table- totally different
ways to play but I'm really
excited to show them those
and then also people got to
see their first taste of
naval gameplay. I which we
haven't shown off at all
except for a little teaser
at the end of fan preview
paying off that teased and
we also revealed one more
about campaigns the hundred
years war and that
Jordan Voght made an
appearance at we also
announced that the game is
coming October twenty
eighth and it's coming to
windows store steam and of
course the boss PC. Earlier
you mentioned the two
civilizations the Abbas a
dynasty and the French can
kind of go into detail
about that- yeah I guess
I'll start- the absence of
the opposite dynasty is
this amazing technological
powerhouse of a
civilization that has a
really unique mechanic that
we're bringing to- them in
age of empires Ford's
actually unique- across all
the cities that are in the
game in it they they
construct this bastion of
knowledge called house of
wisdom and they can keep
upgrading it with different
wings and it gives them a
host of incredible
technologies. That leverage
their army either Connie
their resources- but beyond
even that they have the
incredible amount of fund
units- especially campus
unique to the Sims again at
the license Razer parts for
his camera units and these
camels how amazing-
believes the boss the other
units and their armies and
so you have these wonderful
diverse mixes where you
always want me throwing
different units together
but always including camels
for the different kinds of
Boston advantages you can
give- tears in to your
civilization's great. And
the French a really really
strong with trade out some
great option that Gaming a
late game really really
interested. They have a
michael highgam hers
Commons. And units you
really to focus on nights
and lan says they use a
power. Is but the French
actually made appeal
appearance in the trailer.
As of hundred years war
campaign and as you can see
Joan there I'm actually
wearing around my neck
she's a feminist icon from
history. This young woman
who leads with her
convictions and led to. A
battle and she was a
teenager and so she's
beloved she's in H. two in
a campaign and so we know a
trans gonna love seeing her
again. And the hundred
years war. With it multiple
missions like the battle of
the thirty. Really going to
bring that period of
history to life and all the
live action footage that
you saw in the trailer on
Sunday. That's all from
within the game we have
these multiple
documentaries that will
play between the missions.
To storytelling really
bring it to life as you
journey through the hundred
years war yeah taking a
completely different
approach to Howard- telling
stories. In fact I don't
think I've seen any games
knows what we're doing in
terms of how we're showing
the story how we're getting
people involved. With
history so it really.
Really brings it to life
and- I've learned things
about English history from
these documents you I
didn't learn in school so.
Educating is as well as
moving the game for it. Now
community feedback is
always important in in any
game but especially in
something like age now how
do you take in some of that
feedback and development
for it for. So we formed a
community council back in
twenty seventeen we wanted
our community a place to
have a seat at the table
for development when making
the game for them. So
they've been hands on with
the game for a really long
time and giving us their
honest feedback and we then
take that to the game team.
And they look at making
changes based on what
they've told us so they've
influenced things from. The
look at the Y. icons the
influence system that's
built into age for. They
really really helped us
with a few points make the
GamePass a- one thing they
really pushed for actually
with naval. Yeah it's
amazing- we actually you
know if you look at a lot
of the data you know we see
data on all of the-
vampires games people play.
And naval is one of those
things the- in H. two a lot
of people. Use which is
crazy. But if it wasn't.
People wouldn't it so. And
sometimes we have to ask
those hard questions were
making games ratings they
like to eat do we need to
do this and it was
something that we felt.
Weird about it and we went
to the council with they
were like Hey. You know.
Even you guys don't play
name all the time like this
do we need it and then I
can only see your point but
you know you have to have
the- and- it was great it
was a great reaffirmation-
and we throw a lot of
things like that are
counsel to make sure that
we're making the game.
That's great for all the
different kinds of players
that love age of empires
all over the world. And now
heading towards lunch yeah
we're branching out beyond
the kinds of people gonna
get hands on for the first
time so we had a fan
preview event back in
April. And we look to the
feedback from that and made
changes since then so. You
know you let us know that
you didn't feel like the
weapons scaling is quite
right so we- had we've been
pretty. That is fantastic
now you actually hit on
something. That I want to
jump in. Because H. as been
around for a while. If
there's been previous games
but you continue to make
content for those so. What
some of the news you can
sure as far as development
with some of the legacy H.
games. Well we have a new
expansion coming in August
for H. two definitive
edition called on and the
dukes. And in that
expansion we're gonna be
adding two more
civilizations the Bohemians
in the polls. And three new
campaigns for the
Lithuanians the peak unions
in the polls another great.
Great stories about. Really
cool like- brother brother
brother and sister teams
that work together to kind
of rise of these empires
and I can't wait. For
people to get a hand their
hands on it. And the great
thing is that if you pre
order age of empires four.
And you get that for free
that's part of the deal for
pre ordering H. for on. On
the. Different platforms.
And- for H. three of.
Because we- leave. Out in-
H. three to. Were hardware.
On an African PLC with new
civilizations in campaigns.
And I can't wait. To to
show more we're not ready
to. To talk about that one
just yet. But if you don't
miss out. Go to age of
empires .com to come inside
it you get little sneak
peeks of things we've got
coming and chance to get
hands on with content. Yeah
now Shiffrin is back to the
present in H. four. What
some of the things people
can expect as we lead up to
launch. Well we've got a
bit of an exclusive for you
today. Is we- yeah we're
gonna name our remaining
loans saves an hour meeting
launch campaigns in order
to show them just yet
that'll come closer to
launch but ought to
remaining civilizations. Of
the holy Roman Empire and
the roofs. The names of our
two remaining campaigns on
the rights of Moscow the
Mongol empire. All that yes
transaction please no no I
was gonna say I'm so
excited I can get all. It's
like this- we're gonna have
to wait a little more to
add to get information and
see more detail on those
civilizations in campaigns
but- we're also got you
know a ton of stuff planned
we have a beta that's going
to be coming up. So you
know you can go to age of
empires dot com to sign up
for it need be an insider
to get in our beta and get
a chance to actually get
hands on with the game. And
then of course again you
know we're launching
October twenty eight Hey.
Donna long to wait on- you
know on steam on windows
ten and on GamePass for PC
so it should be great
anyway you want to play.
Which really excited that
it then that is great and
I'm sure age fans all
around the world are really
looking forward to that so.
Again Adam Emma thank you
so much for being here
thanks for having us on. No
thank you. Massive battles.
Across land air and sea.
Have been a hallmark of the
battlefield series from the
beginning. In this next
video. Design director
Daniel Berlin. Will tell us
more about what dice can do
when it brings all out
warfare. To the world's
most powerful console. The
thing that really excites
players is the introduction
of all this cutting edge
technology that would just
if using. Into the sandbox
I think of having to come
back of the helicopter. On
the battlefield that's just
introduces a whole new
layer to the sandbox it
just gives players. So much
more tools that makes it
more battlefield than it's
been in a very long time.
We really enable our
players to be really really
creative with the tools we
give them an answer about a
fearless this is kind of
all about being in a
massive open. For setting.
And being able to say like
Hey there's a problem over
there go solve it and the
players actually choose.
How they want to solve that
problem and through that
process crater on
battlefield moments. Sun
twenty forty two you will
experience three really
distinct experiences- the
one we're talking about
right now we're talking
about today. Is the
experience of a call to all
out warfare experience that
this is the place you go in
twenty forty two when you
want to have those classic
battlefield experiences
this massive war. Worries
you know air land and sea
just coming together in
these massive battles but
we've actually made a
distinction between two
separate experiences with
in they all out warfare-
well for a franchise it's
something that our fans
know and love. And we're
just taking the confidence
to the Max this time around
Congress is all about- the
freedom the access to the
sandbox being able to
choose where you fight how
you fight where you want to
go. But it's also
experienced that- will
allow players to kind of
shoes their own pacing and
there's moments in
concourse where it's
complete chaos when a lot
of players just FPS
converts from a single
point. And the chaos goes
up to Max. But there's also
within conquest where you
know you just had that big
battle and now you 1 that
probably going to okay you
bring up your map and you
have a conversation with
your friends and you said
OK when we want to go next
all. We need to go over
there to that state okay
how do we get there all
let's call in a vehicle a
vehicle you can. Call
anywhere you want and then
your friends hopped the
transport vehicle you go
across the top you go to a
new look. What is the new
so Congress is just that
for free to this. And right
to live- the other
experience within our war
for which is a break for.
And this is this. More died
the next. It takes- pointed.
Through our the and mac.
And in break there so
attacker. And there's a
different team- and we
cannot confirm them into
fighting had a- in a- space
with a that that. To is
short and a lot of care is
real really high there's
HELOC. And there's hang in
does every happening and
it's just come chaos break
for so all out war for
Kenneth these two.
Favorites mon and we make
them the state. Liana their
space strength and that's
on a series mac and the-
series yes you will
actually be able to PC- all
that work experience up to
one. And twenty eight
players which a double to
what we do in the and if.
And this is really you know
you can have those moments
when playing for forty two
when you see in the house.
And look down in the see
this you know. Of tanks
Seoul. In front. Hello. You
know just making it bigger
and then portion that the
locations that that doesn't
really work that way so we
leaned into a new type of
design without ever calling
clustering. Now it's
clustering means that
you'll have a massive
battle field in front of
you. But within this
massive battlefield you
have particular clusters of
objectives so the map
hourglass is set in Doha
Qatar. And it is I'm not
gonna go into the specifics
about exactly how large it
is- but it is definitely
one of the larger- maps
that we will have an twenty
forty two. It's one of my
favorite math personally
because it has some really
really cool distinct
locations within it. Down
to the south of the map
you'll have a- fully
destructible- village this
is a great space for
infantry and vehicles alike
because you know that's
about if you're fired at
infantry skulking around
the sides of buildings but
you know when you're in
your tank right tackle like
offer you can doesn't. You
know can destroy those
buildings you get access to
the infantry and you can go
further east than you'll
find a bunch of high rises
skyscrapers so there's a
whole section there were
you content to discuss
gamer should go up to the
top of them you can sip
line between the rooms.
Have fights in between the
rooftops but if you want
change up even more you can
basically skydive office
skyscrapers and if you're
playing a particular
specialist that has access
to a wing suit. You can
actually glide across the
entire map space and get
yourself all the way over
to the stadium which is on
the east side of the map.
And at the stadium itself
it's a place you go when
you really want to just
take out your shock on and.
Have some close quarters
combat. So the Mattel. Here
of. Build larger maps but
create. Locate with the mac.
Where there's a taking a
type of gameplay and with
the conquest game mode for
example. You will also see
the fact that if you want
to capture. The entirety of
the stadium. It's not just
to go there to capture one
occasion. Yes you have to
capture multiple locations
within the stadium in order
Future cannot. To consider
it your is that your team
can actually get benefits
from. So lots of dynamic
moments on our glass if you
saw on the gameplay trailer
as well there's a massive.
Wall of sound moving across
the entire GamePass 5. So
what happens when is
massive all kinds of course
and golf you. In the storm
itself. But acid passes by
leaves that the entirety of
the map in a different mood
in a different light. In
exchange is the visibility
for the player. It is a
really good time for you to
lean into our plus system
we have the capability to
actually. Alter the
customization on your
weapon. I also like to
mention that the wall of
sound is one thing right
but there's also the
possibility. Of a tornado.
The tornado is this
massive. Destructor that
just comes into play space
and it wherever it goes.
Destruction follows this of
massive- moving physical
entity that will pick you
up. For- you across the map
full helicopters into it-
it's just a crazy fun
physics experience that
happens ask you play them
up so. Everything is in the
hands of the player this
really is a sandbox. And
these moments are in the
hands of the player well in
other games about a few
moments our- pre scripted.
Our game. If they just
happen and happen
differently every single
time because it's- players
controlling. What's
happening around here
that's something that you
only get in battlefield.
That's that's why I love
battlefield so much.
Catholic action at an epic
scale is what we all want
from battlefield twenty
forty two and dice looks
poised to deliver. During
the showcase on Sunday we
announce an exciting
collaboration between rare
Xbox and Disney. With see
it be a pirate's life a
free update which brings
captain Jack sparrow and
his crew sailing into the
sea at the- today we're
premiering a brand new
trailer showing some of the
gameplay. You'll experience
when you team up with
Jacksboro for this all new
adventure I can't wait to
be a part of this group
let's take a look. Remember
your group was joined by.
Check. To see if they
because a lot of. The world
at six I. Is one of the C.
now we have a we. Eight
eight on the Pollard. I
think you've taken tumble
on everyone's on their feet
as I. This is the place
where everyone appreciates.
Uniqueness. You may. David
Jones this is. Hi lights.
He's. They'll be hi. What
evidence house you it's not
true. Unless it's
flattering in which case
it's all true but they left
out the best. Sorry hi
everyone Joni exit use on
see if so we show this in
trailer we've shown game
they try to this more come
so Sunday at eleven AM this
to eastern seven you can at
eight PM in Europe we have
to see if the user pirates
like show. So this is a way
deep dive Justin order to
detain but this caliber
with Disney did we bring
Jacksboro install well how
do we capture humanist. An
older the kind of character
that are coming in as a
politics unique a first
look at the couple of tiles
and up to game play of
those gonna get some behind
the scenes interviews with
our development team and
also just to chat with us
with Disney just about how
this collaboration came to
be so it's going to be
amazing. Everybody seems in
so we'll see once. On the.
I'm ready for the dangers.
We'll get to that in just a
second. One microsoft
flight simulator launched
last year on PC reviewers
and gamers alike were blown
away by the stunning
visuals and the depth of
simulation joining us is
your Newman the head of
microsoft flight simulator
your thank you for being
here really appreciate.
Good to meet you those are
cool glass. You get your
jacket yeah that is well so
you have some announcements
is Sunday about microsoft
lights and later can you go
into that a little bit that
was super cool enough Mike
is a flight simulator is
coming to Xbox series X.
and S. and the franchise
has an awesome history on
the PC it's going back all
the way to nineteen eighty
two. You know it predates
office and windows and-
Bungie launched last year
on it was on the PC only
and it was a really warm
welcome from seminars and
from press and from people
have never flown flights in
before. So we're super
excited that it comes to
console now and- so for the
first time in the history
of the franchise. So I've
been playing for a similar
since last year on PC I
have a thirty eighty but is
now coming to the Xbox
series X. and S. what
sorcery are you doing to
get this running on both of
those consul at the mill I
think it's a combination of
two things really mad.
First off it's a super
powerful contest and then
we are you really using the
top microsoft tech stock in
an interesting way so as
you know. Sirius XM as a is
like a beast the jeep he
was awesome super powerful
CPU with multiple cores-
ram fast ram we can run
four K. that's super
important for plans yes he
said that the **** but you
need to be able to read all
the text SST. Fast internet
so it's basically the
equivalent of a really
powerful hi and PC and on
top of that on flights and
we're using the microsoft
stock a lot like we have
two point five petabytes of
data. It's one point six
million C. visa- sitting on
out on and- basically
streaming that down as you
go and- we also do machine
learning algorithms up
there and that's how we
build procedurally in one
time one point five billion
houses and two trillion
trees so it's a combination
of those two things will
pop a consul. Super good
use of the michael highgam
of tech stocks you get it
to work on council that is
fantastic now with Xbox
game pass and with the
coming to console you're
gonna expose flight
simulator to all a lot of
new gamers right so. What
are some of the things that
you're going. To do to make
it more accessible to why
our audience. We got. Took
exact what we had a little
bit of. Last we launched
because we knew the flights
most. This hobbies came in
know everything ABA. That
exactly to do but had a lot
of people in so. GamePass
on PC. And basically tried
for the first time so we-
even on the PC launch we
did a bunch of work on. On
boarding this to Tory oils
would get some assistance
us but not for this Xbox
version. We're actually
doing a ton more. Nash
brought you little video-
and so this 5 things we did
the first thing. If you are
becoming a pilot the first
thing you do is. You do a
discovery flights. It's
basically you know that.
You have a flight
instructor next to you he
does most of the work
usually. And you get to
steal the plan and feel.
Good about yourself right
and so we said we need to
recreate that so we picked
to put ten places on earth
like some of the most
compelling places like.
Mount Everest. Or we are
there's a narrow or New
York or the pyramids. And
be busy put you on a plane
it's ready to go it's
beautiful weather and all
you need to do. Is fly and
have fun and it's it really
is an onboarding experience
a super good. And then we
noticed on the PC side that
people I really love to
explore the world flotsam I
did that I've- I spent like
a month in South America
and I've- never been to
South America and was super
cool- but- it was only
visuals. And it also you
didn't quite understand how
everything fits together so
now he added labels. And
being as all these labels
basically for every for
every- I like. Famous plays
a riff off a mountain. So
we have all those Namco.
And we put that into the
world map. It is. If you go
down. And you. To play out
your fly you can always.
All the cities around you.
It's totally transforms.
Expiry same in in game so
we now have labels in gamer
you see you. You know he
has averaged over there so
you know what. Whatever the
and you learn about the
planet more and it's a much
more enriching experience.
Just just experiencing the
planet however. Absolutely
the next thing we did- is
the B. B. B. ramp the
toilets you wanted to
spacey's. Smoothing out the
at the onboarding
experience we wanted to
retain knowledge more. So
we had a tutorial on the PC
even though we have twenty
two. And it's they're sort
all that much more focused.
And we have a performance-
a performance indicator
system so basically it
rates you and how you did.
And you get a score. And
honestly I can speak for
myself like I'm totally
motivated to get better and
better and better and-
without you learn more and
more how do you. How you
really fly. So it's been
super successful and I
think it's going. To help
newcomers a lot. The next
feature that we have is.
Called fly this. Which I
use a lot- it's basically.
Cincinnati flyover York.
Then you see. You 1
actually just look at the
landscape at lunch look at
the city but you. You know
it eventually want to go to
Brooklyn Bridge on that
flight instructor you can
now. 5 system you can now
click on. Go to Brooklyn
Bridge and the A. I. almost
like a cool part it next to
you. Will fly you. To the
Brooklyn Bridge you can
just look around enough. An
interesting time. Same with
airports which are
sometimes. Challenging for
people like me you can
click on the open so please
land yet SCEI Newark
airport. And then the last
thing is if you really get
in some trouble like. Stall
out the plane or something
like that you can actually
now click into. Yeah you
can now go and basically
say we cover. And it's
almost like the pundits
sitting next to super
helpful I think that people
will love it. And the last
thing was- you know. We
learned that people are.
Everybody is good taking
off but some people are
hesitant to lance yes if
you give a you look at like
big international airports
they seem scary and- you
talk to the- traffic
control and all that super
technical. So. We added a
new feature called manager
where. Just let. Them land.
And then and when you do
that the for. Thing you see
is. 71% of the- just water.
Yes so we added basically
floats to a bunch of our
plans. And you can. All
everyone on the ocean or in
reverse- ever. Same with
snow. So we have skis and
ski on on our plans now
it's you can go to the
polar regions mon top so
when it's winter because we
have we done. Been snowing-
you can now land anywhere
so I think those 5 things
in combination will really
make it. Easier for people
who have never been in a
flight sim because it's-
you know we- we- B. as it
made a decision not to.
Dumb down the flights and
it's not easy off it's not
gamer Feyerick we made me
get a few assist me give
assistance is. To help you
learn how to actually play
5. Plan I think we're going
to achieve that. So one
thing I'm PC is there's a
ton. Flight accessories
that you can use as far as
various peripherals and
controls. What are you
going to be able to bring.
To the console beckon
somewhat replicate that
experience. Totally as a
good news story- so there's
two really good flight
sticks already on the
consul it's the
Thrustmaster T. flight
HOTAS one. But you have
that and then there's also
the whole T. hotels flights
yet and so we fully support
those two. And then we work
with all the main. Top
notch the parental make us
both on PC and Xbox. And I
can all I can say is there
going to be some really
good announcements coming
out and a four course
similar I can say. You can
now play we have the
software to have a full
course of expense and we'll
have the hardware on Xbox.
All for the first time on a
consul it's gonna be great.
That's going to be great
now but we obviously had
the funniest start with
with the Top Gun maverick
expansion pack you announce
that. But can you go into a
little more detail about
that yeah I mean expect. We
couldn't be more excited
right like it I mean it's
really like a dream come
true if you think about
entertainment and- the
franchise that celebrate
aviation you will actually
come to michael highgam
flights amid a- and- and-
Top Gun. And did the it's a
perfect marriage so- I
can't say that much about
it because the movie. This
is you know kids
everything's under wraps
but if you look if you
watch a trailer carefully
solder some F. eighteens.
And there's an aircraft
carrier. That might be
another plan. And then I
can say is we're going to
go fast let me get in fast
and we're going to be in
the danger zone. With that
is one that is going to be
great really looking
forward to that now as we
wrap this up. There's not
much else you can say about
the maverick expansion pack
but what else can people
expect from flight
simulator in the near
future. A lot so- ever
since launch we said we're
going to launch we're gonna
launch you have a new
update like a big
meaningful update every
single month. We launched
nine months ago we had nine
updates- so we have
something is called world
updates we just because on
on ours. Like the United
States and Japan or- and
like England and Ireland.
Have you make that we-
battle likely get the
latest positive. Boss
sublet a- B. B. credit and
elevation map that business
makes the mountains look
better with me make. We
create CD cities like.
After lunch for lunch
London and Paris. And then
we also make mission so we
celebrate the planet. Like
with these updates which is
going to go on the planet.
What we do we're shipping
to more this year and six
more next year. And then.
We also have something
called sim updates
simulation updates we work
with the manufacturers of
planes. With the floods in
community out there that
knows tons about
everything. And also with
me. With with we will
pilots and build but
basically making the sim
better and better the goal
is to make the ultimate
center. It's the perfect
thing off totally
authentic. And then. On top
of that you should expect
the unexpected. Like best
just like with maverick
which I don't think people
really got saw coming. That
would be more of that and I
think I all I can say is.
It'll get the GamePass. And
the Simoes both the hearts
pounding so. Keep watching
the skies. That is awesome
now. Again I'm so excited
that more people are gonna
get to play flight
simulator. I've been
playing it on PC. I love
it. I highly recommend
everyone to the flight from
LA to Parris it's really
good very cathartic. But as
we get out here. I want to
thank you. So much for
taking some time to talk
about flight simulator.
Can't. Wait for the
expansion. Thank you so
much. Thank you. Still to
come we have grounded sh
and of course hello
infinite but first one of
the best games of twenty
twenty with Haiti's and
it's got a ton of awards to
prove it here's a closer
look at what we can expect
from supergiant games later
this year X. Xbox Series X.
X. and- we just announced
that Hades our game of the
year winning roguelike
dungeon crawler is coming
soon to Xbox and I want to
introduce you to some of
the gods ghosts and
monsters you'll meet in our
rendition of the ancient
Greek underworld. You don't
need any prior interest in
Greek myth to get into
Hades but as you play maybe
I'll get to wondering how
much of the stuff comes
from anthology. The answer
is the whole lot. Greek
myth is filled with wild
fascinating often
contradictory stories of
these larger than life
characters the Olympians
are a big complicated
family always bickering and
always pushing each other.
In their portrayals in
classical mythology
inspired our portrayals in
Haiti's. Let's start with
Hades himself. What is it.
He's often relegated to the
role of the villain in many
modern adaptations of Greek
myth but in classical
mythology he's a
complicated guy and much
more principle than some of
his brothers or sisters
it's so fascinating we made
a whole game about a- as
the god of the dead. Hades
has an imposing reputation
to live up to so he even
has a monstrous pet. In the
three headed hound of hell
server. The idea that the
savage beast was still
somebody's pet dog
crystallized how we wanted
to portray the gods in
Haiti's. But despite being
immortal and all powerful
they're not so different
from the rest. So let's not
forget Zacarias. We've
heard from many players who
figure exactly this was a
god of our own creation.
After all. Was ever heard
of Haiti's having any kids.
But according to some
ancient sources he did.
Greetings from the-
transaction was a delight
thank you for asking. So
I'll just be on my way
again. In classical
mythology Zacarias is a
little known Cuthona god.
Meeting a god of the
underworld sometimes
associated with Dionysus
the god of wine. But in
other cases he is
associated with Haiti's.
How could Hades have a son
nobody knows about. How
does he fit into the myths
we do know of Haiti's. We
were so drawn to answering
these questions that they
form the basis for the
entire story of this game.
If you're the prince of the
underworld. Could you get
as a personal trainer. That
would be a Kelly's near
invincible warrior and a
state once called the
greatest of the Greeks.
Right this. It's raining
out that. Yeah. Cady's
place after untimely to
during Trojans once he's a
lot time to reflect on his
life choices Achilles lived
in glory so he's got an
okay gig in the afterlife
but some wretched souls end
up in a really bad spot in
the underworld and for
better or worse they get to
meet. Mac first of. Ninety
nine what might make you
reconsider whatever it is
tempting she is one of the
three ferry sisters tasked
with torturing some of the
absolute worst souls for
all eternity and in our
game she's also tasked with
making sure Zacarias
doesn't make it out of the
underworld these two have a
lot of history and since
the story of Haiti's keeps
moving forward each time
you play the more you run
into Megara the better
you'll get to know her.
There's also founded. Since
decide to drop in on you
when he isn't busy whisking
the souls of the recently
departed to the underworld.
If you could just get away
from me did you. He is the
personification of death
according to Greek myth.
The represents more of a
peaceful death and say the
kind that happened a lot.
During something like a
Trojan War. So even though
he can seem a little
sinister at first. In the
spirit of the mythology we
wanted our senators to have
a gentler side. Senator
says a couple of brothers
in Haiti such as hypnosis
here. The personification
of sleep. Says one of the-
when he's not dozing on the
job hypnosis can comment on
every single possible way
you can die in this game of
the dozens and dozens of
different possibilities.
Where did all these gods of
the underworld come from
anyway. According to the
Theogony an ancient Greek
creation myth by Hestia
that introduces all the
gods and their ancestors
many of the confining gods
came from mix the
personification of nine.
This guy to child. This
house no Sir. Should you
return again here you see
she is a primordial goddess
meaning she is much older
even than Hades or the
Olympians and in our game
she has an important role
in the underworld not the
least of which is helping
you unlock some of your
hidden power. There are
thirty different characters
to meet and grow closer to
the more you play Haiti's
and we hope you enjoyed
getting to know the mall.
Some of them feel truly
ancient and got like some
are funny some are scary.
We found them incredibly
inspiring and hope you do
too once you get to meet
everybody when Haiti's
comes to Xbox one and
series X. on August
thirteenth.
The first
school.
To this is the holy
laundering with.
Here to
tell us more about the
grounded update Adam
inherit from obsidian
entertainment gentleman
thank you so much for being
here thanks for having us
it's a pleasure to be here
as our honor no absolutely
love grounded love
everything that you guys
have been doing with it now
my first question is this
mushroom system what can
you tell me about that yeah
so that's one of the big
things for the Sherman do
update is on mushrooms are
really changing how that
the- yard is with mushrooms
every mushroom that you see
in the yard is now
harvestable. Which is
really cool so the small
ones and big ones the big
toad stools the ones that
you find in caves now those
are present in the yard
before but now you can
actually harvest them- get
mushroom- stuff out of
them- the next kind of-
part of that is that- we're
adding a couple base
building elements- white
mushroom bricks in so you
have to take all those
mushrooms that you find.
And then you have to grind
them up in a grinder which
is a new building and then
you have to take them to
your other than which is
another new building that
we're adding and- bake the
mushroom- stuff into bricks
and then- with the mushroom
brick buildings there's a
whole host of new options
for base builders- minutes
more fortified walls- in a
bunch of other options so
you can build a cool big
castle. All that's really
cool now we saw the brood
mother so you're bringing
bosses into grounded what
can you tell me about that
what does that mean for the
direction of the game as we
move forward yes so- the
print others are first
Boston on that so we do we
actually launched with the
primer there- and we didn't
really feel it hit the
right mark so we took the
birth mother out and we
want to spend a lot of time
making it a really
memorable boss fights. So
we put a lot of development
after in a behind the brew
mother and it's going to
really feel like a big huge
fight in a memorable one-
there's a lot of kind of
cool things with it I don't
wanna spoil everything I
want players to kind of
experience it for
themselves but- it
definitely is something
that we want our players
feedback- to see like what
do they like what do they
not like how is. The
challenge that we want to
make it really challenging.
I which and- a good reward.
For the- mother but- it's
it going to be is it too
hard- we'd like to. That so.
Well for featured in. On
like. We want to make more
bosses and so we want to
get all that feedback to
improve the system. Now you
actually bring up a great
point about community bill
put a pin in that. Come
back to. The second so. I
know you don't want to
spoil anything about the
brood mother but- is there
any tips you can kind of
give people ahead of time
what they can do to survive
that encounter. I would
definitely say that he
would need to make sure you
have the highest your
armor. Yeah really well for
this site because it is
going to be difficult. And
then- you also have the
right mutations equipped as
well- and- if you're
playing with your friends-
it might be good to. For
when your friends or
yourself to. Use the brand
new crossover gonna put
into the game so you have
some range D. P. as well
someone else like base
things the brilliance of
the particle. That's pretty
cool so again going back to
community I know you love
getting feedback about
grounded obviously starting
as an early access game
but- what are some of the
things that you're looking
for as far as- in this.
This update is what was
something that you got
feedback wise. From the
community that you put in
this update. Yes so there's-
a you know that's why thing
that. We love working with
community sites that's
something that we will as
developers we love just
hearing what people have to
say about the game and
worse continually
developing it with the
community- so there's a lot
of. New things in our in
our new update. On one of
those things is- slipping
buildings- and that's one
thing that we really. Like
just adding like those
little features another one
is just sprinting up.
Ladders which is something
that like. You know just
hearing people how they
interact with ladders on
adding a sprint mode. The
other one is. One of our-
funny or features that
we're adding is sitting in
chairs. So it's something.
That a lot of people really
really wanted- they were
also interesting like the
first phase. Of take pets
in the game so we're gonna
start with a fade so you'll
be able to tame a fade.
Always run around the yard
with a family also to make
sure your protector if it
because accidents can
happen. Mac yard other
there's on one other thing
to achievements. So we're
really excited to announce
that we have an amazing
grounded and that's- that's
purely based on everyone's
feedback everyone's been
wanting achievements. And
so we're finally adding
them to the games. That's
really good. Now it. Again
sticking with this- the
topic of community so this
was an early access game.
And it sounds like pretty
much the foundation of what
ground it is was built. Off
of community feedback so.
How does that process work
internally for you as far
as- people's meaning like
Hey I like I want to sit.
You know I want to keep. It
but how does that whole
process work. We have a lot
of. Bungie avenues where we
gathered feedback from the
community so we have. We do
weekly developer streams
where. Jack and ask much of
questions with one half
Adam on- other developers
are myself- and we'll get.
Gathered feedback
assertions there and then.
Our main source of feedback
as to our official discord.
I granted the game. I
handle- we I hate use a
series of bots. To gather a
bunch of feedback from the
players and then. From
there- me Adam- couple
members of team and from
also from the community
teams team gets together.
And we have a weekly
meeting going over all the
suggestions and- kind of
prioritizing what will work
and what we can but we can
put. Later in a few. For
the other such. Excellent
gentleman. Thank you so
much for taking some. To go
talk to me about this new
update for ground it. Looks
like a lot of fun I'm gonna
get to sit I guess. That's
great. Thank you so much.
It's been often. It's
almost time. For a closer
look. At the multiplayer
trailer. For halo infinite.
But first. It's time to see
what the snow. The slopes.
And the powder springs.
Look like. When powered by
Xbox he respects. And S.
this is shredders. Hey
there and welcome to the
stream for you'll get an
extra glimpse on our
snowboard game that's
called shredders. And there
shall well then project
lead that phone bunch.
Hello this is mark is for
small take the lead on
shredders stumbled upon.
Yeah you've probably seen
or trailer at the Xbox
event. We've been tinkering
on this game for a while
now while it's still in
development we're happy to
show you more of this game.
So switching to our
developer drone comes I can
actually Spohn wherever I
want clicked instantly. The
first one to show you some
of the areas that we've
been working on- this
mountain resort is cold
frozen would it's inspired
by some of the resorts in
the French Alps were I've
been snowboarding a lot. Of
the schools he parks side
kickers. Both bikes really
big grills a lot of
features in there will be
more than you would expect
in the normal mountain
resort but Hey this is a
video game everyone as many
features as possible. So
yeah like I said this is
completely open and you can
go snowboarding anywhere
you'd like you can do some
missions there's like a
story revolving around the
main character that wants
to participate in the kick
**** of additional border
crossing even. We can also
just cruise around and find
some nice lines with a good
flow like for example here
in this little like
environmentalists shown in
the trailer. Sorry can go
up there. Take some new
skis and be great. And big
park. Just look. This Regis
like we've got. For indoor
or since there. There's
back. Hi arrive. Even an
old tell you looking you
can trust. Hello of these
looking have been inspired
by events happening all
over the world snowboarding
movies inspired us these
past years. It's kind of a
preview to effect. Also
anywhere you go you can
always write during golden
hour computer real. Time
lighting engine. Hey having
a fun a realistic
environment is nice it's
not without feeling the
writing right. So for the
actual snowboarding that
means. The writers news
crazy stuff in the news the
snowboard and of course the
ourselves writing in real
life just having and being
creative on the snowboard
that's something the we
want to bring into the game
conceptually trying to keep
the conventional once the
for the board and once for
the body and directly the
into the snow. Get a
physical or animation. Soon
as you were touching those.
It gives you a lot of to
place seeking choose to be
in the city views. Mr
aggressive. Can change of
your style. The motion skip.
This was being reactive
that's challenge and we had
to create the system. Just
for this. You can see the
board interesting now
people someone. Eastern can
you really do things and
using. Please. From this
dance you can also start
just as a normal writing so
for the trickster system
trying to give as much
control as possible to use
the movie or any questions
that you can imagine was.
Great you can also three
with the four six. So
basically you have to get
down. And keep the body
it's been that high rate
and then it's just a matter
of. When it's time to. When
we succeed in very simple.
That is what we're trying
to achieve a really fun
game. Generation to fight.
Yeah. The enemy flag.
The
flag is.
Now.
I am so
excited to have Tom Alex
and Quinn from three four
three industries gentleman
thank you for being here
extrapolates now I watched
as multiplayer trailer
numerous times and I want
to see some specific
moments from it so we can
break it down so can we
roll the trailer to fifteen
seconds and let's talk
about a new character. The
generation. To fight. Get.
All right now who is this
character she looks like
she's in charge your your
your senses are right there
she's very much in charge
that's commander Laurette
she's in charge of the
Spartan academy which is
the kind of contextual
rapper that the whole
multiplayer universe lives
and she is basically
training a new generation
of Spartans to you know
become better that's really
where everything wraps
around- I really love this
character and what's cool
is not only is it kind of
the contractual wrapper for
the game but it's also we
have a whole suite of
academy features we call
them where there's a
tutorial that teaches the
players the fundamental
basics of the game there's
weapon drills that let you
practice with every weapon
that. Exists in the game
and get improve your skills
with us then there's all
the michael highgam
training mode which lets
you play against bots- on
any map basically in the
game and let's you
experiment with the toys
and kind of learn the flows
of everything so we really
want to bring players on
board at the Gaming again
under her orders and her
charge now I wanna go to
fifty seconds in the
trailer because there was a
lot of action on. Going on
I want to check that out.
You may notice I sat on my
chair a little bit on that
one because there was a lot
going on there so please if
you can break that down let
me know. What we're saying.
First there's a lot to
breakdown of we got enough
time to get. All the way
into- the some of the
things I really love when I
look at that. Trailer is
that that first sequence.
With the player than the
Bulldogs shocked on the
running through. Shocking
enemies. They grab the-
commando off the off the
rack. Put the shots and Lok
sensor like. There's all
sorts of different things
that the players
interacting with and that's
the sandbox that's what we
call. The sandbox the toys
that is at the disposal for
players fans and- and we
just really love that. That
moment in the trailer where
they- have to grapple shot.
They look up grapple the
ceiling. And then mid mid
air. No scopes night enemy
come all the way down back
what the photo and- and the
rest is history as you see
what happened that trailer
but that's just. Some of
the stuff that. That
players can do and that's
actually the game that's
not. Just the a movie for
cinematics Razer that is
the game that. The players
are good enough but in time
they can actually do the
things that you see in the
trailer. And few things are
more important to halo
multiplayer. Man like
interacting with the
sandboxing combining it.
Picking it up off the map
and combining into awesome
playstyles so. What we did
was- every- sandbox item in
the game. When it sponsored
spawning on an object in
the maps you can see where
those things can be found.
And then also tells you the
response time of that item
when it's gonna come back
and you always know. I go
grab that commando over
this- spot like that. That
guy did so. Anyone the
players you know accrue all
those awesome items and do
awesome things. You know
you heard the return of-
just icer the multiplayer
announcer- shouting out
metal so we always want to
give players metals and
they do really cool things.
So you heard some there and
you'll hear some later on
in the trailer. That's
awesome see when I watch
that to me that's a little.
That's a load of me I
absolutely love that now.
Let's skip ahead a little
bit more. Into the trailer
to fifty seven seconds. I
heard a voice. So I want to
know the voices with. See.
Yeah yes does the players
person I- so inhale 5 they
there was a leader that- an
ounce you know when weapons
are gonna come up another
things going on the match
in an infinite we have the
player Blake chief has core
Tana- they have a
personally I in their
helmets- that is kind of
telling them these things-
and it's also another way
that players can- show
their personality on their
in their characters so
there's multiple
personalities and
characters for the- player
to choose- so that they
they write a eyes on their
helmet helping them out in
combat I want to give it a
little further here
because- I think I might SO
big team battles sold so
let's go to a minute forty
in and check that out. The
enemy flag.
The flag is.
They look like big team
battles what what what's
coming in we're going into
a big team battle method I
mean it's not even just
that I mean part it
actually opens with
actually a forty four with
the vehicles map called
behemoth in at the
beginning so we actually
bringing vehicles back in
the forty four read about
then yes it definitely
transitions into the
forties or the twelve V.
twelve actually Beatty be
part of the game where we
are to make it a bigger
team battle this time.
Really wanted to index into
the battle fantasy with the
more players we had sort of
like vehicles responding
around the map we have
pelicans drop them off
importance pods the drop in
new weapons and inside of
the whole time you have the
battle commanders Florette
talking in your ear giving
you orders and trying to
kind of encourage you to
play around with really
just bringing the whole
sandbox in the playstyle
around this whole battle
experience in building.
Yeah Tom brings up some
good points there of-
commander at miss you've
you got your commander in
the comms and then you've
got the pelicans dropping
vehicles and items I forget
drop pods everything it's
just like this this theater
of war that this time
around it's is this twelve
B. twelve bigger team
battle if you will and just
that last that the ending
segment which is like a
capture the flag match is
just so beautiful awesome
where you've got. The
pelican drop the banshee
off teams fight over it
your your unity matter just
making a beeline for the
bench your teammate gets
picked off by the sniper
and I don't know if you get
this your take that cyber
out jumping the banshee
when you hit the jets and
fly up in the sky go for
the enemy flag that is.
That to us is- what is so
exciting about this version
of big team battle with all
the toys all the vehicles
the modes coming back the
maps a brand new map that
you see there I mean it's
gonna be an amazing
experience yeah I trust mac
I cannot. Wait to get my
hands on it for myself but-
let's move on. I want to go
to- in the trailer. Because
at think I saw samurai.
Let's that out let's go to.
The tray. Now. Okay so
guess next manager because
that was definitely a
samurai so gonna talk about
that so we're gonna start
seeing some more
customisation with the
armor yeah and I mean that
is a samurai the Spartan
armor and so it'll be in
canton armor you'll build
unlock for free in the
first season which is super
cool players will be at the
a quick do you know gain
more armor pieces and
customisation options for
eccentric across the season
and then we actually have
more of the stuff kind of
coming down the line with
there's actually some
really cool ideas that were
seen in the- that our team
that's building up stuff so
they'll be a lot of other
cool armors besides just
the really core. Halo
Spartan armor's they'll be
some other different kind
of twists and things for
players to play with
awesome look now before we
get out here first of all I
want to thank all of you
for being here today to
talk about hello infinite
I'm excited I can't wait to
get my hands on it and play
it but before we do leave
is there anything else that
you want to bring up in my
fans out there know about.
Well I'm excited for people
to actually get their hands
on I like yourself so I
mean if people sign up on
our halos insiders program
we have in the summer we
have a- a technical preview
that we're gonna be
launching some people
finally get they have put
their hands on the sticks
and I was really excited
for players actually
finally get to play the
game organ on yeah and then
on launch day hello and
then multiplayer is free to
play which is new to the
franchise the team is super
excited. To hopefully bring
in you know all sorts of
fans that have potentially
never experience a
franchise or haven't played
in a long time to just try
it out come in and try to
with your friends me with
my buddies of I have some
friends out there that
haven't played halo before
Mike was free it's just
come on with the jump in
download it let's let's
check it out and if it's
for you it's for you if
it's not then Hey it's not
but and I think it'll be
for yourself make 5 fort
yeah that's a the other big
kid that. Point is a PC
right like this is as a PC
game as well we've been
putting a lot of effort
into that so now is gonna
be console but also PC a
free to play at the barrier
to entry is so low and that
has us excited and I think
it's a really just a to
really think. About it is
we've been working on this
game and I as- anyway. On
again. You want to get that
GamePass. There and that-
almost seems like. For us.
The finish. Line but in
reality. It's going to be
the starting line. For all
of us for us. And the halo
fans. Day one. There's
gonna be a bunch of content
there and things that are
exciting and good. But then
we're gonna add more
content we're gonna add
more. Maps were gonna add
more modes and- weapons and
vehicles equipment items.
And it's just the
beginning. Of this whole
journey that. That we've
been on for awhile and
we're going to take.
Everyone else with us as
we- as the game comes out.
I'm excited. German again.
Thank you so much. Now for
fans who want to learn.
Even more. About halo
infinite multiplayer. Check
out the brand new deep dive
video. With the whole
multiplayer team. Over on
halo waypoint .com. And
allow me to give a big
thanks to everyone who's
joined us today. Where the
you play your favorite
games on Xbox PC or
GamePass. The next twelve
months will be nothing
short of spectacular. It
has been my absolute honor.
To be your host and share
this experience with you.
Before I go. Here's a game
played deep dive from the
team behind the highly
anticipated. Scarlet nexus.
Click on those American you
know domestic. The you
don't maybe journal.
Square Enix system Virgil
took to the call. Character
limit on the total cost
some of them another PC
sees the day coming. Your
question. Hi this is. On
the second of it all. Spohn
you know to stick things
course at the most. The
Oakland school to see. The
only which is United by
Swiss. Consume to submit
them in ways walk to doing-
okay ski DLC. Going
indenture image. Do you
need within you know I
could article critical. Of
the coca city sitting with
Gettys sticker high K.
closest city we've done it
on the skin. Throughout
Muzinich took only stack on
in list documents. Not the
most of the city the
capital Gettys deep enough
is a model to you down but
this waste no time in took
almost an timing and I
cannot do on fox. It
doesn't you see sitting on
the Capcom yes Gettys I or
to not phones will him.
When we in that's not and
we can it on schedule
almost anyone could that to
clinic the- they are. Plus
unlike France nine some
expenses tied to some
internal conflict at all
goal for the gold
acceptable to you did on
the total cost Houston a
guesstimate what. Could I
do nobody most. Some sixty
to the shooter to Muslims
our system on. On the-
thirteen emotional looked
as much do much the it is a
total. Unul sweet taste so
this do you know how missed
it. Well it took a double
booked if she want to get a
local. On the corner Dennis
I signed get all with one
of our much or nothing at
double digit officials and
official a month even with
she tonight most. Yes I
couldn't get in a lot
people in the to. County on
this. So only will get us
not. What it was like you
know don't go it on date
please. Clans to a seat
look at photos. In order to
see please try to call
today. All the meat on it
and god so much
contamination items to
signpost. This holiday what
does the so called clients
you don't thank doing
cooking I must. Dole ninety
seventy artist on cuddle
credit on a kinds of
designs. This article
within ten office it's good
stuff got another more you
know that. The stock was
name is yours to stay on
the on these look up.
Capcom co schedule not cut
and looking to cloud. On
all. What does this machine
did you only one of the saw
I. And also it's good
looking on need improvement
EIC emotion captured
sculpted into skittles so
then I would love to skate
on this day from all.
Nintendo what hold and I
want to make it up today of
course you know
conditioning on Oct in
complete. Hi she knew they
just used as coming start
you too today to discuss
about this the whole ninety
two we know what it takes
someone of your so in
Austin could. It's sort of
a standing up it. All some
couple misdemeanors. It's a
mistake. I got screwed it
up you can get more. Okay
can kind of musical titles
when she passed your best
rockstar. If you want. Your
suited up to one one to do
point eighty two. At
rockstar disconnect a quite
to and it's called stay in
your stop doing use. This.
Illegal because I know most
can you go to most in the.
Most of the- W. W. W. dot
or- the mobile. Should it
wish to conduct a quick of
start but some know you
should conflicted character.
Are you today yeah this of
up to not what kind one she.
I know you don't want me to
muscular persia utility
high dose. She's. Two for
the I simply to. Hi. Your
children to smoke when you
don't we about the conduct
of what kind of it.
Calcutta I think my mother
due to low damage your to
cut through this through
the walls. To which I can.
Such kind of. Could delay.
The schedule Hey what's
your coral all go Houston
more. Not to put storediq
cool to meet in the quarter
crime yep now I know what
the social or stick. How to
you know. Maksud Khan the
more Ranma clans- look. I
Esports. Coach most. What
is it about total
destruction of 1 about
awareness. I am also going
to not known what the
little book not I'm table
do that and all don't I can
I could I know to go it and
I was in the ask you. To
the system the schedule.
I'm a kind of good stuff
but also Jean-Luc how do
you get assistance now
hello Los it's the please
stand up and look at. It
will today michael highgam
not only. I know what's
going. Among Baldino told
listed in the schedule.
Does it assume going call
me a couple. Deduction loss
which cut the thirty the
total cost in distance.
Hello notional keylogger
posted I didn't do a lot of
good on. Also it's got the
he's thank you it about
another also this was.
That's a little dramatic
emotional so it is not a-
suffocated to this I said
look you need to Oman. So
does that mean I still in
the- easily double the
thought with the- posted.
On the Senate this little
give. I know not. Do you
couple tied the. It is
number one indicated that
the following the schedule
on all my continental stuck
it in a day full okay so
when you go to a vehicle a
little cut. To fit within
the thank you. Of course
you can buy. This call
given the- on. On we got a
little sun scheduled muscle.
Okay neat. The ticket the
much even then you know
it's kind of heated. Also
Jean-Luc on the. Hi. This
is the most visible goals
and all also the whole
doing that that today she
not hi they do this because
I table I think you know
there's a lot I told if we
need to get those fossil
that the host of the little
box most of. You know what
if he's only going to get
on his good old boy she's
own external. The company
got I don't think I today.
Pop but we do get the
Lawson will. Cook on ninety
yeah this morning sky high.
Out of little boy isn't all.
All but even look in the-
this. Thank I thought going
on not only. It's unlikely
that the. I'm not going to
it up in a the device with
a lot I must they could is
not looking. It is all. Set
up to the couples. Some
cable because I thought
you'll also that now. My
doctor he'll cook was
awesome. It's also skidded
seasonal the most local
noticeable total loans on
all that's your design dot
city you'll skis it's good.
The hello my name.
Taijiquan comical be doing
much and on following an
all methodical cook until
is a lot of an option
michael highgam. It'll not
coming hi you can they
could not have the skill
muscle it doesn't on the
cook without getting
there's a- my name using a-
the lawsuit to. With up the
Bob o'clock I lose your
stuff levels I'm going to
go not what else can the
following the Los of them
are not you could kind of
at the legal skills. To
there's a little a new
missiles and movie capital.
You'll not ONL designed you
put a lot because of. What
skills in question but the
hotel so doesn't my sinking
a look at the this model
number. This automated look
as how do you the equipment
collected. On or not come
up he's not it's not of the
kids cases it a couple days
all. Even though it's kind
of a. Hello games all
looking on indeed you know
nobody nobody on the
computer. It'll muscle
nobody. Thank the see
because of the little could
you FPS did I mean I and
taking the that full. Did
you know they conducted you
need content. Final I have
the team we did on it a
little my stuff- localizing
dividend that's a lot I
didn't. Movie because I get
a bonus as hello my team on
I please enjoy Scott it
next.
Welcome back to games
with coverage of E3 twenty
twenty one and that was the
Xbox extended it showcases
our Parris lilies Xbox
expenditure case he did an
incredible job and welcome
back to him. Hello I'm back
that's going that was fun I
enjoyed that Parris Killin
of course on the mac I've
already made my- design lab
Xbox controller beamed off
the- character Simon
Phoenix from the best movie
of all time demolition man
don't ask me about not- no
I mean you you sent me a
link to it it looks. I want
to see I think you should
buy it if you haven't
already. You gonna put a
call on. All right yet
Simon says bleed. Maybe if
I can fit that in. I think
it's like my old- the last
time Xbox had design lab
are you and I both got
overwatch themed ones you
unit is already 1 and I
made a diva 1 that in
retrospect didn't work very
well yours looks great mind
did not work so well
because I don't. Have an
iPhone- the color palette
to marinate but that was a
really great I deep dive
into some Xbox is a biggest
games I think as well the-
the that. The hint of a
tease and Hellblade to look
great time what was your
highlight from Sharm. I
think this office showed up
for halo like I'm I hi I
was messaging all of my
friends to be like are you
watching this halo thing.
And buyer by all of my
friends I mean two of them
because- this one's-
actually watching right
now. About your father so
you know you know. But I
love everything about
everything that they've
shown so far filo
multiplayer. I'm it looks
like a classical halo
experience but they brought
back some of the-
interesting things and kind
of made good on them like
I'm the ability to use
grenades to like- use the
explosion I'm going to move
weapons closer to you and-
what about in in a more
meaningful way- it just
looks like any. A really
small the well designed
halo games that ease of its
own to me not like we
talked about this before
but like. Hello fellow
oculus core in in a place
where it was trying to be
its own thing but having
to. Kind of us to come to
the design the popular
design choices of
multiplayer shows all the
day and it became this hawk
breed thing that wasn't all
that interesting- I'm kind
of like we- when I feel
like they figured out.
Their own identity. Again
and I'm super happy about
that. Yeah I'm sitting to
see more. Him infinite it
launches later this. Coming
up next we have an
interview with velop is
behind lost in random. As
well as a friend you
trailer enjoy. With random.
Where everyone's destiny is
decided by a rule of the
one. Geis the word. We
controls it when a child
comes they must rule this
dice. Indeed determine
their fate the role. The
best day. B. grade child
that the queen has yeah.
Day. Let's see what kind of.
Trulia you. Where is this.
You. Children. Hi all. Say
something. Where are you.
She is just our range we
destroy them clean. Hi
folks and welcome to this
special interview today
we're talking about loss
and random a new dark
fantasy adventure game from
zoink games the folks that
have brought you feet as
well as goes giants
flipping death and many
many others and it is a
huge pleasure to be joined
by folks I'm a big fan of
the all all of our game
director in Klaus the head
of development it's like.
Good evening how are you.
Degree good evening
michael highgam. How are
your course- I'm doing very
well I'm kind of like
admittedly I won't beat
around the bush I'm a
smidge nervous. Like you
James- hi- and began to go
signed it was one of the
has been 1 the first really
tiptoeing into VR and like
that was like when the
first ones want to get into
which all of you were in
the game and art director
for cracked yeah that is
correct I had a lot of fun
with that and actually that
was my very first D. R. den
project as well and also to
what was the whole story
is. First the art project
so it was a great way to
learn and do something
weird and different I think.
Because we didn't have
much. Yeah knowledge about
it. That's when I'm things
can happen. I think. We'll
get into that. I have. A
tremendous amount of
middle. Of admiration for
your your guys ability to.
Seemingly not repeat
yourselves but before we
get into that- let's talk
about lost momentum the new
game that you folks have
been working on- let's
begin with what is it it's
not out we have only a few
glimpses of it but give me
the pitch. Action adventure
game about a girl called
even and her living dice
companion at dicey and it's
set in the center of course
darker it's a worthless you
know called random- where
everybody's destiny is
decided by the roll of.
Evil queens dark dice and
even and I see are there to
kind of. S. started path
and the- and bring this is
weird the queen is put into
place throughout the world
I have to ask is there a
studio philosophy that you
folks may have some kind in
in in changing- our
direction and style because
at this point it really
hasn't felt as those going
because John the same came
twice in any capacity and
now lost a random it looks
much much more grand it
seems to be like one of the
biggest gains because of
put together. Studio
philosophy is that
intentional yeah I think
there's still some the last
time you have to think
about so EIC is a company
that. I started out as a-
six largest many many years
ago you know and then.
Human artist and then.
Making games and then when
I started sewing it was
really just I just need to
have a platform to make
games and just a fun place
to make games you know and
as an artist or as
something to regret
somebody it's always like
it's just a really really
fun journey when you start
out a new project that. You
you try something else you
know if you done it before
it feels a little like
you're going to the same
place again you know. And
that is just it's just a
really fun personal journey
to let's try this. This
would be fun to try I think
every time we dug done
something new it has always
been sort of like a reason
to we did this ticket and
I'm not mad I'm sleeping
deaths were trying to find
a place where we could do
games quite big story with
very simple means
basically. Well we did say
it was about how can we do
three D. games expression
games and three D. but with
a very very- also quite low
budget in some ways you
know and the simple style
the budget in a way also
dictated that we need to
have a style that was just
really cool for the- money
we could build a gamer but
then for lost and randomly
was we like okay now we can
just really. We can finally
do. I could take say you
know. And it was more like
if we want to do something
that almost looks triple a
or any sort of looking very
realistic how can we do
that with the style you
know that's that's
interesting you know not
just doing religious so we
thought like why don't we
do small. It was public
style really is the way it
looks a little bit like
stop motion in some ways
you know I know I that
absolutely does- for use as
as he was like a creative
and- very focused in part.
What is like what is that
like for you to be able to
transition into different
art styles- and now it's-
going to Lawson random
which is which as Scott
said mention is as much
more triple a static much
grander bigger a static.
Yeah like my classmates and
looks like it's always been
the more our treatments. To
do from the get go and- S.
touched on. Since there's-
just about a has been
limited. It's always about
the idea I'm sorry for at
like really huge a
realistic yet again. I'm
not gonna be inspiring to
me on the and it's been
real by work with Klaus
learned so from him just as
I process and you know.
Fifteen we the really well
the I haven't seen before
like. It really may be and
then it grows on you yeah
of course it's nice to have
two legs and arms and let's
make a deal about that. So
my idea. It develops a lot
working with clouds. They
go also working on train we
came out of the project.
Having of course it has a
darker undertone of course
because people now have.
Actually played constraint.
But on the surface it's
very bright and colorful
and busy. And Q. so we were
had all. Built up this
longing to make a little
something more darker like
michael highgam often say-
at and on the this longing
to. Now with this proper
budget explore. S. fantasy
and- epic story. The skin
that they haven't been able
to before like us on. For
me it's always about
started thank just like
with Klaus I love to start
drawings and story because
everything is storytelling
and the things easily grow
out of a story and when we
found this iconic. Picture
of a girl under dis lesson
for us things really
started. And you know the
story started well.
Question thanks for
interesting. Gameplay take
a dice the most iconic
gameplay icon and make it
your own and it has to be
good game play so that's
been a real challenge but
also very naturally takes
you for a journey because
you along and can't help
but- tell a great story.
With it I feel. Really
proud and excited to show
everybody what. Yeah I
think I could probably talk
to both of you about the
creative in our process to
the ends of the earth-
really. What I do kind of
want to I don't I kind of
want to shift into.
Something you both kind of
touch on especially you
class about the studio
starting you know. With you
is a small thing six or in
the moving as a means as a
platform. To make creative
games- what has this. Has
there been any. Interesting
challenges should I say-
when. From going from
smaller smaller- budget
games another big budget
Gaming kind of. What that
process is been like
applying. Eight of artistic
integrity to develop a
bigger scope in terms of
budget I was always those
boring things about going
bigger is basically like
structure you need to look
structure you need more
producers handling
everything does all that
stuff that. Comes out of it
obviously that that's it's
harder to run a bigger team
you know that's just how it
is you know I think some of
the challenges you really
run into quite quickly is
that on Jan figure team
really need to have a-
really strong vision of
what you want to do which I
think is great but would
love to give you some love
back here or love is
basically have somebody
who's really good at.
Telling what the vision is
to the team you know and
making sure that they
really understand this is
what we're doing right now
this is what we're going
for I think we are running
the games a little bit
similar to I guess home
movies around it as a movie
director who really needs
it you know and has a
vision for it and goes
forward that this is this
is what we're doing you
know. There's so many
decisions have to make on
your way as much as you
make a game and you know
this thing to be blue or
green red and it could be.
Could be quite good you
know. The way it. Doctor
wants to. This and is.
Probably the best. That's a
real. Good choice and- has
to. That road all the way
you know too make sure that
that. Actually becomes.
Really great in that
direction. The challenge
has really been to make
sure that. Everybody gets
it. Everybody that follows
it and understands what
we're doing right now and
everybody. Is it's going
the same direction. But I
also think. Sometimes when
you have an idea like. I
felt directly of. Like
we're lost in random BAndai
deal with the- dice and all
that stuff is. It sold
michael highgam senses such
a strong subject that. Once
we have that it was like.
It's very easy to create
something around it.
Because it's so. Almost
like you win the lottery
something. Wow that's a
great idea let's keep it
you know that's a great
idea just. Go with that you
know. So happy you found
it's like you're digging in
your brain and suddenly
thing this thing comes out
and it's like that's-
really cool you know. Yeah
I remember. Early on when
we had our smaller studio
we had just started out.
Prototyping lost around I
felt like we were all. Just
like. Little kids going on
lunch break like. I'm not
sure what we're trying.
What do you think about
programmers I don't know
what you think about. Well
let's just see what this
idea things- you. You want
to go over there and you
want to. Like just like. We
started out. On short with
this. Big blank. Slate and-
and the core we to tell the
story about such. You know
general. Topic like like
random. In a way it's kind
of cold itself. Everybody
has has. A relation to
randomness. And uncertainty
in life. So we have we just
had a group of like. Five
six people sitting
together. Everything just
proved very naturally out
of the- I was so much fun.
Just the- funnest part. At
work. All of I think you
know the- that's- that
really stands out to me is
this. I I've only got. To
under. Bits and pieces of
the crew hi guys work in a
creative process- but one
thing you guys. Like both
of you mention this kind
of. Finding where I'm
covering. And idea- and I
kind of. Love the fact that
it's- it's call Lawson
random and you referred to
it almost is like you're
chasing these ideas that
are kind of just. Maybe
developing on their own or
going their own way and
like were you to stop those
ideas from going- was. That
always kind of a reciprocal
thing from the start you
know when thinking Lawson
random or was it just
something. You want
covered- along the process.
It's definitely something
we I'm covered since but
like we touched on already
we started out just wanting
to tell a fairy tale dark
curtailing looks at
artwork. I Spohn town
that's- for instance.
Australian artist. At that
was set you know he's
artist so. Just is what it
is. It leaves so much to
the imagination- dreamlike.
And it has a child's
imagination. We waste and
also like me a sake real
sweet we have. And- over
the garden wall we looked
at all different. Things
that are just very matter
of fact yeah. And that at.
Was some last. It would be
just the at all these
different. A fairy tale-
just are what they are and
they don't need much
explanation I want to tell
that kind of story and then
all. No systems and teams.
Snacking but we still want
that kind of dreamy
fairytale. All of class
unfortunately this is all
the time we have as though
I can speak to you folks
probably for hours and
hours more but just know
that. I'm very excited for
this it's been a huge honor
to be able to spend just
even a glimpse of time with
you both talk about lost
random but before we- go.
When can we can we expect
the game this year. Yeah
you can definitely expect.
Well yeah yeah- it's coming
soon and it's coming this
year that's for sure yeah
and- yeah all platforms. So.
I feel the exact occurrence
but all of them. Okay well
absolutely amazing all of
thank you so much class
thank you so much- you can
look out for Lawson random.
I'm Kerr one last time.
Thanks again folks the only
other.
Welcome back to a
playful role A. K. A. E3
twenty twenty one the E3
that never quits that was
an extended look at lost in.
Austin random lost an
infinite my hate my halo
brain it's just like and I
was gonna- lost in round
and we're going to see a
trailer that really cool
looking. Lucy you compared
it to look at my car line-
what is your opinion of
what you saw that seems
like it was the first time
you saw that came. The
interested in. Yeah I never
seen. Lost among them
before until I the trailer
and like. I Devin fear and
yeah it looks like it Razer
Carlijn reminds me of night
before Christmas- you know
the- the Tim Burton vibes.
Very strong and I think as
well get a little bit all
of our little nightmares
to. Not little time is too
long my most common to. But
there to those guys so that
was. I think it looks it
looks it looks fine it
looks wacky look really
it's kind of I'm into. On
yeah I did get. Burying the
lead somewhat we also
joined by the one the only
michael highgam high and
you may have seen in on the
E3 streams up that. Eleven
up during Gaming fresh out.
Looking fresh
michael highgam welcome
back firstly how you doing
secondly I know you want to
get this off your chest
quickly give us a rundown
of the games that got you
hyped for E3. If you
haven't had a chance to
speak directly to the
audience that knows and
loves you. The games
Baldino okay tell us hello
that's and we've been hyped
about everything you store.
Gives back michael highgam
E3 okay okay I am back from
E3 live from LA- and I got
to work with so many great
people golden boy Greg
Miller. On a bunch other
people that's just
shortlists right there but-
we were paying attention to
everything at E3 because
that was that was that was
our job but- of the things
that got me hyped up your I
wish you all were there
when should Megami Tensei
5. Was revealed during the
during the Nintendo direct
I lost it and they were
recording reactions when
we're sitting on the couch
watching the stream and I
was. Last and all right I
look like if your watching
the livestreams I've lost
it too Greg was let me down
because I was sweating.
Broly but yeah that was
that was my favorite thing
of the show that was my
personal game show I love
that they did an extended
thing for tree house as
well. You're the
protagonist looks so sick I
cannot emphasize this
enough. How does the
protagonist looks in S. and
P. five but other than that
like the Xbox showcase was
just. Stole the show
mainly. Like weird watching
all together in some
everyone's getting hyped
about something else for me
was stopping to. M. earlier
when we were running the
extended Xbox showcase I
was paying attention to
like other doing the mo cap
how much production values
going into stoppage too
because if you think about
stalker the original games.
They were very much- held
together by duct tape and
those were incredible
games- so deceased doctor
given. That sort of
platform given that that
production value. I'd still
maintaining that that
spooky spirit of like
Chernobyl but supernatural
like. That is that was my
second game of the show and
I think the third one was
probably halo infinite
because- I was getting
hyper golden boy that was
like his game that he was
waiting for. I'm like you
know what. I can get the I
can get into halo again but
that that's still but
there's like so many
independent games like
superhot. Tammy did super
for me all manner and
here's watching. That
yellow. That was a game
from Philippine I was
honored. At U. also she
dreams. Because I got to
give love to avoid. You are
good in. So many great
games at E3. Yeah there are
a lot of amazing games and
it's good to have you back
I predicted those would be
your game so I'm glad that
I know you well enough to
predict that stuff. Right
next stop we have a
gameplay video for a little
game called boyfriend
dungeon which is as weird
as you probably expected to
be also Razer any coal. And
yeah we're gonna have pro
CD who's in that game on
the chart E3 but more about
that later. Enjoy the
gameplay. Pretty weird
hobby think about it.
Yeah.
And that was a look at some
new gameplay from a
boyfriend dungeon now
michael highgam you've
actually played some
boyfriend dungeon before
right I sure have boyfriend
dodges the really cool-
that's how I met of chess
sets of Victoria Tran- who
runs the who's the comedian
manager for among us now
but- I met her at pax the
thing is twenty nineteen
because she was working
with kit fox on boyfriend
AJ I got hands on with it
it's really cool like as
you saw from the game play
that it's- isometric
dungeon crawler but has a
visual novel elements so
the thing is that. Your
weapons if you take into
the dungeon are your
companions in the real
world and you take them to
power up your weapons you
take them on dates and you
are you have to like say
the right thing so it's
like a like- like that
social sim element that you
get out of it. It's really
fascinating I think the
dungeon crawling it's
really fun it's really
smooth so Adeoye has the
that unlock for the
gameplay element but- the I
think the character art is
sold you'll all the
characters are hot what I'm
looking at you like all my
god my sort of soul 5 only
gosh this. Not only I looks
like a cake pops are I
think that's a that's who I
can't remember who's who in
terms of weapons but it's a
fascinating concept I think
it has come together really
well when I played it all
those years ago so I hope
it's- hope developments
coming along because it was
really promising in its
early stages and I can't.
Wait to see what the full
games actually being. Yeah
I mean also. Has the
speaking his. For like.
Malone DLC- friend engines-
reading it. Him this
morning he not only. Hot
Lotusphere. Apple doesn't
believe me. So yeah. I time
I you mentioned proceeding
before we as a group it
took like a boyfriend
dungeon- and you mentioned
he's gonna be not charity
stream. Yes RPG is playing
a character named boyfriend
dungeon- and we're going to
have him on next week- to
talk briefly about the game
and I'm mainly talk about
him a little bit- he's he's
had a meteoric rise to fame
and success- you know
climbed his way up the
voice acting. Community via
the anime community
appealing to the niece and-
so what we're gonna do is
we're gonna have him hang
out we're gonna try about
he's kind of off and use.
It's kind of like a rare
case where he is talk about
boyfriend under the band
and then we're going to a
big old anime quase. It's
gonna be me M. and- hello
we. Jordan- that's going to
be this to be a good. Time
my get someone else in I
don't know the significance.
In I am for a- and we go
from there. But yeah it's
gonna be it's gonna be fun
and obviously we're raising
money for a bowl game is-
you can you know the lan
Kwai able gamers is live
now- I think it's time you
all dot com forward slash.
Play for all twenty twenty
one. I think that's right-
so if you want to make
donations now you can but
the entirety of next week.
Donate yeah we'll be
talking more about our
charity streams very
shortly but now can take a
look at nobody saves the
world.
That was eight gamer
video for nobody saves the
world which looks cute all
C. thing running around
getting stuff done I'm into
it- alike yet. So for this
segment we're gonna quickly
run down what we've got
coming up- following yes
we're going to have a if
you all I bought actually
no we're gonna show off.
All wearables. An interview
for that well as women west
Austronesian dave jewitt
press conference and
surprisingly it looks quite
funny I was I was surprised
at how much I was locked in
a trailer so I'm excited
for that. And then we'll
come back to Austin we have
a fallout seventy six
interview followed by. A
collection of really cool
people joining lucy james
tell us who you call on on
the panel Lucy. Yeah we've
got- liana from game
informer liana ruppert with
god gene park from The
Washington Post and- Amira
Virgil A. K. A. X. mere
Amira I took about Lizzy
biggest announcements and
what their favorite games
from E3. And so very
excited to talk to you. And
then we've got a mobile. In
come up and then a bunch
all of. Is in. At Razer one
lonely outpost- no place
for bravery Roque spirit
and a few of those. And
following not we've got
another. Collection of cool
people joining us to
charge. Me I'm and then
we'll have the new face of
video games blessing. June
yeah. Somewhere in the room
in the room in the
apartment michael highgam
somewhere around there it
measures in the room down.
Also joining him is no Mike
Mike. The legend and all
very own Jeff. Ocular thank
you lord Jeff macula.
Bacula I couldn't back it
up because I need to say I
need to make it removed.
Mac imagine. I got a guy-
and then after that it's
going to be the end of E3
stocks a floral rock pop
and we're gonna get a bit
weird with it we've come up
with some awards that are
completely non official
okay those awards out. It's
gonna be a good a good time
michael highgam hasn't
hasn't seen the list of
awards by might give it to
you so you can contribute
okay yeah and you can
present their okay all
right so all of yeah yeah
the wards like yo games
what is it like GameSpot's-
like I would suggest like
best of show what is it
like nobody's. Gonna data
revealed or like yeah a six
eight when working with
Zachary exactly like that
we've got categories
including a game of the
show obviously we've got
the least necessary
showcase award. Okay we've
got we've got the best use.
Of zoom award- we've got
the biggest goal. 1 we've
gotten most unsettling
expression award. This is a
little weird categories.
It's going to give us an
opportunity to have a
little fun talk about some
of the games that were
shown and why we were that
we send me mobile moments
from mac- and you'll be a
good time and it'll be a
nice wholesome way for us
to wrap up the week long
coverage over a week at
this point- of E3 as part
of a four oh. One the
question have the winners
already been determined.
Are we assuming okay I mean
we can so they want to come
and find me. Yes we can
have a debate. Debate and
figure out we can figure
out okay we're gonna figure
out this is a dictatorship
now. All right let's go
over to the web almost
within interview. Howdy
folks welcome to this very
exciting and special
interviewed during this
play for all E3 week
extravaganza I'm joined
with none other. Than Sam
Richardson the star
producer of the new film
wearables within based off
the Ubisoft video game Sam.
It was a pleasure to have
you how are you doing.
Greatest pleasure to be
here thanks for having. Are
you kidding me pleasure's
all mine so to kick it off.
In your words from Sam
himself tell us about
wearables within. I woke
where was within is a- the
horror comedy whodunit
thriller mystery- restores
me as forest ranger fan
Wheeler who's new to this.
Snowy mountain town called
beaver field- and
everything gets turned on
its heels when the
townspeople are snowed into
small in and fin tested
figure out who or what is
terrorizing the townspeople
so not only are you the
star. The cool cat glues
this whole thing together-
telling- you're also the
producer so before we get
into some other questions I
want to get that I want to
get an idea of that Beyonce
with it with what's it like
to be in this film with
the- all stars cast of.
Rambunctious personality is
also being able to be a
little bit behind the
scenes. I was really cool
to get to produce and star
in a movie- because first
off like with a cast like
this everyone it is a
brilliant. And just. Hello
Leo yes actor and performer
within things like get a
play off those energies- as
a lever moves like this and
kind of be like the through
line through that is a
complex one- exercise and I
got a really great
opportunity for me and then
as a producer it's great to
get that kind of thing a
macro view. It's like this
and kind of feel ownership
and really feel that you
are. Kind of guiding- or do
you feel like you feel
certain a huge amount of
ownership over something
like this and you know I
really feel that I can put
my- little specificity is
and in my vision on things
really cool experience.
You're an EIC
extraordinarily nice guy in
the movie so here we go
into some other questions
are you is actually as nice
as your character is. Not
nearly not nearly no are
you aware wolf. Could be
could be a moment you know
now. Would you want to be a
world if you could. I would
want to be a werewolf
because like it's a lot the
enhancement I first of a
lot of red meat so that to
begin with you know the
idea of using the freshest
red meat which may be you
know animal maybe people-
I'm I'm like excited for
that and also. You know I'm
naturally hairy like a
hairy chest and but and all
that stuff so- you know I
feel like I'm part way
there anyway I got like.
You know sharp teeth- thank
I think that the probe
prolongs- so now. We're
over muscle. Something I
don't. If I were or were
not aware will sandwiched
in real life you know- I
think it changes my facial
structure and features but-
it's nothing I'm opposed to
I do like a dog. The money
be turned into a world do
you think. I think so- I
think I think. I I'm I'm
I'm I'm gonna one hundred
syncing yes they can-
eighty a vampire also I
don't think we ever seen
this remember being turned
to where will. I mean seems
plausible right the- you're
both like that out at night
so where will you know when
the full moon comes that's
when we're will shine and
let my time S. own time a
vampire can be around so
that's why their rivals but
I think it's. It's that
that rivalry will end one
day- the- who would win the
game of basketball team
will for air but- he will
because he's got all the
powers of- but plus you.
Does does that mean there's
basketball this movie-
without giving any spoilers
no. There are there is a
there is kind of a sport
that involves throwing
something but we will we
will get into that- if you
had to hang out or be stuck
in a scenario in real life
with any of the 1
characters. That are in the
film who would. I'm I have
to be stuck with any of the
characters in this film
yeah it would be Cecilie.
About Moana Vandross
character because she's fun
funny. You know- quirky
without being as crazy. As
the others. There is- the
cast as I mentioned earlier
it's quite rambunctious and
quite exciting what was it
like to be on set with all
of those. How do I put it-
screaming personalities. It
was really really fun to
get to like work with
everybody ambience that
would bite my kind of
working off of everyone
because there's so much.
Energy that is the kind of
harness into this movie and
EIC into these scenes and-
be it you know it's hard to
not laugh when you
successfully appreciating
these performances when our
on the other side of the
camera boards on the other
side of them in your on
camera you know definitely
a challenge to try and- it
I they're not last we're
not going to go wow. And
some of those moments that
are like E3 I think
everybody in this movie
that really adept at doing
both it was really cool the
game of course is- it's
kind of more medieval
setting. From your
standpoint being on the
other side of Cameron
certain ways was there a
conscious effort in kind of
placing it into this small
town village- and what was
that like kind of adapting
this this. Mystery whodunit.
Style thing into a snow
covered land. I will. Well
mission will who wrote this-
sort of had but my guess
was in her interpretation
of what. The game could be
into the movie from the
your soft property. I and I
think. The idea of it being
set in not medieval times
kind of takes and elements
of sort of. Hokey mess out
of it because you know EIC-
in in in which works for
the game but to put in the
movie I think it's gonna
be. One too many hats on
hats you know- so- having
it set my time it makes a
little bit more
identifiable or make it
helps you identify with the
characters a little bit
more. So it's like one less
barrier. Between the
audience and the cast where
the- characters cast. Well
our this is unfortunately
that's all the time we have
but with this brief moment
that we have left Sam not
only thank you for being
here but the show floor is
yours what do you want to
say anything you got you
want to tell us. Yeah watch
where worlds within- it
comes to theaters. June
twenty fifth. And then D.
O. D. D. N. on demand and
rental. July second. It's
howling good time I came
back on the spot and I'm
very proud of it. Take that
and you're gonna launch a
for every single interview
from this point out put it
on all of the posters
that's it perfect I'm
getting to right here. Yes
yet to match the hairy
body. Exactly how time and
then there's- the this is a
sexy mommy on the top one-
all right. It's been such a
huge pleasure Sam seriously
thank you so much for
taking the time to do this
once again I'm Kurt. That's
Sam. Till next time go
check out world within
sealer.
So that was our
very own kurt indovina
speaking with one of the
stars- behind the upcoming
I Ubisoft movie well it was
a game. As a kind of board
game first in the U. was
off game and now it is a
movie- levels within. Let's
take some PC to discuss a
little bit- Gaming video
games movies or movies
based on video games a
recent university we just
had mortal combat
Castlevania non movie TV
show but still. On down the
stone. Town meeting the
tide is turning them. I
think it might be you know
we had some we've had like
peppering all of- decent
movies in the past but
mostly. Absolute junk like
some real life top ten
stinker movies on there
like so bad that it's like.
Oh my god this isn't just a
bad video game movies this
is just a straight up bad
movie. However I think like
what's happening now and
it's exciting to see is 1
video game companies are
starting to understand
that. They can make their
own things they have the
power to. Attain some
creative control and
there's also a reason to
put the effort into making
the most of you know. The
opportunities and to the
people that are making them
the- right as directors
creative people behind it
have grown up in a
generation that you
understand- games-
understands how to best
adapt source material. The
days of rainfall are gone
thanks for the I believe I
mean I'm sure he's out
there still making movies
and telling. The boxing
fights- unlike. You know
there we're starting to get
away from me I've not seen
the monster hunter movie
and let me I was gonna say
may I see monster hunter. I
will not be watching them
once on a movie I do pray
that whatever. Information
the secret stop hold. The.
WS Anderson has on senior
Capcom execs like I'm I if
the Capcom was a high meter
like get that information
back hit Moscow all take
care of it for you because
please please stop him your
movie- Frazier values like
the perfect things of what
everything you should not
do with your franchises
when making movies don't do
what Capcom is doing we're
present evil monster hunt
and everything else. Do you.
Yeah yeah I mean I mean I'm
I know take it from pulled
S. and give to pull comes
on because I would love to
see. And then there will be
blood. Change I don't know
I know get Daniel day Lewis
in to play wesco or
something. I think you I
agree be fun no I it's. Go
on. I was gonna say like
give resin evil the maybe
cap doesn't have the car
for apple like you can
present a to my James all
like know among Toro and
you've got some things and
you hands Gary. You give a
to a pole W. S. I. and you
got yet another please stop
to handle coming through
with heat though all kinds
of ten day relax well
you're not wrong- and ten
ten mention like coming in
through headmaster I'll
yasa people hit man movie-
I already. But yeah the
awesome people the hit man
movies but- you know I.
Okay Transylvania's great
because it was a series-
and a lot of there's a lot
of anime adaptations of
certain other games I think
the P. 4% for- anime
adaptation was actually
pretty good or was it was
okay- the persona five
anime adaptation was I
didn't do it for me but
what I do want to shout is
the persona three movie
series so it's a four part
movie series that adopted
the core of the game. And
it was really really good
so I don't know I feel like
the case with a lot of
anime adaptations that
they're very hit or miss
and I think video game
movie adaptation has been
very miss. I don't know
what it is I think it's
like. I don't know it's
like. Feels like just get
something out with the
game's name on it and we're
good- it was yeah. That but
once once you start Ludwig
digging into kind of having
creative control of the
source material trying to
recapture the spirit. Which
I think is like what
monster hunter didn't do
what the rest of you like
resident evil movies were.
Fun on their own but if
you're coming into that as
a resident evil fan you
like kind of like. And- I
whatever. It was I don't
know he definitely tried to
do like in the first
resident evil movie oversee
being in- the mansion they
tried to do the dog.
Leaping through the window
or at least their own take
on that seeking. You can
see where they've they've
tried it but like. I'm
intrigued by the new
resident evil. Series
because there's two of them
those that live action 1
where is- is it lance
Reddick is Intellivision 1
playing Wesker. I want to.
Or is the voice of- western
one of them's Saddam act he
is actually I know I think
I think he's in the library
I. Google yeah. If he's
alive action what I am well
up I am yeah yeah. Snaps
internet risque but also
there is going to be that
C. G. I. version yeah he's
gonna be I'm all the
western- hello yeah live
action series so there's
not one but then there's
also going to be the- the
CG I want. Which are full
of Liana class it looks. It
looks interesting I just
hope it like it seems like
it's gonna have the sort
of. Coffrini Sirius toned
resident evil and then
it'll probably have just
like reading wacky 1 lines
that. You'd like if you are
just a TV or movie watching
you really what the hell
was that but he played
resident if you like yeah.
Yeah I mean. The other
thing I was gonna mention
is like. Obviously Ubisoft
days in a position where
they kind of understand it
now well they're trying
they're doing their best it
seems like this result well
who is an- but then they
announced during the- the
Netflix gift week that
they're doing splinter cell
and they- got- Derek.
Kolstad whose- 1 the craze
of Jean-Luc on the- which-
really interesting like I
like the sound of that so
far I'm not a 100% sold on
the animation style it
looked a lot like one of
the- shorts that they use
for. Remote sixties when he
when they put some pressure
in there and he didn't say
anything like Sam Fisher.
But it looks kind of like
that but what would that
kind of like pedigree of
talent behind it if you it
feels like the tide is
turning on. On these kind
of adaptation so I'm
excited. To see that unfall
cries all the- well I mean
it's yeah. I'm looking at
you- film TV. Website new
thing a minute it's like.
They go out of an mythical
with with is that. There
got the S. creed feature
for they have rap. Live
actions and I'm- high-
these. Creek come to
Netflix they have a beyond
good and evil live action
slash hybrid feature film.
The division. Allegedly a
just dance feature phone-
the senior citizen
Australian projects. And go
in bones live action TV
series. That was a- game.
Yeah get up before the
game- I did. Even know that
they the animal that they
had like they're basically
doing. Like movie or series
adaptations of every single.
One of the franchises
that's while yeah- no
sequel to J. Jim. Prince of
Persia the old. He is going
to be in the foe so Hey
maybe it's a- without a
cause I mean. Is that is
assassins creed movie an
animated live this is the
so there's a lot of our
assessing creed series
there's a size creed film.
To send me to reason I to.
They like over going. It
was the first Russian been
one right now my trust in
the 1 so it's not just like
gone. Should be. I don't
they've they've been like
at least three different
assassin's creed projects
as well as far cry like the
blood dragon stuff is
getting its own animated
series well- so. Trees but
like yeah the previous
assassin's creed movie and
prince of Persia. Not that.
It's but I will say mythic
quest is surprisingly I
should stop saying
surprisingly because of the
people who are behind its
like rob Michael Haney-
and- Charlie day behind and
actually birch is writing
it and there is someone
else as well- here I feel
bad for forgetting Megan
Ganz- they they kind of
creative team behind the
quest and I think that is
it. That is a series that
is like. Written clearly by
people who know what
they're talking about and
know what will appeal to
gamers like there are so
many. Inside jokes there
are so many references and
it feels like- you know
that like the old saying-
the- do give you say about
the Big Bang theory this is
arrested development where.
Arrested Development is
smart TV about stupid
people but- like. And then
Big Bang theory is small
character is but stupid TV
so it's like it's very it's
a very similar thing it's
more in line with the rest
of development and it's
always sunny. Where it is
very smart jokes aimed at a
very specific audience but
they do land. And three
against seven other V.
watched mythic quest. I
haven't but I did- added to
my- watchlist because I- I
subscribe to apple TV to be
not going to watch what I
want to rewatch ten blast
so and then there it is I
was like yeah I was like
yeah I guess a lot of
subscribe go watch this
again tell us so all time
great- I am is a quest
seems real cold- I'm not
sure about the- other show
that they did those scenes
I've heard a lot about
things. It was a cold it's
always funny and so it. Is
so the- something like that
I don't know seems. Like a
no show. This as one
there's one time I'm you if
you ago- we will stay in
and it was like oh June
something and F. how on
it's always marathon. And I
may a swath. The night
Namco is and the Dennis
system and- Tamilisai know
about it I was like this is
some I was like this is a
country with everyone in
here is annoying as hell is
it was it- to Jacoby in for
you. Is the while young
Gouveia is. Ian Breaux hi
you no more Peavey glue
white she. Zero Dan looking
at the bar that I'm not
that- like M. I get I risk
the you know always I
likely I think what
mathematics does like-
it's- I think really down
like the okay of the things
that you to see in- like
invalid where my me of she
Bach which is a while enemy
about make anime so. I kind
of got the same vibe it's
but it's also really funny
I just I know I I've seen
bits and pieces of meat the
quest but having like
seeing it as a as a whole
but- yeah yeah I think it's
been impressive and I'm
glad they're gonna get like
a new season and also other
stuff because- yeah I'm
really interested to see
where that goes it's like
finally years later
something that's yeah it
it's funny but if it's it
does have a serious edge to
it where it is can be
inside. Also I got a lot of
respect for that. Yeah so-
well. Mike you. This
segment it's an interview
you did with the team
behind four of seventy six-
what were your big
takeaways. It's really it's
really dope to see that
fall seventy six is found
its footing because we all
know what it was like at
first at lunch when- no one
really knew what this game
was there wasn't much to
do. And there's no NPCs you
just had to interact with
with the players in the
world and it was really
confusing what that game is
but I think over time with
the updates they've really
found a core audience and
have the building out and-
struggle to GamePass
because it is one of the
most played games off of
GamePass and it's really
cool to see. The impact of
connecting with your
community- understand what
they want to see in the
game and working with them
through the different
updates and kind of helping
them. Be part of how the
game is shaped and its
future because there's so
many games as service and
when they find their
footing it's really cool
but also just how powerful
GamePass can be. I think
you what you'll see in the
conversation is that all of
the steel rain update which
we- dig into a lot more is
kind of- really nails that
it's a continuation of the
previous update and a lot
they have a lot of exciting
things especially if you
are into the fallout.
Xbox Series X thank you and
yes. After michael highgam
upon us and six into. We'll
be joined by the- gene park
and Amira vigil to discuss
all of that favorite games
from this year's E3 cystic
around. This is play for
all GameSpot's Gaming
showcase for the summer and
charity efforts for able
gamer is what we talk about
the latest and greatest in
video games. And we're
talking about a game that
has been out for a while
but is not stopping in
terms of DLC and updates
we're talking about fallout
seventy six and here to
talk about it with me. Is
Jeff Gardner project lead
and mark Tucker the design
director how are you all
doing today. Wonderful yeah
we're all we're all hanging
in there saw I'm good- and
there's a lot of exciting
stuff gonna fall seventy
six I'm glad that you all
can join me. Let's talk
about steel rain that
trailer kind of has a lot
of into implications for
where fought seventy six is
going to go so. I can kind
of give it give us a quick
run down of those who may
have missed it. Yeah so. It
still rained is the second
half of our brotherhood of
steel a story arc. So we
kicked it off last year
with steeled on. We
introduced a lot of new
characters obviously you.
The brotherhood of steel
that returns appellation.
And you know over the
course of that story arc
you you learned that.
There's some conflict with
in the leadership. Of the
brotherhood of steel. And
so as you know. As a
player. You know. It
engaging in these quests
are gonna make some
interesting choices are
going to learn a lot about
these leaders. And the
mission for the brotherhood
of steel. And by the end of
still don- you know things
that really kind of come to
a head with that conflict.
But you know- trouble and-
you know various events
coming to the threes right
so at the end of still
dont. Right when this
conflict comes to a head.
You're dealing with this
other. Conflict with this.
And so that's of where you
the Boston still gonna we
pick up still rain. So now.
In still raining. You know
yes your dealing with the
conflict within within the
leadership in trying to
decide. Who you know who do
you think is gonna force
the best path forward for
the brotherhood. But in an
industry that got the super
means right now that has
emerged and- reports of
missing people across.
Across Appalachia so.
That's kind of where we
pick up that's where-
single player has to- take
different quests are you're
gonna you're gonna be
talking again with- dealing
with raiders. And rich
caravan makes fun of
parents so there's- you
know we were kind of tying
back into a lot of the
existing. Factions and PC
so we better use- prior
sort of the evolution of
fallout seventy six kind of
going into a more- story
based kind of direction. I
think was very exciting at
first of course- things
take time to kind of flesh
that out and it's good
you're kinda. Starting to
see the fruits of that
labor- and it's very
fascinating how it's done
for a live service game
obviously MMORPGs done
this. For a while but-
how's the team handle
trying to tell stories
within a live service game
what. Specifically would
still rain how are you able
to handle factions and-
choice and consequence in a
persistent world. Yeah
you're right that's a
really- tricky challenge
and a multiplayer game. You
know a lot of the choices.
We offer players. We have
to reflect those choices
are in unique and different
ways and single player
again so. We have to
leverage- well. Our
instance in technology
where we can kind of
reflect. The choices that
they've made within within
the spaces inside the game
in the case of still
raining. Choices you made
still dont. Are going to
affect. Your dialogue
choices and how help of
these NPCs interact with
you. I instill rand and I
will say like. We have some
pretty meaningful. Long
lasting choices at the by.
The end of this- content
that really are going to
sort of determine. The
future of the- and- now.
You said. Very fascinating
about you know that having
dire consequences at the
end of the steel rain stop
sort of storyline now
course. I'm not gonna ask
you to give away what
happens- but- but with that
in mind- does that present
like new challenges that
you've had had to face
before in terms of okay
where do we take the
seventy six story what's
the next story contact a
look like or have you
planned ahead for that and
accounted for. Those sort
of different directions
like all these players can
make there's a lot of
planning that goes into
this- you know we have a
lot of unique challenges
with this with this game
because players complete
content in different orders
so we have to take that
into account when we're
creating content- we also
have to deal with. The
reality that our game is a
prequel incomes before all
of the other follow up
title so that means
anything we create or add
here needs to fit within
the greater you fallout
universe and more so that
those are challenges right
there that we have to
contend with and are always
thinking about because we
can't. We have to be
cognizant like if we add
something into this game
you know it needs to stand
up and sit with them and
everything else that's
that's come before and so
that you know that right
there is a huge challenge
being a prequel is
something that's- in the
barber's don't do. I always
have to on our idea. Who is
the lead is fall three and
he's a our warm now- and
it's there's there a lot of
okay are everything we do.
But as far it makes it it a
it's a very interesting
michael highgam about it
but at the same you have
creative restrictions there
that you don't. The thing
that we want do longer term
it's- you know we have a
lot of ideas. And things
that we're thinking about
but- you know we're not.
Committed to any one thing
just yet. We do you listen
to our players we- we like
to hear what they say what
they think about the things
we put in the game. So that
that kind of helps. The
decisions we make longer
term yeah I actually have a
question about that a
little. Later on but I
guess Alaska now since you
brought it up. And ask a
lot of last I asked
developers to do MMORPGs an
ongoing gains about this
like. How do you balance
player feedback with. Your
vision for the game because
I know that. When followed
semi six kind of started.
There was a very vocal
community about the
direction at lunch and then
kinda adjusted course now
it's grown into something
that. You know maybe no one
expected back it when it
first launched so. How do
you balance your vision
with player feedback and-
yeah hi how do you deal
with that now- with the
fallout seven six in the
place that it's an- there's-
you you wanna always read
and if you try to look at
quite a few back and try to
take it from the point of
view of the fans just want
what's best for the game
that they will offer even
if it's negative. So you
look at it you take into
account and then hopefully
mark and I and others on
this project have a meta
version of the game and we
realize things both in
terms of what we can do
what we can't you for
different reasons right
there's always time
restraints everything is
sort of a priority waiting
on something else- it's a
very interesting take on
this is we've found one of
the things that we have
done in the last years
we've watched a private.
Public test server. I'm PC.
And so we really read and
take that feedback very
seriously and marking talk
more details about their-
there's two systems we put
in the game. Legend our
parks and our our our
newest one legend or
crafting. We have taken
that feedback into account
and changed. Course have
agree on what we were
trying to DO. Because all
best all the best laid
plans. Like they don't. You
think you're doing the-
right stuff on paper. Or in
a microcosm of the game
you're testing the twenty
thirty forty people when it
was a hundred. Thousand
seems. Very different.
Especially we test games.
When you're testing game
like this in a very
isolated where you're
talking a very specific
thing. For folks hoping for
thousands thousands
thousands or see it very
differently. We think that
we do but we just. Like we-
shortcut that content.
Difference even. Yes Sir.
Sir Future Christine took
how. Players are playing
the characters that they
they- they noticed her
strawweight started playing
at the- there's all these
sort of psychological
things but we really.
Didn't the crux of it is
we- take it very seriously
we read on we try to
explain our reasoning. I
was different first year in
the past we sort of did
things we never really
explained folks why and-
how. But we took choose
from other games and
services that your better
job of corn Hey we- we
understand. This is an
unpopular decision this is
why we're- and I find that
works well. In game
development and also with
the community up. Also
sometimes decision and made
are made from. Re for on.
Each to explain- now before
we move on from C. rain do
want to kind of ask a
little bit. Some specific
things that you saw in the
trailer so- there's two
phrases- choose justice or
choose unity. Also I will
mention that those teams
kind of represent the
choice you have to make.
Within the brotherhood- but
also there is a power suit
with- like this. Red white
blue power suit like. You
tell me more about what
what what. So you know we
when they saw there were
some people are. I'm sorry
I'm on the and then I'm a
regular design director.
Ernest by him I'm gonna get
a third take another put it
in even more so. Any and I
don't. Yeah I'm- a
superstar that power armor
in relations the story
marking talk more about the
story thanks to my yeah.
The power over that case I
think which is something
that looks really cool
instead the moment. Excited
to look. I don't know if
this is a secret or not but
I guess someone can don't
yell at me we are launching
this right after the fourth
of July as well so it the
street there right now it's
July seventh- now in terms
of- the teams as I
mentioned earlier the two
the two step two I guess
split into factions for the
brotherhood- can you tell
me just at least a little
bit about like thematically
what you're going for in
terms of storytelling
because I know. It can be
kind of. The brotherhood is
if the organization. As
though they bring forth the
fallout since day one. But
you can only go back and
forth about how you feel
especially throughout all
the different games that
you played- throughout the
series but- yeah what kind
of themes are you hitting
here. When you're trying to
tell the story about a rift
in the brotherhood of steel.
Well you know from the get
go- we really wanted to try
to capture some of the- big
this seems that you've seen
within the brotherhood
across the different-
follow games right. And we
wanted to capture that- it
really kind of show the
conflict within- those
scenes right like. The
brotherhood. Has done a lot
of different things it's
there's a lot of different
options and whatnot and so
we wanted to capture this.
You know there was a sort
of idealism- within the
brotherhood originally were
sort of this. You know.
Humanist organization where
there really are trying to
help humanity. Right but
then there's sort of. You
can with any idealism you
can twist it right things
can change and you can kind
of make it into something
different so then you have
this other version. That is
still trying to help
humanity but in a much more
sort of- hardliner rigorous
way and so we kind of.
Reflected that with her to.
A to her main characters we
have- paladin Ramani. And
night Shannon and using
that you folks that are. At
odds with each other
brightly. Colored Ramadi's
really more interested in
directly helping people and-
it's not necessarily as
concerned with. You know.
Keeping technology in
Ording technology from
everybody we're- persia and
these the dangers and
technology. And you know
chin also sees the dangers
of you know acting. What
he- the way he feels like
rumahnya. Rationally and we
touch a lot of that. With
our story or so we have
this kind of. Two different
ideals- coming to had
because they're- so
isolated and they're far
from- you know the west
coast of the headquarters
and leadership of the
program. And they they've
lost communication are kind
of on an island another
sort of. Having to compete
with each other for whose
whose ideals are gonna
take- take the lead and
that's where you know a lot
of the player choice and
agency comes at. Right and
so by the end that will be
heavily reflected in what
the players get to doing-
but you know. The story
across like. Try not to
spoil too much. Yeah yeah-
now the other I that for
are curious about the pet
now I know that you all
have too much just on it
quite yet- it is with ways
out but it is part of
follow at seventy six is
efforts to what are called
expeditions which are
venturing outside of well
what we know as the faults
of the six- Virgil map- and
that seems to be really
genuinely exciting stuff-
and I feel like y'all can
do a lot of
experimentation. With with
what were were false every
six goes so- am I on the
mark there in terms of like.
Expect expeditions are kind
of your way to be
experimental I know there's
not much to share but- yeah
tell me a little bit about
more what you what you all
are trying to do with these.
We always wanna go off map
right. Especially after
Gaming been out for two or
at this point it'll be. Two
three years. Folks have
explored mac thoroughly we
can do different things
biomes creatures and- some
sites and skylines. So
there's and then. When
marks in the folks in
Austin came with a list of.
Places to go trust me
there's a lot of new places
to- but this seems like an
obvious choice- I was lucky
enough I worked I was a we
produce- original. Long
time ago each is required.
So hi hence all John and I
think Tom how. We just
wanted to do like what I
love history city it's near
us it's one of my favorite
to go over my wife on
weekends stuff so we just
really wanted to do it. And
we're super excited to be
able to go back there and
expeditions are are in the
way for that to come up
with to gamer find it gamer
find a little more into to
open up the idea that there
are more to come yeah I
mean a high level the way
we think about them and
talk about them-
internally- just sort of
our taglines like. Your
expeditions are repeatable
and randomized offsite
missions. Are two very
exciting locales and all
the universe and- coupled
with that you know there's-
we have. A strong story
behind it right we have a
lot of love story German-
elements behind it so- so
yeah it's- there are. It's
fun because- we're offering
glimpses into different
parts of the following
universe at this point on
the timeline so you know
we're going to the pet. But
it's actually before the
fallout three DLC right so
that's kind of interesting
we're going to get to- see
sort of where things were
at that point the time line
and we get to do that with.
Other within the following
universe in some locations
we may end up going to. My
team source smaller
locations that may never
make it into a real game so
it's kind of a fun.
Opportunity as a fan to see
sort of these small windows
within the following
university wouldn't
probably ever get to see
otherwise. But I can't wait
to go back to Vegas. You
never know in a living room.
Follow to follow my fallen
Vegas fans out there know
the five. But yeah. Yasiel
of men but- yeah before we
close this out I want to
give you an opportunity is
there anything else that
you want to share about
false every six- before we
let y'all go- just quickly
for me. Remember it's just
this press one a great
liberal love and I just
always want to thank the
fans of the folks working
on it for sticking with us.
And in seeing this through.
It's one of the most- play
games on GamePass right
now- you know it's- sort of
a small renaissance and we
like to do experimental
things are patches we
haven't. Really had a
cadence of. This release on
these dates or anything so
we just we like trying
different things and see
what works and- and that is
largely driven by the fans.
On both internally and it
does you're an externally
on the forms of Twitter and
reddit. Discord now- you
know and again like this
updates free all the things
weren't were or talking
about are free so if you're
on the Gaming and turn it
on a long time please come
back. If you have it you
know. Check it out it's-
it's a great place it's
kind of unbelievable
community a very welcoming
players will cool. Cool
draw you when and- I'm
sorry this universe in a
way that I think is you. To
a lot of. So I'm I'm I just
couldn't. It's been a great
joy of my career. Here's
thank you that's cool yeah
that's cool here mark yeah
I think I yeah you know-
for those players that
it's- got to Gaming we
first released and haven't.
Been back you know we've
been busy the last couple
years so encourage you to
come back and see all the
things we've added and
changed. It's a pretty
different game from when we
launched and- we're still
adding a lot of cool new
stuff. You know we've been
talking a lot about still
rain today. Other things
that we've got an
entertaining. We have a
whole new season coming
out. Which is gonna be
super awesome. Featuring a
Kitty well- which we
introduced our previous
season. Really fun stuff
there- and we touch a
little bit on legendary
crafting that's a whole new
expansions to our listener
item game. We're also
adding and- power armor-
legendary however in the
state which is gonna be
really exciting- and we
have a new vendor that's
gonna show. You how to
clean the world- that's
going to offer great deals
with our gold bullion
currency so. There's a lot
of cool stuff coming out-
really appreciate the fans
are stuck with us and
looking forward to seeing
some old ones come back-
and- yeah. As Jeff
mentioned this is been.
Definitely a privilege to
work on it's a really fun
game to work on- and we
really appreciate our fans
and- yeah I'm looking
forward to- just to rain
and we've got a lot of
other cool things like. The
jet coming up- in the
future so. We're gonna be
busy Jeff Gardner project
lead and mark Tucker design
director. On fall seventy
six. Thank you so much for
sharing so many details
about the what's coming up
in the game and- all right
thank you all for watching
as well. And I want you to
stick to GameSpot dot com
because we have so much
more. For play for all with
our charity efforts are
live streams. And so much
more fun stuff in the world
of video games so thank.
You all for watching we'll
see ya next time.
Welcome
back to games with coverage
of E3 twenty twenty one and
once again I am joined by
industry friends. To
discuss all of the biggest
reveals from this week. I'm
also clearly hitting
puberty I'm very sorry.
Joining me from Gaming
Palma is liana ruppert
hello I'm excited thank you
for having me thank you for
being here from Washington
post gene park. Everyone
happy to be here on
GameSpot. Yeah it was great
to have you I'm as well we
are joined by ex mayor
mayor prolific I Yujiro
streaming my seen her on-
the Sims sparked last year
as well hi hi. I do. Glad
to be here thank you for
having me. Yeah well thank
you all Ijoma it's been fun
kind of getting these
panels together just to
kind of this is the best
fit E3 like when everything
sort of dying down all the
announcements over you can
finally just like no doubt
about the games that were
shown- weekly friends so
let's go rather how is you
E3 been obviously this is.
The first year it's kind of
old when did you tell if
it's very it's a different
show it's the it seems like
there's way more press
conferences there's way
more. To use Bo Burnham
vernacular but like a
little bit of everything
all the time for well more
than a week which is what
we used to used to- study
on it what's your E3 been
like. Weird it's like you
said it was been you know
usually it's- could that
work condensed and knowing
it spread out. And I don't
know I feel like some of
those showcases that
necessarily. Need to be
showcases they could have
been an email but- whatever
but it was. Yeah I think
that. Honestly though I
think Xbox what really took
it this year and that was
what I was both excited for
so it's nice to kind of see
like everybody had a really
hard twenty twenty and-
it's kind of able to make.
That work for them in. Yeah
it's- been busy but- kind
of a big to do that or- the
Square Enix would say chaos.
Thank yeah I mean I think
you're right I think I
seeing- the fact everyone
did come through twenty
twenty and it seems like
this year E3 there's been a
lot more of like Hey here's
a big press conferences the
most we just wanna show
devs playing and being
excited and talking about
the game's gene. What do
you think that you think
that's a fair point-
totally- to build off what.
Liana said- you know-
obviously everyone had a
really rough years so I
feel like it's expected
that. Like that not a lot
of folks will show. Up it
makes me think about how.
E3 has. Kind of become like
a homework assignment. That
publishers and developers
need to like build time
for. Like like we all we
need to trailer we need a
vertical slice to show off
and- you know as we
definitely saw from. A
quite a number of
publishers there really
wasn't much to show- you
know- I'm gonna bring in
Capcom because Capcom. I'm
gonna first base Capcom
Capcom has out of amazing.
With you the best selling
games. Of the year. And so.
The shop E3 and it's like
whoa we've already like
done our thing you know.
Average people village in
monster how to rise a
tearing up the charts- so
we got more updates on that
you know- so that's kind of
what I felt like like I
wonder. What we could do to
help. Ease this pressure
off studios and in that way
it we can ensure a better
show for fans too because
it's hard it's really hard
not to think of you to be a
something for the fans out.
That's something that ESA
husband has positioned E3
as now to- so. You know
that maybe they'll be just
be left disappointed at-
people if but they're just
a little bit more concern
this is people are able to
show. Yeah and Amira before
we discuss our favorite
reveals miss your show. Do
you think like that this is
the future of E3 like
everyone kind of impact in.
Two a week or do you think
that publishers would
benefit from sort of. Going
out and doing it their own
way like kind of do what
Sony's done and pull away
from E3 and- make more of a
splash themselves later on
when. Things on so busy. I
definitely think so- as a
content creator and a
consumer myself I feel like
things being spread out
will give us. More time to.
Take in the information
without it. You know
feeling like it's
overwhelming because I
admit it was so much going
on this weekend that I had
to like most of my
information is like from
the time line and recaps-
because I had such a busy.
Like work week. I wasn't
able to like her tune into
things and- actually I'm
just so used to like being
there so this is different.
From like. I'm at home I'm
I'm used to just being in
Los Angeles and like seen
the shows seeing them live
in being in the- in the
middle of the action but I
definitely think they would
benefit from spreading
things out. This is a lot
of information. Or you know
consumers to take in at
once but this is also a lot
of. Information and news.
For the people to have to
put out in such a short
time it's a lot of I feel
like it's a lot of
unnecessary pressure. On
those. Out this constant.
Yeah totally I mean. Let's
talk about kind of because
would like hundreds of
games twenty being talked
about over the last week
let's talk about some of
the ones that. Caught our
attention Liana what was
your your favorite game
that you sold was revealed
at this year's E3. I all
professionalism the window
when they showed us hello
infinite I don't even. Care
I hate. It I have like six
different variants of the
energy stored I have like
the giant Needler it's one
of my favorite franchises
of all time. And I kid you
not when they show the
story trailer because
aspects like one of us and
one of my favorite games.
When they show that story
trailer with him like.
Master chief falling down
to the debris and into the
car the end to the pet and
then you had like the Reds
and blacks just the color
theory. Kind of reminded me
of the opening sequence of
aspect too and like my
heart is like pounding. And
then they started showing
off the multiplayer. Member
my boss. With yeah are you.
It was I I'm so happy
because I know when I went
three for three for showed
hello if it it was not met
with the best reception and
I'm so glad that they took
the time that they needed
to kind of re orient
themselves and what their
vision was for the game
environments looked
incredible the- Cortana
light. The mystery of what
actually happens like.
Mysteries afoot to timer
master chief to figure it
out again and I don't know
it's- everything about it
was just. Open and
multiplayer with the
grapple hook in the changes
they made this night being
and the recall Sir and the
new vehicles it's like.
Because in the words hi I
just. I got a thought.
Thank talking about it
we're- but- that was a
couple of notes that they
loved him and it was like.
Just because- and like you
said I mean we found what
everyone was talking about
you know the last time we
saw hill incident last year
it was kind of like a
little bit of it that's
sour taste in everyone's
mouth everyone felt like a
little bit disappointed
oversee they kind of Sir
Craig and run away with him
being mean but it I'm
really glad that they took
the time to delay the
Gaming like work on it to
get that kind of reaction
because like. You say you
cry I will not name names
but when hello if it was an
initially revealed I was in
the games but will remain
E3 and one of my colleagues.
He's so. There is no she-
let me excited about
getting he yeah. A gene
what about you. Well I
don't wanna make a halo if
show- but I will see if you
have a wonderful nice. It
was so nice to see Joe
Staton- the author of the
first three halo two-
stories of back on the
stage- I'm old enough that
I was back in E3 two
thousand two. And I saw
Staten- play halo to live
and that was like the big
trailer that really set the
standard for like big
budget trailer is back
that. So it just felt
really good to see starting
back in a project and- and
that I'm surprised it to be
really really excited for
battlefield twelve twenty
forty two- and I'm not a
huge battlefield fan. But I
love- disco that that that
this year is always done
and it's just really really
nice to see a multiplayer
game- just really really
push the boundaries of what
a large scale a worker look
like and it's nice to see-
the battlefield. Series
entice really really needs
seeming to have to really
take that. As a focus. Yeah
totally I mean NATO. Yeah I
mean there's rados ripping
of buildings I mean like
and it just looks like a
such a huge map- that the
hundred twenty players love
it I feel like like we
haven't seen the experience
like this in a while so.
Yeah and especially I mean
it it always feels unfair
to kind of pick one French
I 1 Gaming series against
another but you know with
call of duty taking a more
quiet E3 you know
typically. In years past
they would be all over the
Sony stage- we're just like
making their presence felt
and so for them. To be a
little bit as a part of
just show- you don't have
any G. M. John ferries that
just took a little bit
about could you see but
then it felt it felt like.
I'll feel re still the show
when it came to- well
between the two of them I
was gonna say between
office procedures but we
have. Seen a lot hello. So
yeah and Amira what about
you. Me is a bit a game but
I would say it's a toss up
Mike's is a toss up seats.
The new Super Mario party
and also read full- I'm
super excited for read full
and like the trailer it
looks really really cool at
this point I'm just really
ready to see like a game
playing characters look
really good they pick some
good voice actors and
actresses. And I love
vampires I love shoot em up
games like I love that type
of stuff you know- so I'm
really curious to see what
the game play is going to
consist of because I'm
really interested like I
thought it I think I
watched a trailer like ten
times. I'm like okay this
is good- you make fun of
Arcanum games. I'm yes but
this right here like. Like
I was I'm excited-
definitely they have
another game coming out to
that I was- looking at that
I guess it hasn't released
yet- yes we yeah that's
coming out in September
yeah definitely so that's
not even it was another one
it was I think. Man it was
a it was a superhero game I
think is a DC area it
wasn't but definitely
definitely something we're
waiting on to- right. Is
right here I yeah I was
like no I need game play
like as soon as I see
things I get excited about
the first thing I'm just
like where's the game play.
What. And every feeling
vampires are having
something of a moment
sometimes I like co op
shooter is- noon everyday
kind of coming back into
into vogue at the moment
yeah I'm right there with
you read full I am a huge
fan of arcane and sort of
like I was genuinely so
surprised to see them this
old for this project not to
leak but also to be the big
surprise me in the Xbox is
shown and like like you
said I think we'll just
dying to wait and see work
begin playing through looks
like are you also
mentioned- the new Mario
parties while. And which is
going to marry opposing and
I brought it back with my
new fun twists which I
think is great- hi Matt
like than the stalls a I am
getting like we played on a
Super Mario party awhile
back and it was amazing it
was just like the good old
days on playing with your
friends on your console
and- in it was really
exciting they're a little
bit of drinks in there too
and. It was really a fun
turn up I'm- those. Yeah
you got a little box though
I'm all lie got a little
time late it was great
anyway just this so many
like many game we have get
to we couldn't even get
through everything in like
a knight I'm like we're
going to have to come back
to this place. This was so
fun. Yeah I want. And I'm
like yes- yeah I mean the
thing is like I hadn't
played- my apology for the
longest time that I've
played the most recent one
and I played it actually a
few weeks ago because
London is way more open up
we went to a blockades and
they had Mario party and we
were those obnoxious people
in the corner screaming.
Stealing stars of each
other like doing the whole
thing so I'm very excited
to do that with some more
classic boards- keeping on
Nintendo I mean Hey it's go
online place I will I will
play with you if you want
to do it transatlantic
Lilly- look. At the game
but I'm down here for. Me
you just put blame blame
the online displaying the
server that's what I do.
Thank you flag. The both
that I'm- I'm- but let's
give Nintendo because they
had- one hell of a show I
Jeanne what do you make of
Metroid dread yeah- I am
super excited obviously a
lot of people are waiting
for major crime- me
included but I've also
wanted to two D. Metroid a
new treaty Metroid- so I'm
really really excited- I
have faith in Rikers
stream- there at the dare
to Spain in Madrid Spain
based you DO that's making-
Metroid. Dread and they did
a pretty good job with
Samus returns and- they've
cut their teeth on the
Castlevania game Konami and
most of them were were
pretty good so I'm really
excited to see- how much
they've improved- it's
always a relief to see- the
series original director
one of the regional
directors a U. S. U. S. I.
Komodo- back at the helm as
producer and he's writing
this story it is making
sure that it stays true to
Metroid- scene- you know
it's nice to see metric go
back to its really scary
you you re routes- I played
Metroid back when I was a
kid on the any S. and right
from the title screen. It
just launches and it just
comes in with this really
really like the dark and
cold **** beat and music
and it's nice to see
Metroid dread kind of like
the lake could continue to
honor that as you know you
are Samus Aran your loan
women in this planet and
you have no idea where.
You're going like like I'm
into it. Yeah I mean I you
will kind of throw my hands
up here and say that I.
I've never really had the
much experience of metro.
But just I kind of. Working
the show seeing everyone I
work- exploding slack and
seen the reception. On
Twitter. I I'm just like
I'm really pumped for it
like it looks. Like the-
creepy stuff- I cried-
Liana. Amira what's on
Metroid. That's a lot she
did throughout that whole
part she never comes to
make those cover it was
great. Sorry. I'm excited
for it that is definitely
something I thought I was
like oh I want to play this
I haven't played much
writing years so it's going
to be cool and when I say
years I mean like back in
the day like I was a little
kid- so it's gonna be
really cool to come back to
measuring and joy that hi I
definitely was happy about
that too- another game that
I was really excited for.
The wild even though they
gamer stresses me to no end
number from my sister soon.
It's just. It's hard for me.
I think I just like the
epic games and it's not as
simple as like- I'm one of
those super casual casual
like I play games on wind
in the slightest bit of
stress annoys me but I'm
like I have to come out of
that- in kind enjoy things-
that breath of the wild.
You know used to stress me
out because those monsters
are hard- yeah. Eight to
get I think it's sort of
quite a bit. Well that's a
fun game that I like to
just you know lay in the
bed and like play on my
switch and I'm I'm really
excited to see- but this.
Week was going to consist
of and how this is going to
call. Yeah I'm I'm like
I've been replaying- one of
the things I never finished
the first time in play but
I've been playing breath of
the wild myself over the
last year or so- because
lockdown nowhere else to
be. And I go through these
phases with it where I have
like I feel like I'm
breezing through it and
then I will find a trial
where it's a trial of
strength and I would just
get so mad I have to use
all my food that I've
cooked all the potions that
I've spent all this time
making. And so I'm already
I'm already right there
with you I get what you
mean about the kind of he's
thanks in it yeah read on.
Like but it is such a fun
game and it's influence is
being felt all over like
everything. All these games
kind of like lord it and
you can tell these
developers love it so much
and it's definitely. I set
a new standard I think his
older as well Liana what do
you think about with the
world's. Do you I. Cool I
need to know what's going
on planes armed man because
like. I know we got the
glimpse of it like
corrupted by I don't know
when that first teaser at
him and linker Hammons
older going in and you
discover this dark cave in
you know it's betting up
for the danger ahead at I
don't know I feel like. Ten
point foil hat time but I
feel like we're. Waking up.
Got it or if it were. I
think EIC either he had
like so kind of a- to. Laid
and like maybe links. From
the but tripped it or- or
E3 when he woke up he woke
up and he just got mad
somehow but I want to learn
more about that that portal
jumping move he did in the
trailer. Hi that was one
thing that bugs me like you
talk about you know
stressing out this game.
The a weapon breaking
really annoyed me. Because
it took so long to make it
feel balanced it didn't
feel meaningful at all
until much later in the
game so a lot of people I
feel like maybe you might
have quit before it got
meaningful. But more than
that is like the stamina
FRAP was like I just. Let
me go look this cliff I.
Think I swear. I don't know
that I thought would do
that portal job extra right
up until the- let's but-
over to number claiming
number claiming no. Rules
now Nintendo they called me
like make sell the player
will make it couch co op
with all the optional if
you want it. I just want to
know and more dogs it needs
more dogs we thought yeah
he actually needs. To
happen this time. Yes it
would be dope buildings are
becomes like a hobbies are
you like that power.
Because the way. They thank
you does look like the dog
and it was like you know I
to worry about. Yeah I like
whatever energy
michael highgam energy or
whatever that you have it
installed on- I be brought
that allowed three times
four to sixty Korat seeds-
I played it so much and I
can't wait for part two of-
I. Like the I don't want to
even know anything about
it. That's the trouble of
being games your list I
have to like I don't I
don't know anything about
Hey look how do you do.
That is one no I want to
play it. Of but now. Have I
because it. My job I have
to know about these things
and it sucks because I wish
I could have a media
blackout. Well I feel the
same way like. This is
because I'm like right near
the end of breath of the
wild. And like seeing I
want to see what breath of
the wild fecal looks like
for the same time I'm like
I don't wanna spoil.
Inadvertently spoil myself
I don't I think that
keeping things. Very very
under wraps. So I mean
they're not talking until I
didn't even say what. The
name of the game. Is so I
think I'm- by. It's brother
well too until they tell us
otherwise okay so all
right. Is going to breath.
Well I. That's why we're
that's likely to be the
name just rather the flight.
Or something like. A not
charged Gaming games. The
wild to the skies and
beyond- something I'm only
good times hearing our
panel I'm Mary Jean the
only thank you so much for
joining us- to the handles
on the on screen after to
go check out all the
incredible work that these
three do coming up next we
have an interview. But the
future of Marvel's Avengers.
And I am jordan ramee and I
am joined by Josh Bassett's
project director for
Marvel's Avengers thank you
so much for joining us
today to talk about some
new Marvel's Avengers
content. Absolutely excited
to be here thanks for
making time to speak with
us as well. Of course now
like right before sitting
down like literally right
before the ten minutes. Ago
I got to see a new trailer
for some of the new content
coming to Marvel's
Avengers. Of the New
control the new cosmic cube
events that new content
coming in the Wakanda
expansions. Lots of cool
stuff I had to mute myself
but it wouldn't embarrass
everyone in the discord
call. But I have loads and
loads of questions and I
really want to start with
the cosmic cube events
specifically- because this
like new event seems like
very geared towards like
finally taking on. Monica
who's kind of been the
story of the Avenger side
for a very long time- is
this like a closing chapter
for an arc for Marvel's
Avengers. Because it feels
very final occur finally
going after the big bad
who's in charge of paying
this kind of been around
for awhile and now we're
finally going after her
and- the feels like a sort
of like in tame type of
moment. Yeah we absolutely
showcased our upcoming-
event cost to keep event
which launches next week-
and yeah and it we have our
an exciting news on sector
as you said will face off
against Monica refugee.
Assigned to supreme and
it's sort of a battle for
control over the cosmic
cube which is. The motion
ultimate superweapon that
she can use to bend reality
itself for her when her
will. Over to our heroes.
I'm really really excited
about the story that we're
gonna be telling their and
it's part of the narrative
arc they'll be continue
before with our future
beats and roadmap- but
we're partnering that on
Thursday with a limited
time. Cosmic threat event-
will you be able to partake
in special missions and
challenges to earn our
unique courts. And that
event that mission that
were getting is it's sort
of like- here's a little
bit more story kind of one
and done thing or is it-
sort of event that like you
and your friends should be
playing over and over again
to. Grind out for some new
rewards- we definitely want
you to be planned as both-
if by yourself if you'd
like but also with your
friends- it'll be
multiplayer- content. And I
think you'll definitely
enjoy it if you do so. S.
and we've got of first.
Kind of first look at the
new patrol that. Kinda
coming out that's that in
like the post apocalypse
wasteland- what type of
missions are people gonna
be able to expect from that
new patrol. Yeah like you
said we're we're really
excited to provide that
sneak peek and not a-
wasteland patrols will come
out. Later this year and in
it when players selected
from the work table. The
intermission where. They
can. Play against random
encounters of enemies and
villains any fast
landscape- where there is
no time restraints of the
conjoined. I'm looking
forward to jumping back
into some. Marvel's
Avengers express only four
and like I think this. This
might be where like most of
my excited squeals came
from. When you all finally
showcased. Black Panther
and so the story beats.
That are gonna come in the
Wakhan expansion I'm like.
This looks so does. Thanks
cool. As they look a little
bit- the little bit MCU
inspired in its- design-
what inspirations did you
take and designing this- to
try all of this Wakanda we
definitely inspired
directly from the comics
material- from all the runs
of Black Panther and
especially the more recent-
rise of the Black Panther
run. I said I I'm pretty
sure that was sherry like
his sister I'm like it
seems like her she's got
that Spohn she's got that
personality but I'm like
there's no sometimes I
can't tell like who the
speaker. Yeah yeah well I
edit we tease Black Panther
without his mask we
definitely showed sharia
throne room- we also showed
a claim EA. And the rest of
the Dora Milaje eight. Are
we also teased are you this
is Claude the main villain
for this expansion and in
our story he's- alternately
trying to steal avocados
vibranium it's up to you
plan as Black Panther with
the rest of the ventures
and the rest of Wakanda. To
stop. As I E. it was hard
to like get a gist of just
like how. Much there was
just looking at that
trailer is this something
that's similar in scope to
what players have seen
already with- Hawkeye and-
Kate bishop expansions is a
little bit bigger is a
little bit smaller. Yeah I
think that the expansion is
considerable in size to the
past operations that we've
done both between the
Hawkeye and I kicked isha
and we're we're excited
about. Continuing offering-
additional content on the
monthly basis in which
we're doing that we see
that continuing in the
future. I'm not sure how
much you can go into this
but like the fact that like
Black Panther he's- he's
not an archer he's not like
Kate and haka like even
though they had very
different skills that's
both of them had abilities
and fighting powers that
were. Very like year around
the fact that they have
about one error on their
tools that can you speak to
anything about how. To
chala fits into the overall
like squad make. Up like
what type of character yes.
Well Jeff be covering that
more as we do our updates
to our road map- but what I
can say is it's been so
exciting- clans Black
Panther it's done in the
last few months- on the
development project it
just. You know celebrating
the power of the suit the
wacom technology the
ancestral past- and- you
know. Just. These are both
his traversal and stroke
combats it's gonna be
really exciting. Back to
that because mac- cube. Van
for just a little bit-
should players be like
expected to grind out a
little bit to prepare for
it is there like a minimum
level for it like what's
the way of getting into.
Fighting against Monica. I
yeah I think it'll be
content that's available to
all players to partake in
and we look forward to two
people jump in there and
facing off against. Monica
S. A. it's definitely
things are going up against
Monica it feels like a
very. Post campaign thing
probably not something you
want to dive into. Before
you actually- playing the
story but- should players
go through hot guy and Kate
bishop's- campaign first
before jumping into. The
events of this upcoming
event or does it not
connects to much to those
post launch stories-
absolutely I would
definitely recommend you
know plants the single
player campaign planes and
Kate bush of taking aim
plan through our Hawkeye.
Future in perfect it's just
gonna make the experience
all the more richer and-
and yeah like read the
comics. Look for the
inspirations I have fun
while you play it- and all
of our stories I'm sure
you're used to. It seems
that that the quality the
crystal annexes been
putting out- for the story
of our games- and it this
is no exception with. Every
beat that we. Do is Delbert
intentionally. R. Ford. S.
A. N. for one of these-
thing that we saw in the
trailer so we can go
through them one by one so
the cosmic cube event- new
patrol the Wakanda content
like what's the overall
goal for each of these
things like what is the
ideal for what each one of
these are supposed to bring
to the Marvel's Avengers
experience the way I could
answer that is it's
generally touching on are
generally our whole focus-
for moving forward and I
think it's quite clear and
if there's one thing I want
to say it's this which is.
Crystal and I'm X. is
absolutely dedicated to
delivering the Marvel's
Avengers game our fans want
answer- we aim to deliver
compelling content- you
know we're talking about
things like I Katoch
supervillains I conduct
locations from just the
comics- and ever expanding
cast of heroes and
partnering that with
meaningful rewards and
progression our players
want to serve as a new kind
of detailed out like a road
map for this that we start
in June with the cosmic
cube event like. People are
gonna be able to play the
first part of this trailer
like very soon is this kind
of the plan for the rest of
twenty twenty one or is
this kind of like oh here's
like the next few months
but we have more in the
pipeline after this well we
definitely want to talk
about the road map as we
update it and definitely
celebrate that with the
community and talk through
those beats- I think
they'll be a little bit of
it's not necessarily that
we have a formula that we
want to follow- but given
the time and E3 and the
cost to keep. It made a lot
of sense to talk about here
and we're really excited
about it- but that site
were also taken the same
opportunity to release
speak up about just that
same level excitement you
have for Black Panther you
know sure that- and so we
love to talk about that and
through the course of the
summer we'll be updating a
roadmap and engage in that
conversation thank okay I
feel like I've done my due
diligence I feel like I've
done enough of going back
to talk cosmic cube and.
Patrol that I can now
selfishly go back to our-
you. Questions- Black
Panther- I. Okay I very
curious like if one of
those like. Weird bizarre
things that as we get into
more and more like game as
a service games like
Marvel's Avengers it's like
oh you're gonna tracks like
new players like months
years after the game. Has
already come out like is
there any way for someone
to just jump straight into
the Black Panther content
at their like on picking up
Marvel's Avengers. Later
this year like in the
holidays or something and I
would like to just jump
immediately into this story
just to see it because I
want to try it or is it
more like oh no this is.
This post launch like you
need to grind up to this
yeah we want people to
participate in the content
they're really excited
about and so yeah there's
no- rules restrictions for
a new player jumping in and
immediately clans Black
Panther and experience your
mac. The story missions.
Same with- feud now story
missions under the belt
like a bishop pakai. And
the cosmic cube event is
coming. Black Panther after
that like stories like
beginning to. Fill up where
is there any plans to kind
of do like a- here's like a
quick story recap if you're
like. Jumping in here is
like is anything like that
in the works or is it more
of a like the player kind
of. Needs to fill in the
blanks themselves yeah it's
definitely something we
talk about internally in
the del Valle. Development
team and- we'll definitely
share- any updates that
question as they come in
the roadmap. All right
awesome that is all of my
questions for now the don't
like jump immediately into
please tell me like every
single detail of the story
for Black Panther site know
what it is because it looks
very cool I'm excited to
play. Thank you Josh that
was for putting up with my
D. ky and tex I I'm like.
I'm like partially like
shivering and like
excitement over here and
I'm really really hoping it
doesn't come and on the
video that I was like
bouncing in my chair and
certain moments with a
looks unprofessional- so.
Parris but- that's all the
time we have thank you
again so much for joining
me and answering questions
it's been fun learning
about what's coming in
Marvel's Avengers with the
new patrol with the cosmic
cube vans. With Wakanda
with Black Panther a lot of
exciting stuff a lot of
things that I think people
have been still playing the
game we're gonna be looking
forward to and for everyone
at home who was watching
remember. Stay safe and
stay tuned to GameSpot for
more Marvel's Avengers and
play for all content. Via.
We are back that was a and
feature length interview
for Marvel's Avengers
showing off some of the
Black Panther stuff which
was featured earlier in the
week at the press
conference and- that's
right explained- I may not
laughs I'm active I would
say laughed if I was trying
to preserve any so if they
can if I am actively
playing tomorrow's. Event
so. You need. I actually I
think there's lots of. What
time is we it now yeah did
in out you know I'd wanted
some comes with a look at
my Kokomo she's alright. So
she's turned okay all and
yeah that that is that is
what it's about but- yes
so- why I am super. About
getting the stuff in
because it looks meet it
looks like a big old
Avengers steak. Thank 1 for
his biceps. Well we know
from the- lack. Yeah both
classical. Yeah that's the
flip that's the flip DLC
though like because do you
think about Avengers and
I've talked to Greg about
this too- when ready E3 is
that it was contemplating
Greg is like the biggest
like Marvel's Avengers
stand out there I guess and
my god kind of. I can
respect that- so it's nice
to see the like again this
kind of goes into what I
was saying about philosophy
six as in the with Marvel's
Avengers is that. The
content roadmap it's all
about the road map and the
kind of the feedback you
take in what you do with
that I think like. You
know- Black Panther is that
he is that character- like
the whole the story about
Black Panther is the like
something that will grab a
lot of people including
myself. So like a plate I
understood what it was I
still don't know if the
core of that game is
necessarily up my alley but
I do want to see how the
game is going to fall
because obviously. This
being Marvel is such a huge
you do anything you do
anything with Marvel- so I
think the future is bright
for it and I think a lot I
think my- my taste for is
really depend on how this a
Black Panther DLC- plays
out- but it looks like just
judging from the trailer
and kind of. The different
elements they're putting
into it I do think this is
gonna be very interesting
for those who may be lapsed
or if keep playing like. I
don't know man I don't. You
do it but- I respected.
Lucy is anything there
about ten. To come back
come back to us Lucy. You
know I don't think that is
at this point I think the
black the stuff looks
really cool. One of my
favorite- although heroes
and- I think I would defend
it play that and then
leave. Ultimately because I
think my issue with
Avengers is that I thought
that the campaign itself
was really strong and I
loved the way that heroes
played and I love to be
credible touches that they
had on that campaign. But
when I go to the live
service stuff I would I
just bounced off it so
quickly I have. A very low
threshold full reputation-
in games and- Marvel's
Avengers wasn't nothing but
repetition it was a slow
grind. And you know
watching you- friend of the
show Simon Cardy obviously
living with Greg at the
time. Andrew Goldfarb like
all of you guys going to
the platinum well you guys
trying to hit level cap.
Like you would just I would
just his stories about you
hitting hives over and over
again and I was like come
on to that too he spelled
I'm sorry I need to be I
need to do it like I'm
terrible for. Lake just
bouncing off games dies I
was a terrible thing that I
do all the time but I feel
like once I completed the
Avengers campaign and
bounced off the live action
I felt like I was justified.
They have a ladies and
gentlemen lucy james.
Thoroughly explaining why
she does not want to play
video games. Stephanie I
hate to see it even. I mean.
Of. Yes it. Yeah I am I
like I said I'm excited for
it and thankfully I have
Craig I've been to go far I
have some quality so I'll
be. E3 friend I've got
three friends. Don't need
you. Simon Harding of them
as yeah- wow gold Lasko
I've said that so- in- both
ended up doing nothing well
we will hang out in a pot
you try and play different
games which is. Presently
phone 5 and jazz. Coming up
next we've got a block of
trailer is hot trailer is
coming hot off the presses
I say hot off the presses.
They're actually sent by
email last week and- so
they are they are like
fully fully. Cool down but
it's still good trailer.
We've got games including
tell him. I've got residual
we've got one lonely
outpost no place for
bravery no coal and drugs I
know what you're thinking.
I know how to any of those
games. If you have those
games great job everyone
the people who are like I
am head of any of those
games trust us there were
sticking around for they're
worth checking out because-
we picked. We know a thing
or two about video games. I
do. Michael highgam does
this he doesn't have any.
So. What do you guys know
any about anything about
any of these games yeah one
lonely outpost- was a stand
out when we were at- hello
pointed up here just make
sure I got I got it
straight yeah it was one of
the standout games during
the various indie showcases
that were happening during
E3 I think there there is
also a- like a like a
development developer all
interview about it where
it's basically you know.
The hopper the harvest moon
well yeah I'll kinda like
harvest moon Stardew valley
type thing- but for space
and like I think that's-
it's really interesting
because I think a lot of it
has to do with isolation
and how to deal with
isolation and when you
think when I think back to
Stardew valley and the kind
of like the relationships
you build black and I'm not
sure if when we oppose the
strike and hit like the
same notes is that but when
I look at that game might.
I feel like I get notes of
that no one really want to
try it for myself to see
like how it spends that
sort of genre so I got my
eyes on it I think a lot of
people are tall talking it
up to once it was revealed
during E3 so. Definitely
keep an eye out for.
Anything on that list that
you. Personally I have not
of a of the ones so I make
just to get a fresh of
trailer this meeting will
be. Sorry yeah I think hi
this keep your little.
Things yeah I think for me
that 1 nahi outposts and no
place for bravery ready
stick out as the two games
I'm intrigued in love games
over the lost we can offer
I need to write go back and
watch trailer to write
their names down of
thankfully I've started
using the Jiji app which
allows me to. Create lists
and I've got a list of
indie games I want to check
out- shot he G. were not
sponsored by them but if
they want to focus on
sponsorship money. Hello
are you boys. The blessing.
I DO Eugenia. It's a G.
anyway let's kick it over
to the trailer is enjoy.
What probably.
The.
But
after. At if. You. At seven
but Xbox. But.
But but and-
the- 5.
If.
It. Not. I
don't.
Some already here
maybe something interesting
it's.
If you is make me.
It's an orange pixel anyway.
It's kind of an
extrapolation a modern kind
of debate that we have now
where there's people saying
that organic food is so
much better there really
isn't a clear cut answer
the player will make that
choice the synthetic route
is more about mass
production and control in a
lot of ways a greater
degree of control over the
outcome still with your
plan. By selecting specific
genes and it'll give you
very likely result. Max is
much more distance kind of
like say forget it so it's
less engaging ultimately
will be. Produce high
quality of staff it was
organics you're focusing
on. Your tending to the
individual plants and
experimenting with cross
breeding to try and come up
with new varieties
naturalistic is more hands
on that means that you're
almost always going to have
to check in on. Someone
with the naturalistic farm
probably will never have
this big farm as a
synthetic. Tier two after
you've made that decision
and growing your calling a
little bit more you get
into the third narrative
game which is kind of the
last arc and it's about
colony independence so
you're winning
certifications. Your own
independent little self
government entity. In the
greater universe.
We.
The.
It.
Hi I'm part of the kids
was sixteen and I'm here to
show you a run through of
on you gamer. Read it. Zero
spirits. Say confirm
inspired D. rose light
flashes. Add in proceedings
and it levels a dash of
stealth. And a whole heap
of studio Ghibli inspired
on. And that's pretty much
all game you play as the-
some in spirit of the
prince of the kingdom of
mudra. You mean ability as
you've probably already
seen. This and switch
between the bodies of your
feelings. Each anytime has
their own six stance skills
in a taxi so you find
yourself. To decide when
and if you should change to
a new host body depending
on what the levels during
it you. As you battle
through enemies who come
across various perks and
modifies can you choose
between as well as- a
freight train carried over
from the future and. The
overall story in goal over
experience read the kingdom
of major from an ancient
evil is taking over the
land defeating the great
chaos demon. For now though
which try to find a way
through next you find an
exit to the federal level.
So not only does the ghost
form offer you the chance
to faster and stealthier
around enemies. You can
also see the best way
through the level. Full
some secrets that might be
hidden. All right let's
skip ahead just a little
bit. They're very secret
strangers in challenges
stream trout the levels
that's up to you if you
want to take the bonus or.
So he has the exact we just
got one boss battle to deal
with first.
So that was a
successful run of just one
of all levels. We know the
games like for experience
live and breathe through
close community feedback so
we plan to release in early
access sometime this year.
Followed by full release in
twenty twenty two. If you
currently have the free
steam demo like trying to
solve. Thanks Watson.
And
that was a look at some
more trailer is not
michael highgam did
anything grab your hi- yes-
was a call was the first
game call with the black
and white one with the-
yes. Because I saw that
blow up on Twitter recently
because of how creative it
handles- different camera
angles and it's a
photography game so you're
you have like this top down
view and then you can snap
in the first person. To
snap your photos and I
think it's just such a such
a fascinating way to build
a world because obviously
perspective changes you
look at the world
differently. I definitely
want to check that out I
really like the art style
there I think the game is
doing something very
creative. And now I got my
eyes on it even more so.
Now that we saw trailer.
What are you. Our you are
Carmen which it was I think
it was one lonely outpost-
the one that was- start
your body what we've got
okay so. That I'm I know
what was going on there but
I just look like acoustic
single gonna hi Kelly Xbox
is get the vegetable and
add on those crops so I'm
gonna be playing that game
roleplaying as Goku Baghdad
west dad Goku is just
trying to build up far like.
Half the characters named
after vegetables anyway.
Yep BBC yeah exactly yep
okay Turkey origins that
works that's what's if you.
Home is very little on- I
was and you to be very.
Right now though was going
to go over those two time
another group of industry
piles of this time we have
blessing Adeoye junior from
kind of funny as well SO
what Mike from kind funny
and- giant bombs very own
Jeff Bakalar to talk about
their favorite meals are
from in this year's E3 and
it's a good group of lads
so I'm sure you'll have a
very nice time. The company
to watch and see. What they
thought take a- you're
watching Spohn cover all of
E3 twenty twenty one as
part of play for all and
for this special segment
I've assembled a triple
threat of amazing people
from around the games
industry we've got. But I
should get up up up up
blessing that is when the
blessings come in how you
doing blasting. I'm doing
good man how you doing. I
am doing really well
because we've also call.
The king of high. No
bicycle my sickle how you
doing man I'm so good I'm
gonna talk video games and
share the love and the
passion with you you know
that I'm excited. Fantastic
and we've called the one
and only Jeff. Macula
bacula how you doing Jeff.
Like I wanted I'm hungry
now is what I. Talk with
you find people I'm excited.
Fantastic so first things
first I want to kind of get
your temperature of E3
twenty twenty one you know
it was kind of a weird one
not impressed and very did
you owe a lot of
conferences that if you've
been watching kind of
funny. You would assume a
lot of face problems from
the crew that but we were
given facepalm tempat like
kind of a weird E3 blessing
what did you make of the
three twenty twenty one. E3
twenty twenty one was.
Fairly interesting as he
put it you know coming off
of a year of. Not having E3
and have having the Summer
Games fast and having all
the different. Showcases
and presentations spread
out over a summer I think
the thing that was nice
about having E3 back is
that so much of it is
condensed into this one
week and so we don't have
this. Long summer where by
the end of it we feel super
exhausted granted we are
still to have things like
opening night live and
things like I EA play
happening in July and I'm
sure Playstation is gonna
do something somewhere- so
they're still gonna be some
of that but I do think it's
nice to have. E3 back to be
the central- week of
announcements and
showcases- that said I feel
like this. This weekend E3
it's been hot and cold in
terms of how different
publishers have been
approaching it I think you
see folks like. Nintendo
and Xbox some of the some
of the big ones doing it
right so making sense kick
off doing it right in terms
of. What should a showcase
B. how to how do we
showcase these games and
what are the big
announcements we want to
bring to the show. You know
in a year that's been so.
Weird and difficult for so
many in terms of what it
what it's like to make a
game that you have game
delays you have- publishers
after being unsure about
when their team's gonna
come out which leads to
that maybe not knowing when
to announce. Thank you and
how to announce thing. You
know seeing the fact we got
announces. That had
concrete dates to him I
think is impressive by
itself. I so with that you
know I'm very excited that
we got starfield for next
year I'm very excited that
we got red fall for next
year things like- Brussel
out to you that for next
year then halo infinite
for. This fall still I and
then with Nintendo so many
games are laid out for this
fall I think that alone
made for a very. Exciting
E3 for me and a very
impressive E3 in terms of
you know pivoting and
figuring out what that
looks like. But then on the
opposite side I think you
also had a lot of
publishers having showcases
just how showcases. And a
lot of those where. This is
a into mischief the most
part like. We know it comes
to like what you let
Gearbox. Okay me those a
huge mess for me that. Koch
we- show okay. Was kind of
a mess for what they're
trying to do their Capcom
as well like. You got you
kind of had. Both ends of
the stick in terms of. All
right cool the big guys
doing it big and then the
other guys are. Seemingly
or just having a showcase
because they know they
can't because- digital
which means it's- easy- but
I think that's the
evolution E3 and- we'll see
where it goes from here
we'll see what next year's
E3 looks like. Yeah I think
I feel like that's a-
pretty great summation of
the entire event. Mike- you
know that. We're gonna come
we're gonna have one of the
host of the Xbox on here
without specifically
talking about Xbox- but
obviously. How how do you
think microsoft fat. This
this year because we had a
couple. On shore E3 is.
Previously like what was
your take on microsoft this
time. I was really
impressed with microsoft
this time I think a lot of
the community around the
game for happy to see if
they come back and I think.
They saw microsoft do
really good job of
listening to what their
fans and their viewers want
out of a ninety minute
press conference right you
it have the addition of.
But as the now and we
thought before is but
that's going to have their
own conference so they can
have just a clear divide.
Of Xbox and it does not
think they did a really
great job and building both
of them. Opponents of great
faces like Serra bond at
Todd Howard Pete Hines it
was really exciting. To see
the meld between both of
these companies coming
together and sharing the
spotlight. And that's for
Xbox and just the ninety
minutes it really listens
right they brought us games
games games we didn't have
to go into deep developer
diaries we didn't have to
get lost. With just the
faces talking for an
extended monologue so all
in all ninety minutes of
just fun right and they get
you with someone else like
blessing said. Red fall
coming in twenty twenty two
the anybody was ready for
project Elmander just kind
of splash on the screen.
And halo multi player I
mean that was a big one
right there halo infinite
multiplayer got a big boost
out of everybody. Adam re
energized for the halo
franchise after a poor
showing last year and- they
didn't have to harp on it
right we didn't have to
bring out break the brute.
We don't have to show you
all what we re did was like
Hey. Here's our bread and
butter let's get excited
we'll talk more and so.
Microsoft. Empathize that
they did a great job this
year. Yeah I'm Jeff EIC of
want to get. Take on- show
was a- bowl. What do you
think E3 is looking like in
the future- you know
obviously Sony is. I'll for
now do they need. Does the
FAA need to figure out a
way to bring Sony back
given that. The time that
they would have taken up is
being spent with smaller.
Kind of showcases like
passing mention the Capcom
the Gearbox. Is essential
for the essay to build that
bridge again do you think
all or do you think that
they've got something here
that they can really.
Finesse and fine tune into
something that works even
without Sony. I mean I've
surprised if they were not
actively at all times
trying to repair that- but-
you know. I think what.
ESA's learning and they
have learned a while ago
with a lot of people
realize is that. You know
the these big vendors don't
need E3 as much as E3 needs
them and I hate to B. as
sort of brutal as as that
but that is what this.
World is now that is what.
The world of you know shows
are regardless of the
medium whether it's games
or any honestly any other
sort of. You know. Being-
in the world in terms of
like what industries need
to do to get their things
out in front of people.
We're on a different sort
of. You know schedule now
it's been like that for
awhile even before the
pandemic. I think E3 before
the pandemic was on pretty
shaky ground I feel like
every year we- get out to
LA we get back we're just
like Hong. What's that
gonna look like next year
in that story. You can go
in the in the direction
that I think the essay you
wanted to go to and look
this is just. How we are
evolving right this is just
the nature of it- so I
think. You know all that
said- if you look at like
how did the show go right
like what was that what was
the takeaway what what was
that. You know kinda knee
jerk reaction for me. I
said a lot of like Hey All
Things Considered and I
think that's kind of where
I landed you know. All
Things Considered when you
take into account the way
the plan it changed in the
last twenty months. The
fact that like. We got out
of E3 kind of feeling good
about the state of our
industry- that's a win
right that feels good-
that's what you want to
see. So in that regard I
think that's that's- pretty
impressive that. You know
we- you know all things
considered we got out of
this. On you know it in in
the right sort of frame
where there's some solid
momentum and- and their
stuff to look forward to-
but again. You know in
twenty two we're going to
have this conversation
again and- kind of reset
the deck in and see where
we're at. Yeah show. So I'm
going to hell in a couple
of games. For each of you
that Randy kind of start
out and captured your-
attention blessing was that
a game or two games
whatever maybe have that
really stuck with you and-
I kinda like holy moly this
is something to get excited
about. I think for me the
obvious one is altering ten
or no you're one of the but
when the most high people
want to come Seldon. Is
patient now I'll- it makes
me feel like how a snow
bike michael highgam lives
so it's like. I get it. I
want you I want to feel
like the way tam feels when
about altering all the time
well I got a lot of that
and sell that over the
counter I want that okay.
But yeah I got a recent fan
of from software games you
know I've I be bloodborne
back in December and then
right after I was like I
got a place at corona B.
Secker own I absolutely
fell in love segro. And you
know I've had this kind of
hunger to play more and of
course I have I've dipped
in the demon's souls I
wanna get into dark cell
dark souls as well-
building is when I've been
hyped for because coming
off of both bloodborne
sector I feel like. From
software has this flow that
there and where they are
like Hey we got something
with our formula and we
know how to make different
types of games played games
I still fall into that
core- ethos of. That
political souls like you
know souls born in our
design philosophy of games
that can be brutal in
punishing but also has
immaculate level design and
also have. Just fantastic
combat and also kind of
play around with with that
can be and- we've been
waiting for altering for
awhile you know we got that
we got the original trailer
awhile ago- and I think. So
many of us were
anticipating seeing it this
week into the fact that we
got it was 1 by itself very
satisfying thing but- I
think the look that we got
a game play was very
exciting as well you know
seeing. Civil what that
open world looks like some
of what exploring the open
world looks like some with
the combat looks like- we
got interviews with me is
akki afterwards talking
about- how the world's
gonna be open what what the
dungeon like- aspects of
the map we're going to be
and how they connect
together- it with a
different biomes of the
world. Are going to be in
so much that I think struck
me as exciting and yeah for
me though is that the one
the one of the most
exciting. Things I got from
this E3. Yeah Mike yeah I
know your also. High for.
M. is a same with you have
some. Else that's really
like at tickling your- your-
you know excitement. More
the that. I get this couple
game action when appointed
to and we're gonna keep it
was some extreme sports
over on my side so I want
to give a big shout out to
riders of public. Would you
be soft of course but I
just want to shine the
light on a smaller team and
that's shredders. The idea
Xbox game coming out of-
Xbox is team with a small
development squad
shredders. Is trying to be
the spiritual successor to
amp to. And that's 1 for me
being up here in Tahoe
being ingrained in the
snowboard ski industry. For
all my life I've always
been on the search for that
grounded realistic
snowboard game without EA
big NSX tricky around
really. All the down on the
extreme sports fun I've
always been looking for
who's next in who's gonna
do it right who's gonna
bring it. That more
grounded level and make me
feel like I am on the
slopes but I'm not during
my downtime in. This squad
really looks to be diving
into what skiing and
snowboarding is all about
the fun of being out in the
back country with your
friends. Going out there
and hit no rail hit the box
the one massive offer some
jobs and I'm really excited
to see. What this team can
do come December and- no
online multi player is
going to be a big one for
me and my friends to go
straight the slopes but-
traders and rides a public
definitely have my. Eye
right now for the extreme
sports. Living up to the
snow by. Money that.
Talking about like hidden
by like that easy thank.
Yeah for when I a ball on I
just get. Can make it the
whole way. But I respect
your confidence. I yeah I
wanna see some. Good age
when I Gearbox is I mean
I'm physically colliding
into boxes. A lot yeah Jeff
what what what do you see
the- excited you. So Q.
games really stood out for
me one game I'll parolee
had been announced ready
and I didn't really catch
wind of it that's a comic
heart. I a comic card spoke
to me even though it was a
short little trailer I was
just like. I don't know
what's going on here but
this is so weird and
strange and- feels very
much cut from- the- cloth
of like a bioshock if that
cloth was soaked. In acid
like L. S. D. or something
like that so I'm down with
that whatever that winds up
being I just want to know
more about it. And yeah
also- Somerville- I think
thank Gaming. It did
something to me- when that
trailer ran about like a
family of three kind of
just making their way
through whatever the hell
is going on in that world-
I feel like that's the game
that's gonna make me cry a
little bit. And I- I don't
necessarily want that out
of the game but there is
something- about that the
creepiness. You know it
like. I don't know either
you know there's the
pedigree there that-
there's like a bat pleaded
pedigree there and I think.
You know I wanna I wanna
see what's next for that
kind of thing and that
story is just- the drip
feed is just enough that
that has me- curious about
what exactly that story is
gonna look like. And if
they kill any of those
family members. I'm not
happy at all okay. Yeah
some of- definitely really
cold it hasn't been said so
I'm just gonna drop halo in
for me- that game looks
incredible like- the
multiplayer specifically
and- the thing that excites
me most is like my friend
circle has grown in a-
massive way over the last
few years like when I
played halo loss really
intensely. It was a smaller
group of people now you
know I'm like surrounded by
people that I know that
love halo and I'm gonna be
into it like I cannot wait
I can't come out and it's
free the multiplayer jump.
Hello my. Friends it's
gonna be awesome. Before we-
close this I will to.
Return to E3 a whole point
and- kind of go around and
get the ideal what do you
think that the SAT sure-
kind of. He all I know-
impacts change to make sure
that the next time we do
this it's a success-
anything everything busing
what do you reckon is a key
thing for them to either
change or do to make sure
that. Next time we come
back it's good time. Yeah I
mean that's a that's a very
good question because next
time we come back it'll
probably be an in person
E3. You know I know for us
people on the media side
you we kind of missed out
on. Having those in person
demos the behind the closed
doors previews and all the
things that really make E3-
a valuable experience for
us being able to report on
games he missed a lot of
that this year and so. A
lot of our reactions you
come purely from trailer
isn't talking about. The
gameplay demos that we see
in the Nintendo treehouse
live and things like that-
inside I want to see them.
Go back to that and figure
out how to make that still
worthwhile especially if
they're going to stick to
a- hybrid or somewhat
digital model. Because for
E3 I don't ever imagine E3
is going to be. The same E3
that we knew and like a
twenty eighteen you know I
don't think E3 will ever go
back to being an all in
person if and I think. In
the future is going to be
somewhat of a mix between
we have now. And what we
had in the past and so.
With that I want to see
them figure that out I also
want to see. Better and
clear communication
regarding. What makes a
showcase a showcase because
I know when they put out
the whole E3 calendar. You
know. Not all showcases are
equal in terms of. What
their purpose is and what
the level of announcements
are at them. What I what I
get for a microsoft but
that's the game showcase is
way different from what I
got from the Capcom
showcase. And I want to see
them- that. Specify that
out in a way that feels
clear whether it is
changing the language in
making it so that. The Xbox
but that's the thing that's
presentation- that
Square Enix thing that's a
presentation what- I
Gearbox did that's more of
a- who knows ad or
marketing they are at thank
they got if I feel you
gotta find language
delineate yeah Hey this is
this and this is this this
is gonna have big
announcements this is a
must. Let's see if being a
must tune in thing where is
this is more of a that
programming thing this is
here just take up the slack
I think them figuring out
what that is what that
looks like for them is
going to make it so that
there is there is more
value in terms of Hey you
know everybody gather
through and watch this
thing together because this
is going to bring an
excitement versus people
leaving with this point in
what they do to. Do tune
into a Capcom showcase. And
there's not much new there.
Yeah michael highgam you
reckon it was really well
said blessed I would add
ons that of like kind of
that take to that Koch
media could almost be
slotted in this like Hamels
quote unquote right we no
panels no welcome packs and
all these other events
we've gone too and I think
with the transition back
into us being there on the
show floor I think you will
see things of like a this
is a pain all right you can
go to this you can tune in
online. But this isn't
going to be your prime time
slot where you have to be
there I think that will
definitely be a good one is
right with the wording
blast but for me I'd
actually go on the flip
side and say Hey let's find
a way to work with Jeff
Healey you know I think we
have this weird delineation
of Summer Games fast and we
have E3 and I think he did
a great job like kicking
off the weekend they make
you feel like this big
thing. But then there's
like this hard line of
like- that's not part of us
right we're a whole
different thing then we
started to see overlap of
like Hey there's a couple
in the conferences that
could have been the same as
this in the conference and
now they started to get
model down you see the same
game over and over it
almost becomes a meme and I
think Abingdon Jeff in his
you know. Expertise and
what he can bring to
elevate your presentation
and your van it would be
really good for them and
expressly a team with the
ASA loves you know taking a
lot of negative feedback is
try to figure out that
criticism to make the best
look to Jeff and see if you
guys can work together
because I think he does a
really good job and I'd
like to see that more clear
in the. Cohesive as one
unit. Yeah like this one is
a- of. I mean the- and- I.
Him as like pretending.
Does exist. Jeff what you
reckon yeah I think that
many of that- keep. Now I
definitely agree with what-
bless Mike said it you know.
View yet to deny it like-
you know Keely sort of
existence is sort of crazy
and I think a lot of people
already conflate- this
being that he does with the
three as well so they're
sort of they're they're
just kind of. Not really
figuring out the right way
to acknowledge that and
sort of mesh it all
together I think the ESA
definitely needs to learn-
from this sort of. You know
unique E3 in in ways of
organization- just- sort of
echo- what blessings saying
you know there's a lot that
we did not know till the
very sort of last minute.
Felt like a lot of things
were just sort of coming
together in a way that you
know you look it can right
we can get away with that
sort of you know
planetesimals because of
the situation we're all in
but- at the same time you
know it's gonna take a lot
of. Messaging and sort of
righting the ship in that
regard I think listening to
press and journalists to
have these not so great
experiences with the things
that with the tools that
the is a sort of put out
there and- and what that is
like in. You know in and
how- and how to make that
better. Ears up a little
bit in hearing what people
have to say about that
entire experience- book I
realize you know there's
still you know bills that
need to be paid and you
know that you're not going
to get away with. Maybe
having to have you know
Verizon spend a lot of
money on the thing. And I
don't claim to have the
answers of how you make
that work it's- I do not
envy the people who have
that as their task- but
it's just something that is
continually gonna have to
be figured out and- you
know it will look a lot
different next year- I can
I can almost guarantee you
that but- where the where
the gradual changes come. I
think- are going to be the
most important. Well that's
thank you so much for your
insight it was super
valuable and I've enjoyed
talking to you a lot about
games. Mr can a sap- thank
you to everyone watching
we're gonna kick it back
over to the desk now. Thank
everyone I. Thank you to
snow bike might.
Jeff Bakalar and blessing
for joining us on the
stream is a lot of fun
trying to them now. Sadly
our time is coming to an
end who this is the last
segment of all the live
show. For the weeks that
we've been at a- I we're
going to go I was most E3
is due by presenting some
awards. You know these are
awards that we've thrown
together very quickly but
we feel like they're a good
representation of E3 we
want to award. The highs
and lows all of all of the
week so far- so how this is
gonna work is I'm gonna
read out the category. I
have a short discussion
about what that means. And
then michael highgam hime
is- is gonna is gonna read
out. The winner. We haven't
nominees every time
nominees it's gonna it's
going to give it. Now you
might be asking how in
depth have we gone with
these awards have we
printed them out have we-
forge them into using three
D. printers. Like we have
been previous yes but gamer
the able get awards made
and give it to the
developers. And what I can
tell you is. Ladies and
gentlemen we haven't done
any of that because- lazy
as hell that's how we roll
we opened up a Google doc
we came up with some
awards. And then we assign
them the women and by we I
mean me I did it. And
everyone else went that
that works and now we're
going to give a great
michael highgam and I made
suggestions to. Our I said
I said I said to together
yes so I the- I'm gonna
read them out. And then-
all the bad awards off from
me all the good actual good
awards all from Lucy and
michael highgam- because
that's how we balance each
other out- three years.
Yeah yeah the first award
category is the most K. all
a game all of this show on.
Lucy what what games do you
we think of what is K. EIC
mean to you. K- six to me
is- an energy it's a way of
life. It's something that
goes against the grain you
know and so when it came
time to discuss this awards.
Many games of chaotic
aspects but really only
one. Click away it took the
element of chaos and really
just became 1 with it yeah
J. to kind of bring up some
of the potential we had
battlefield the new
battlefield was shown and
that is an extremely K.
alright game. You the
explosions there's a sand
storm that rolls fruit a
and mac one point there's a
harder cane that rolls
through at one point. Eight
absolutely wild- another
chaotic game that was shown
during the actual- showcase
Mario Rabbids those.
Rabbits known for their
chaos- so another big bacon
that. But that could only
be one and michael highgam
are you ready to reveal
what them big chaotic the
most chaotic game on the
show was I gotcha all right
so most chaotic game of the
show award goes to.
Stranger in paradise final
fantasy origins. Origins of
course no other game wants
you to once you take take
take chaos to another level
quite like that when you
know it's not even just
like it's not even just
about like killing chaos
fighting chaos becoming
chaos. That demo that drop
created chaos because it
took twenty four hours more
than twenty four hours for
anyone to actually play it
was just up to you stranger
paradise they are no
stranger to chaos. Well do
you know what I mean your
paradises like maybe the
office of chaos because you
are that to kill chaos so
maybe if anything it's
orderly. I understand this
obsession with chaos hi. I
don't understand where it's
gonna go I wouldn't be
surprised if the like.
Mission chaos well why not.
The next award is the least
necessary showcase award
what does this mean I think
you know it means everyone
this means. Everyone knows
when you're all logged
because you look at the
schedule and it says
showcase name of company
showcasing you're like oh
boy this is going to be
interesting there's gonna
be some game show there's
gonna be some costar Sean
and the recent news and-
then you can feel yourself
aging you can feel
yourself. That time fox is
like it's like washing over
you like your body's going
is deteriorating as the as
the- showcases happening
law of contenders for that
this year there were quite
a few. We had. Many many
many of them Lucy with the
cold describe mythical yet
can you describe the
feeling that you feel when
you go into one of these
showcase and you. Suddenly
realize that it's a it's a
at one of the least
necessary showcases. Well I
mean first does the is the
disappointment right
because you know the news
team is prepped to take a
new stories and write them
up the video team is
practically about videos to
post- to cite you cheapen
social and then we are all
here like making notes
ready for our reactions.
And then you just get a
damp squib of a press
conference press
conference- and it's
disappointing but also a
lot of them sometimes just
a bit like- he did that huh.
In. There was a lot of them
you mentioned- mythical on
that. Yeah Capcom Capcom
rolling out being like
kissing games thought you
know I'll Ole we'll be
coming out like in about
ten minutes- I'm ever and
then they'll EIC also
resident evil village DLC
is happening but that can
only be one winner.
Michael highgam are can
there only be one winner.
That is not true because we
have two winners for least
necessary showcase award at
E3 twenty twenty one it is
a tie between Gearbox and
Bandai Namco
congradulations played
yourself. You play the sun
you wasted our time well
done. These kind of like-
front runners for different
reasons I guess the Gearbox
want they had a lot of
things that. We were
interested in but they gave
us nothing all of nothing
of value for those. He
three times did you know
that whole world one one
year back in two thousand
three overall three coming
soon. Like I guess I guess
type deal. 1 Amanda it has
the same trailer that we
saw earlier in the week as
a matter Kevin Hart in with
Randy Pitchford now yeah
Karen Hodges given just
absolutely not a high 5 and
Randy Pitchford one bit
Randy Pitchford walking
around an empty warehouse.
Just being like this is
where the movies being made.
They gonna show us the cost
you maybe no help and then
of course Bandai Namco
devoted their entire
showcase to one game. Which
made me how that looks has.
Yeah house of Russia's does
look cool could be an
interesting game but the
epitome of should have been
an email just to stick a
link Hey but they've got a
round about it they have us
talking about it so maybe
who's so maybe we don't let
ourselves. Yeah use the
religious half. From this
point on we're gonna get
very specific. Our next
category is the best use of
zoom award what does this
mean. I don't know I got
close I just wrote the best
use of zoom because there's
one there's one showcase
that happened which was. It
wasn't a showcase of games
it was a showcase of video
conferencing tools.
Michael highgam what is the
what is the winner of this
award. And best use of zoom
award goes to. Kok media
Koch media ya can't even
get your own name straight
how you'd probably that's
the problem is the pro what
worst worst use of a
company name I would guess
I you know I'm giving out
awards to **** crash. I
don't know whatever you
want to be is. Still shots
of the- I don't know well.
This this your status.
Where it was just. I felt
like it gonna do me the
entire time for us day.
Again they were just like
throw from person the other
interview and I was. They
played extreme loud label.
The show video the star the
hop I think during the
CUNY's. And it was the
loudest trailer of the
show- but yeah and then the
other thing they did is one
of my favorite things was
watching the kind of funny
that like- free show for
this and they were like
Hey. No matter what happens
we'll get a definitive
answer on how to pronounce
the name of the company and
then they proceeded to
pronounce it in four
different ways during the
showcase. And then it comes
back to that kind of funny
right now like. God you
truly hate this. Well done
to them. Biggest flex
award. Now this is.
Obviously easy you know
exactly which means this is
a game a company coming out
there. Just ripping the
show off and just- while.
Love well product just look
at this rippling. With oil
not for this lots of
potential death we had. We
had professor showing off
starfield. We had. Nintendo
Lucy can you think of any
flexes that you think might
be contenders for this- no
you said Nintendo and that
was going to be yeah but
what you could do. So much
in there Maitreyi should
gone with trade that was
the way he said Nintendo
like an umbrella term
monthly I got because it at
Square Enix is guardians
looking good. That was that
was a good one actually
works York Smith Rocksmith
plus. All relax- and now to
say something but we'll
save for the for a leader
award actually. Okay okay
michael highgam will you
please reveal the biggest
flex award all right so the
biggest flex they came out
and said it with their
chest. We're giving it to
specifically Xbox GamePass
baby every single thing
revealed you know what all
the sick **** game that you
want to play right now it's
working day one you'll be
able to play on Xbox
GamePass your subscriber.
Don't trips talking to you
all played out for the rise
Bungie will play a little
campaign one play that go
beyond GamePass. I also
like the game of the year
twenty twenty is also on
GamePass now Yuccas elected
drag. I got to tell me tell
me that's not the biggest
flex the shop right there
you know I'm saying why
custody should be. Coming
through shirtless boy let's
get. Do we give yet twenty.
I did. That's all matters
no we gave it to. Get up
about. Give me that's
unfortunately no on
GamePass suddenly- yeah
microsoft out here like
Oprah just given games to
everyone for free- you I
truly love to see it next
category we have is the
only ship what is this
award and- that is every
anytime you say it has to
be said about holy ****
what is this and that is
something that caught you
by surprise something that
you did not expect and it
has blown you away Lucy is
there anything that sticks
out in your mind as doing
that- and plus all
Rocksmith. Plus get news in
an apt now- are you think
read full to death means
sending- I also think-
merry plus rapids- huh let
me see I think- holy ****
what is this- me
blessing Adeoye what's-
this game was released
during show your Nintendo
is press conference and
that is the game that
you're trying to think of
right now yeah. Yeah that
was specific well this'll
work will get will we're
going toward my personal
game the show will that
laid out so I'll save it
for and then but- if we
want to know. If you all
want to know what the holy
**** what is this award for
E3 twenty twenty one it is
replaced. Tell us about him.
Replaced it was shown
during the Xbox press
conference and it is one of
the coolest looking game
Stephanie does a lot of
indie games this year. I
think that's one of the
side effects all of having
last. Played you know
developers and publishers
eating up all the air- you
know the- the Indies really
got the- chance to. Yes
some breathing room and
they were everywhere on big
showcases like microsoft.
And even in their own ones
and the price was one of
the coolest looking ones I
called granny explained why
looks like quite a striking
all style has. You know
quickly become the talk of
Twitter and its wayfinding
that the trailer- on a you
tube and check them out
because. It is real real
cool. I the next one is the-
global war which means a
game that might have been
shown nvidia. In the year
or previous yes the house-
repaired and is looking
fine as hell. A lot of
opportunities that but-
we're going to speed things
up because I have quickly
started to lose my voice-
and what's going to because
I had. Michael highgam
print. Whoa whoa are you
all y'all okay yeah- nvidia.
Stuff michael highgam off
the streets is that the
three can you reveal the
game that won the biggest
global war. End the biggest
global awarded E3 twenty
twenty one goes to. Halo in
finance because and you
were looking for fine right
now- that lighting textures
the fax floating through
space in for Spartan armor
school boy Hey low end is
look and write. Hello hit
the gym hello when how and
so our stylist hello you
know put in the work you
know did some light because
Medicare came back and he's
looking irresistible
currently. Fiftieth the
trailer the next category
is the most explosions E3
twenty twenty one awards
Lucy. Do you think there's
a threshold for explosions
is there such thing as too
many explosions trailer. No
I think I think we are long
past the limit of too many
explosions and trailer they
just have to be good ones
you know they have to the
of different sizes-
different sounds. You think
they can never be too many
explosions. Yeah and there
certainly was one game
which had a different kinds
of explosions small ones
big ones- multiplexed
lotions next to each other
explosions within
explosions it was wild-
michael highgam can you
reveal the winner of the
most explosions of E3
twenty twenty one award.
Absolutely the most
explosions of E3 goes to.
Battlefield twenty forty
two because it's not just
grenades and missiles and
guns popping off climate
change is also exploring
and battlefield
214-214-0220 forty two. Boy
there are tornadoes
sandstorms all kinds of
things you'll you'll you'll
want to listen the roots
answer can you turn that up
you play Balfe battlefield.
Less edit and- then. What
the CMX award I've been
I've been told in my ear
that we are taking far too
long with this award
ceremony so we need. To
speed up I'm by told in my
area I mean I read it and
try- because I don't it was
just normal headphones no
we can actually talk to me
for these so- the mirror
magic is broken that. The
next award is busy one
hundred two zero real quick
award. Michael highgam what
does this mean. And who is.
Sold if you watch the
official coverage of E3
twenty twenty one there was
one idiot onstage was
hyping up this game. Who
stormed the stage in front
of Greg Miller and golden
boy and Jacki Jing and
said. That this was going
to be game of the show. So
his dumbass look like a
dumbass so. One hundred to
zero real quick. Or goes to
Babylon's fall and
goddammit I was so sad to
find out that a game that
was that was involved the
creators of mere automata
are making a live service
Gaming platinum games is
doing- an endless game that
looks like it has almost no
story F. breaks my heart.
The ATC. We Gaming our
reactions when that happens
because times faced
literally did the Ralph
Wiggum you can see where's
heartbreaks and they said
it was a live set remember
how scream of pain because
I was like no. This next
award we're gonna start
switching things up and I'm
going to PC to read the
winner of this and also
speak to the actual winner
this is the Microport. And
sounds it's a is the moment
where someone drops the
might and just walks out
and because- you know you
want ready for that and now
it's going to change your
life so. PC can you one of
the Microport. For twenty
twenty five. The wind is
Xbox for the read full
review. Okay we would like
we with that- doing a pre
show when Eldon. When
starfield leads and we were
like oh my god this Xbox is
big you get an ounce from
the showcase and gone like
the trailer is off we can
watch it right now- watch
it live on stream- into
like all is this does this
mean there are no surprises
left Xbox no Akane was
there to save the day and
closed the store and
everyone is super excited
about right. Voided they-
the next award I will be
presenting and is. The
hottest E3 host award.
There is I have been
watching and I could only
ready tell you all 1 E3
house that caught my eye
and made me feel feelings I
was not ready for. Of
course I am talking about
the one the only Michael hi
am he caught it. My mom.
Looking as help did you
guys see him he was looking
Chris. At first in. First
off I just want to thank
god I wanna thank my mom-
maybe my dad I don't know-
I would also want to thank
you all my fans out there
for supporting me and- you
know making sure I was
crispy soul while I really
appreciate this work and I
won't disappoint you next
year because you put your
boy's gonna consult goalie
only up from here John Sam.
Yep love seeing this next
award a slightly risque and
we call on me I'm not sure
if we can now we can't we
can't let's just talk about
it to add the conversation
that's where the
conversation happens and
when there's a press
conference happening that
is where you go to get
common trick so you see
some absolute bangers
tweets. What they can only
be there's usually only one
defining tweet all of. The
E3 period. And this year.
Who did that come from
Michael hi am. I know this
the best tweet of the show
goes to our good home girl
Linda Garcia yellow you.
And she said you know this.
Absolutely **** on main-
Garcia who truly an
inspiration it was a screen
cap of 1 Yousef Majeed a
good friend of ours as well
and she said I can't
believe I get to sit on
this space wow wow wow wow.
Truly Yousef and Belinda
are true inspirations to us
all oh my god if you saw
yourself on the Ubisoft
Ford stream. Look at nice
hole we was looking at.
Your love love it yep yep
Lucy. The water is the best
quote tweet of the show can
you tell us the winner for
best quote tweet of the
show and also the context
around this. This quote
three of the show close to
a good friend you Stephanie.
Belinda's tweet amongst the
Batman discourse he quote
tweeted Belinda's dream to
say who's the real hero now
how about. Being PC
indicated that. Superheroes
don't performs certain
actions to satisfy their
partners and- you know new
heroes emerged during this
period and one of them was
our very own Yusif Makki a
true true hero. I'm next is
the hottest protagonist
award lohas pro tags law of
help protect but this this
award could only go to 1
pro tag michael highgam who
is. The hottest
protagonists revealed that
E3 twenty twenty one was
not Stevie class to be
clear that protect us was
not revealing anything it
was just dollars sure yeah
this protagonizado Pataki
it wasn't like naked
protagonist revealed.
Assert EA date thank you
first for setting up but
the award for hottest
protagonist goes to the
shin Megami Tensei 5
protagonist. Their name is
pro tag holy **** you saw
as far as revealed the
protagonist transforms into
the sickest looking. And
I've ever seen in a video
game oh my god S. and T.
has the group best
eyelashes- and the best
eyeliner but yo the
transformation the outfit
the laser store on the long
flowing blue hair. Home god
S. and P. five love to see.
Given the- like our count
on time on the screen was
literally all read two
minutes wrapped please.
Okay the speed. We're gonna
wrap this up real quick now
we've got hot expanded the
show the award goes to
parris lilly put and call
call cook on his custom
Xbox controller the MVP
award goes to Jean-Luc site
key our very own gag dies
who has been who has been
absent in the killing and
the back and- best. Award
goes to GameSpot dot com.
Interesting great pic
though and then finally.
The V. cover eighty games
for game of the show as
unilaterally decided b
tamoor hussein goeso
Alvin ring. You ve to e
it the gamer. During well I
pick by games little
thought Razer j given
thought not jobsood. And
that's the show for this
year thank you to every
puts in and we're be back
next week with charity
streams that's going to be
many of them please tune
in we're gng to be
raising money for able
gamers and we've got a
whole bch of cool g and
it's gna be fun so make
sure you tune in R.everyoneo
the chats. 5 thank you forje
you next week.